thank you
order a lot
thank you
the public order emergency commission is
now in session
I apologize for the slight delay
okay morning commissioner Jeffrey Leon
co-lead commission Council the next
witness will be Keith Wilson
Mr Wilson will you swear on a religious
document or do you wish to affirm I'll
swear on the Bible
[Music]
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Ian Keith Wilson
w-i-l-s-o-n
do you swear that the evidence
I do
good morning Mr Wilson good morning
um I'd like to begin by getting some
information on your background I
understand you're from Edmonton Alberta
that's right I'm originally from
Burlington Ontario spent first part of
my life here in Ontario and the balance
of my life out west
you and I did it the opposite ways
um and uh you practice Law in Edmonton
that's correct uh for how long I think
I'm 27 28 years at the bar now and
you're a king's Council that's correct
and can you describe for the commission
the nature of your practice
um I've typically throughout the course
of my career
dealt with
um people who are up against bigger
forces than them uh I have represented
many landowners and farmers and ranchers
in Alberta and disputes with oil
companies
but I've also
um much of my practice has been focused
on
helping people when governments in their
mind has gone too far affecting their
life or their business or their
livelihood and so I've done a lot of
judicial review and administrative law
and tribunal work
thank you and um have you uh I take it
you've appeared before all levels of
Alberta courts and many regulatory
tribunals that's right
and can I ask the clerk to bring up WTS
6058
you attended an interview with me and my
colleagues on October 2022. that's
correct and you were provided with a
draft summary that was prepared by a
commission Council
that's right and you had an opportunity
to review that summary comment on it and
then you were provided with a an amended
version which you also reviewed that's
right
and
I'm showing you on the screen uh what
we've uh uh
an interview summary uh you recognize
this as your interview summary I do and
do you have any changes or Corrections
uh you want to make this morning no
other than as we've heard from so many
witnesses there were so many events
occurring and it was some time ago but
to the best of my recollection this is
accurate thank you I can just interrupt
you have a tendency to speak rapidly so
if you could try and moderate it that
would be helpful it's
for the interpreters obviously thank you
commissioner
and I'll uh
be referring to your interview summary
from time to time but if at any time you
need to refer to it you just let me know
when we can bring it up thank you
now I'd like to ask you some questions
about how you became involved with the
freedom Convoy I understand that you
were contacted by the Justice Center for
constitutional freedoms on February 1
2022 yes and at that time you were
acting on another matter through the
jccf that's that's correct and uh what
was that retainer
the what happened was uh in the fall of
2021
my wife who is a retired nurse
um we've been married forever and have
four kids
and she became very concerned about what
she was seeing in terms of government
policy Health policy
felt that things were badly going awry
and she
did something she's never done before
where she encouraged me to get involved
and take a case she's normally the
gatekeeper because I tend to take too
many cases
and
um Miss chippyek who had practiced law
with in the past and other cases
approached me and asked me if I'd be
willing to take a case at the Justice
Center they needed senior litigation
counsel I agreed I uh they told me I
could pick whichever case I would like
and I wanted to I'd been studying the
travel mandates and I thought they were
Ultra viries the Aeronautics act and I
wanted and obviously breaching Charter
and so I agreed to lead that case with
former Premier Brian packford as our
lead applicant
and that case is still going on uh we
just got struck on mootiness and we're
appealing that to the federal court of
appeal when was that
we got struck uh not last Thursday the
Thursday before while I was here
and then that led to
um
um on the 1st of February
um I had a t a legal team meeting set up
noticed some extra people in the the
zoom room and let them in and I was
informed by one of the lawyers who had
met for the first time on that Zoom call
that the truckers in Ottawa that morning
had reached out to the Justice Center
and asked the Justice Center if they
would provide legal support
the lawyers on the call told me that
they'd assembled the team and they'd
asked me if I would come to Ottawa the
next morning and Lead that team
and I agreed
were able to clear your schedule that
quickly
well I got a spousal consent very
quickly so that helped tremendously and
um
uh yeah I was you know you say there was
a team of
four lawyers I believe in your statement
that's right and who was on that team I
have a chipyak yes uh Andre muirmer
um Tim turple and Allison Petrovic
and had you been following the news
about uh what was happening in Ottawa
yeah I was very fascinated with how the
Convoy started to form
uh I took I was amazed at the rate at
which
um the donations were coming in just
just from following social media and and
the Legacy Media as well
and I thought I want to really keep on
this is prior to February 1st of course
and I thought well I really want to keep
an eye on this and and I realized
probably the easiest way to do that
would to be make a nominal donation and
then I would get the email updates so I
donated 15 a little embarrassed about
that but just for the purpose of
tracking and getting the regular email
updates I had no idea that a few days
after I made that donation that I would
be in downtown Ottawa
and uh on a personal level did you have
a view of what was happening in Ottawa
well I had a view I think there's two
questions there
um obviously I had grave concerns about
the government's policies and the harm
that I'd witnessed in my own family with
our children with my neighbors with my
friends with my colleagues
so in that context I have a very strong
view that I think tremendous mistakes
were made at a policy level
but with respect to the Convoy
I felt that it was
providing an opportunity for people who
are also concerned
to symbolize that concern and
demonstrate it
and at that point in time what did you
understand your retainer to be
my instructions were to
um
work with the leadership group to
provide on the ground legal support one
of the things that we thought we would
likely be doing which we'd end up having
to do was to obtain an injunction we
anticipated that we would have to defend
injunctions provide legal advice as to
the types of activities that they're
allowed to do and the things they're not
allowed to do
also it was clear at that time if you
recall I apologize if I'm talking too
fast against her
um
if you recall that around that time
GoFundMe had publicly announced the
suspension of the fundraising campaign
I was also told at the time of being
engaged
that work was underway to set up a
not-for-profit corporation Canada Corp
to ensure a proper organizational
structure for the administration of the
donations
something else that I've done in my
background that proved to be extremely
useful
not only in Ottawa but in the events
since as I've represented
um not-for-profit groups
and I've represented various industry
organizations so I've dealt with
conflicts and strong personalities on
Boards of directors
and seeing the the interpersonal
quarrels that can arise
and some of the groups that I've
represented have been comprised of
independent ranchers and upon arriving
in Ottawa I immediately realized this
personality similarities between
independent Alberta ranchers and
independent Truckers
so that's some context okay so the the
next day February 2nd uh you went to
Ottawa and I understand you went on a
private aircraft yes it was a small
bumpy
um I forget the name of it but it's a
twin prop and uh we left at 8 A.M
uh on we left at 8 A.M
on that February 2nd
and we um uh we we landed in Ottawa at
about 10 30.
so uh it was not a luxury experience we
went up and down many times we stopped
in Medicine Hat
we stopped in Regina
uh
um Saskatoon
uh Winnipeg and then Thunder Bay all the
stops were to pick up additional lawyers
and the accountant or the last one to
get fuel now at the time did you
consider or did you wonder
given the nature of your retainer
while you're being flown on a private
aircraft
because at that time the understanding
of the
interim orders under the Aeronautics Act
is that it did not extend to private
Charter aircraft and some of the
passengers on that aircraft were
unvaccinated so that was a way for us to
get to Ottawa quickly under the interim
order
and uh did you know at the time who was
paying for the aircraft
um there was
uh there was confusion about that in the
same way that there was confusion about
there was two other groups that had
allegedly made arrangements for us to
have hotel rooms when we arrived and so
the Justice Center made up made a backup
plan to have a third Hotel ready and
that's the one we ended up using
um as we were boarding the plane
whoever was supposedly going to be
paying for this Charter turned out they
weren't going to pay for the charter
and the Justice Center made the decision
to send us anyway and if necessary they
would pay for the charter if whoever was
going who originally said they were
going to pay for it didn't and do you
know who ultimately paid for the charter
I believe it was alt and I'm not certain
about this but I believe it was paid
from funds donated through Chris
guerra's adopt a trucker
okay
now um
you heard yesterday uh Mills belt Miss
belton's evidence about a conversation
she had with you regarding disclosure of
of this flight
disclosure of sorry information about
this flight
okay
um
I believe she said you she was told not
to say anything about it no that's not
correct what what what do you have to
say about that I had no discussion with
Miss Belton about this flight I had no
concerns about the flight I'm double
vaccinated it wouldn't have mattered
what aircraft I was on
okay now I'd like to just uh pause here
for a moment I know that uh this point
you're acting uh as a a lawyer and to
the extent that any of my questions uh
would require you to disclose privileged
information where privilege has not been
waived would you tell me and and not
answer I will and just so uh everyone's
clear I do
um in July my clients instructed me to
make myself to consider making myself
available as a witness
and granted a waiver with respect to
these matters this proceeding and we've
subsequently confirmed it in writing to
avoid any confusion that I am here today
with a waiver from my clients with
respect to solicitor client privilege
and when you say your clients who did
you include in the uh the clients
include Freedom Corp so the that's their
short name for
um the full legal name of the
not-for-profit
uh it includes
um Tamara Leach Chris Barber
Danny bulford
um Tom marazzo
Sean Thiessen Thiessen
Miranda gracer
Joe Jantz
Dale ends
and Ryan mahilwich and I believe that's
the full list
I I understand that during the the
period we're about to talk to you were
also dealing with
Chad Eros that's correct was he part of
your your client group he was offered an
opportunity to become a client and did
not sign a retainer agreement
well um my understanding is he
his position is he was a client and that
he has not waived privilege
um
that's fine and out in abundance of
caution I we can respect that I do
um know that
the absence of a retainer was confirmed
by him in writing so
to me
and if at any time you're in doubt about
privilege and you need time to consult
with Mr Miller you'll just let me know
yes sir I absolutely will thank you
you know so you arrived in Ottawa then
with the the group on in the evening of
February 2nd
that's correct and um understand you uh
rented a car and went to the ark Hotel
yeah there was uh I was in a taxi with
Dwayne and I can't recall specifically
who else was with me
um and then the others rented a car so
there was we we had two modes of getting
there and uh the decision was to get me
and Dwayne downtown as quick as possible
because we had so little time to deal
with whatever we anticipated coming
while we were on the plane
we received a briefing on and reviewed
the emails from GoFundMe which are in in
the record here uh setting out all of
their concerns and then we drafted
during that flight a substantive I think
my letter is four or five pages
addressing each of the issues that
GoFundMe had raised so we were working
on that flight we wanted to get downtown
to meet the clients sign retainer
agreements and brief them and give them
an opportunity to review that letter to
GoFundMe so we could get it to GoFundMe
as soon as possible okay and um
you you went to the arc hotel am I right
that's correct and that's downtown
Ottawa Slater and Metcalf yep the uh the
the vehicle we were in drove right up to
the front door of the hotel just like it
would today
and when you got to the ark Hotel uh
understand you met with Tamara Leach
Chris Barber
and was there anybody else there yeah
Miranda gracer was there
Sean Thiessen was there
and I believe that's it there might have
been one or two other people in the room
but that's the best of my recollection
and had you
met any of these people before no never
had you uh at any time heard about Ms
Leach
yes I heard about her but only in the
context of
um the freedom Convoy I anything else I
learned about Miss Leach
uh I'm pretty sure I Googled her as soon
as I was starting to watch the Convoy
form so this would be in
you know late January
to try and understand who she was but
I've had no prior dealings with her or
awareness of who she was or what she was
engaged in until
um I Googled her
because of the Convoy and um
what time about what time did you arrive
at the hotel
my memory is it was about 11 30 at night
okay
and um
could you tell the commissioner what
happened at that point
in brief sure well I mean first of all
we drove through the downtown so we
could that was my first chance to see
where all the trucks and the protest
Vehicles were and all the signage and
and and and so on
um and how you could still drive around
there was always one lane open that's
how we got right to the hotel
um when I walked into the lobby
I could really feel the tension
um there was truckers everywhere
uh there was supplies stacked and piled
everywhere
um and the the the tension was I could
really feel the tension so can we come
to the the meeting that you had uh uh
with um your perspective at that time
perspective clients and you said you uh
did you finalize your retainer at that
point yes uh Andre mirmer had the
paperwork and uh had um uh had them sign
and did the nature of your retainer
differ from what you told us about what
your understanding was about it
um well and I should clarify one thing
that the way the Justice Center operated
at that time the retainer has their name
on it the Justice Center as the legal
provider
um
uh was the retainer different no no at
the the nature of my anticipated
involvement
uh remained constant
and um I take it you then proceeded to
get to know your clients yeah
um how long did that evening meeting
last you got there at 11 30
um
when did it end uh not that long
everybody was exhausted we had just had
you know
um
landing and taking off several times in
a small aircraft is a little bit hard on
the body and not to mention I had very
very I'm sure all of the people on our
team were the same but this happened so
fast we had very very little sleep
uh we could tell the fatigue and that
was when I first was informed that that
Tamara was was
um aware that some group was calling a
press conference for the next day and
they wanted her to speak
and
I immediately started asking questions
about okay
who's called the press conference what's
its purpose who all speaking
was there a media advisory
she didn't know
you know this is not her world I've
dealt with high profile cases and
communication specialists
extensively so she didn't even know what
immediate advisory was
okay and um
I understand that you uh
wrote out her remarks for her but what
happened was I had no intention of being
in the media I was there to not be in
the media but to provide guidance
and
even in that first meeting I started
hearing these different groups names and
I was okay well who is this group and
why are they here and what this other
group it was it was the chess board was
starting to
the fog was starting to lift and I was
sort of oh boy this is going to get
complicated
um
the major concern I had was
two things Tamara made it clear to me
that she did not feel comfortable
appreciate she's absolutely exhausted
they all where I could see the fatigue
and she didn't feel comfortable being
exposed to a long format
uh press conference where every media
person could come at her basically
and
um
so I was already giving some thought as
to how we could possibly restructure the
the press conference to make it more
orderly and
make it more effective in conveying some
information that I thought
the public and the world wanted to hear
so and and you you did you prepare her
her remarks for her
so
the
um
uh the next morning
my legal team was adamant that I should
take a more active role in the press
conference I was initially reluctant
when we got from our hotel which was out
of the downtown
to the ark and went into one of the
logistics rooms on the main floor it's a
big board room
um
I got more information about the plan
for the press conference
and that was it was going to include a
number of medical doctors and so my
question was just whether you prepared
her remarks Tamara lich's Mark remarks
for her there was take back our freedoms
had a uh external communication
consulting firm that had prepared a
speech for her
um a number of us including Tamara Beach
reviewed it
did not like the messaging so uh Miss
chippyick and another individual a
medical doctor rewrote it
um it still wasn't in Miss Leach's voice
so I assisted Miss Leach in revising
that statement
and it was finalized in very short order
because we only had less than an hour
and then she proceeded to the press
conference to deliver it
and Mr clerk can I ask you to to bring
up jcf
five zeros one five five it's a
video
and I just like to play one minute from
that good afternoon
and thank you for coming
my name is Keith Wilson I'm a lawyer
with the Justice Center for
constitutional freedoms as some of you
may know there was an announcement
earlier today that the Justice Center
and a team of lawyers are here on the
ground in Ottawa
to assist the truckers and the freedom
Convoy 2022
with whatever legal needs they might
have
what we're going to do today in this
brief press conference
is you're going to hear from Tamara
gleach
who we all know is the spark that Lit
this fire and the leader of this
organization
you're also going to hear from Johnny
pelche who is going to summarize in
French
what Tamara says
you say that Ms Leach was the spark that
Lit this fire who told you that uh that
no one told me that where how did where
did it come from my brain okay
and how did you your brain figure that
out
well I observed what was happening and I
noticed that
um
this is again prior to me being engaged
that she seemed to be the organic leader
she was the one that was doing the
Facebook's lives and other videos she
was the one who was sending out the
message
and she seemed to have the personality
of a natural leader that
inspired others to get behind her thank
you now can you bring up
Mr Clerk hrf40139
and uh
this is
um
a
letter to GoFundMe that I think
dated February 3rd and that's the letter
you told us was drafted on the on the
plane correct that's correct
um
and um
just if you can scroll up please um
a little more
you um
you note at the the bottom there you set
out your understanding of the evolving
goals of
the committee's GoFundMe campaign
yes and if you can just scroll up I
won't uh
read them but those are but that's what
you understood to be the uh the goals
one moment
yes
um
and
if you can just scroll up a little more
stop there the paragraph beginning
everyone has been surprised
you say the last sentence there the
truckers have been open with the media
that they are not leaving until the
government vaccine mandates are lifted
um who on the plane uh provided that
information
um I think it might have been
either in some of the drafts that Mr EOS
Eros had prepared and understand that
we did a draft on the plane
so that would have been the
um
is that the Wednesday night
um anyway the February 2nd then we had
the letter reviewed by
um
the clients
and then the letter the next morning was
reviewed by the finance committee back
in Alberta
and a number of people requested as
normally occurs if you circulate a draft
that words and sentences be added so I
don't know exactly whether that arose in
the very first draft or whether that was
something
that some of the leaders in Ottawa had
added or whether that was something that
the finance committee wanted at it and
can you just scroll up a little more
please
you note in the second bolded paragraphs
that the um the intention is not to
reimburse those for those committing
unlawful Acts or criminal acts and you
say the Convoy has been clear it only
supports peaceful assembly at this point
in time I take it you were aware that
there were some officials that are were
suggesting that some of the conduct
going on was unlawful
um yeah and I've heard that a lot and uh
what I've always struggled with is at
what point in time
did those officials believe it became an
unlawful assembly and on what basis
because it just seemed to be a
terminology that started to morph and
become adopted with no particular
triggering event or explanation as to
what that individual or official thought
constituted an unlawful assembly
and later that day you attended a phone
meeting with GoFundMe that's correct and
among other people that would have been
on the sorry that would have been on the
Thursday afternoon yeah and among other
people Mr Eris was on that call yeah all
of the lawyers that were with me
um and a number of the board members
from Freedom Corp were there as well as
Miss Leach and um
there Mr Claire can you bring up WTS six
zeros
uh 32 and go to page eight
um this is uh a witness statement
provided by by Chad Eros
and he made certain statements in there
and I want to give you an opportunity to
to respond sure on page eight um
he says that the
if you can scroll up
a little more please
I'm not seeing it right now but it he
does say that
um
he
the jccf lawyers and specifically you
were trying to take over the meeting and
assert themselves of the spokespeople
on the financial side of the Convoy do
you remember reading that
um
I don't remember reading that right
there and where it says Mr Wilson
trying to take over the meeting
all I want to know is whether you want
to respond to that
well I mean what does that mean when I I
led the meeting someone needs to lead a
meeting
uh from when you have two parties uh Mr
Hero spoke other lawyers spoke
uh Mr ero spoke extensively in
explaining to the GoFundMe Executives
and their legal team because we was uh I
would estimate by memory
there was 10 to 12 people from GoFundMe
on the other side of the conference call
this was a call not a zoo yeah and you
mentioned sorry and
um uh we relied heavily at least our
side on Mr Eros explaining the financial
controls and who he was in his
background in banking and as a CPA
and his role as treasurer
um but yes I did lead the discussion
that is true
and I understand as well that um
you had some discussions with Mr Eros
about the organization Tate back our
freedoms yes
um and uh
did Ms Leach have some concerns about
that organization yes and what were
those concerns
um
my memory is
as I indicated in my witness statement
and it wasn't just take back our
freedoms this was happening extensively
and it happened immediately or I
observed it immediately after the first
day when I actually started to
you know appreciate I'm coming in at
night and go through the lobby and up to
a a hotel room and then back out the
next day I'm now starting to interact
more and I'm now in a big boardroom and
there's these different people coming
and going and I'm trying to figure out
who's who
um you know there was no organization
chart there was no introduction session
it's not even like a meeting where you
go around the table and introduce one
another that didn't happen it was
constant chaos
so I learned
that there was a group and then I
learned it was this tbof I didn't even
know what
tbof meant initially and then I'd heard
about this Canada Unity
and then there was Mr borgel's group
something for Freedom then there was
Veterans for Frida I could go on there
were so many different groups I was
starting to learn of
and what I observed was that
different groups were trying to take
certain
try to take control
and
what I observed and believed to be true
is that some were trying to take control
because they saw the organic
flat hierarchy
largely of the Convoy
and wanted to make it more successful
and felt they had the organizational
capability to do that
other groups seem to want to reshape the
freedom Convoy into
their own event
branded theirs and I got the distinct
impression from some others that they
were trying to get their hands on what
at that point was 10 million dollars in
donations
and my impression and my recollection
from the discussions that I would have
with Miss Leach as various people would
demand private meetings
or
you know play games and say we weren't
allowed to use the boardroom because it
was their Board Room those sorts of
things
uh that she was
under pressure from a lot of these
different groups for the reasons I've
given okay and um
coming back to take back our freedoms um
am I correct that uh Mr peckford was the
the chairman of that organization yeah
and it's interesting because he's more
of a symbolic chairman in all of my
discussions with uh with uh The
Honorable Brian peckford I would speak
with him
um
not every evening but you know maybe
every second or third evening my
telephone logs confirm that that I've
tendered in evidence
and I was looking for guidance from him
he was you know he's an elder Statesman
he's been through a lot he's one of
their founding fathers of our our
Charter of Rights and Freedoms very
seasoned politician
and so at no time did we ever have any
discussion
around
uh take back our freedoms was did I feel
he was speaking on their behalf uh him
and I become somewhat close through my
work on his Federal travel mandate
Charter challenge in federal court
and I was using him as a resource and
and someone to
to run ideas past and get guidance from
and am I correct that you were aware
that at least Mr Eros had some concern
that if there were concerns about take
back our freedoms
and you were acting
on behalf of Mr Beckford in that other
litigation that you were in a conflict
of interest position that was never
raised at any time
I don't feel I was in a conflict because
at no time did Mr peckford ever ask of
anything of me I was the only one who
asked of things from him
um and
uh
the the
um
the concerns that you're referring to
are concerns that were never aired at
any time during Ottawa by Mr Eros and
only some months later after the Ottawa
protest had concluded okay thank you and
just to shift a little bit here
um
you went are you were staying at the Art
Hotel is that no where were you staying
at a at a Best Western
I believe it was in it was about a
20-minute Drive
um towards the east
so you arrived there excuse me on
February 20 minute drive from downtown
so each day it took us 20 minutes to
to get into the downtown core and so you
arrived there on did you stay there the
night of February 2nd that's correct and
um when did you leave
um our stay there ended
um
it would have been approximately
around
the Sunday of
try to visualize a calendar here
uh the Second Sunday would have been
anyway it was I think we stayed there
for about 10 days and then where did you
go uh then we went to the Swiss Hotel
and how long did you stay there we
stayed there until the Wednesday
which would have been the
um
16th
uh it was on the Wednesday that it was
apparent
this was when we
I had had the phone call from
Steve K city manager
advising me that the third attempt to
move trucks was going to be unsuccessful
and he was very disappointed as he
himself testified
here
okay and I was just asking you the date
sir yeah I'm sorry I'm trying to
contextualize things and I have to
remember things by events because I
wasn't calendar focused
um and so it was that day that it became
apparent
that something dramatic was about to
happen by the government and the police
and as a result
um uh Miss Leach instructed Miss
chippyak and I because we were the only
two lawyers left on the ground at that
point
um to relocate to a new hotel
and where was that La Germaine
and how long did you stay there I stayed
there until the Sunday which would be
the 20th or the 21st
I believe and then did you go back to uh
Edmund I went home yes okay
um
you know did you have interaction During
the period you were there with James
bowder no and if I did
it might have been where I was in a room
or in a hallway or on a sidewalk and he
shook my hand but I met so many people
at the interaction would have been
unremarkable and
um you became aware of his uh or Canada
unity's memorandum of understanding yeah
very early on I was approached by many
people both
um within the client group and others
asking me about it
and um
I I believe uh is it fair to say it was
in in your uh from your perception
getting a lot of attention and you talk
to a lot of people about
yeah they would ask me I didn't make it
a topic that I felt I needed to discuss
with others but I did get asked it a lot
um and what I you know the first thing
that's obvious about it is
a memorandum of understanding in its
simplest legal concept requires all
parties to it to sign
and it was evident that the signature
lines on the last page were not going to
be signed by the governor general nor
nor someone from the Senate and in any
event
um I would explain when I was asked by
the board to brief them on it I
explained and I apologize for my voice
I'm recovering from a cold there's water
there Amina yeah thank you
um
that I explained that there's only two
ways that governments change under our
parliamentary system
the first is when the Prime Minister
contacts the government the governor
general and dissolves Parliament and
asks that the Writ be dropped
the second through parliamentary
tradition is where
um
a bill is identified as a confidence
vote and Parliament votes to defeat the
bill in that second instance the Prime
Minister would similarly contact the
governor general this idea that a
certain number of people
could sign a document
and that would somehow compel or
incentivize and lead to a change in
government I explained consistently and
repeatedly is legal nonsense and
you knew that did you know at the time
that almost uh somewhere around 300 000
people had signed on to a a petition
regarding that I I didn't know the
number I knew that it pre-existed the
Convoy I knew that
Canada Unity pre-existed the Convoy as a
group by at least a year or two that it
was not a creation of the Convoy
it was one of these Hangar ons
so I take it you were
surprised that so many people were
taking it seriously is that fair to say
I am very surprised at this is not the
first time I've run into this I've had
to litigate opposite The Sovereign
citizen folks and
quoting admiralty law and think that if
they present a flag in a certain way in
a court the judge loses jurisdiction
I've had to encounter this many many
times in my career so I was just like
here's another one okay now
um
on
February 4th I understand you were
served with the statement of claim and
an injunction motion by Mr champ that's
correct
and
you represented the
the
Convoy leaders in that uh matter yeah
not everyone who was named at that time
is my memory uh that that pleading has
been amended a number of times and has
is uh evolving document is to be
expected in a litigation of that nature
and um did you oppose the injunction
um
what we did was
um
we
we received it at approximately four
o'clock
uh that was at the same time that we
also received notification publicly that
GoFundMe had
um
determined that the the fundraiser
violated their terms of service and that
they were stopping it and either going
to send the money to some other group or
refund it
we had a lot going on we were served
with a motion record record emergency
motion returnable the Saturday afternoon
at one o'clock
so my legal team and I prepared through
the night
uh through the night Mr champ
uh continued to provide a supplemental
materials in the magnitude of hundreds
of pages
we had everything ready to go
by noonish the next day but not even
enough time for me to read the factum so
I took the did you oppose the the motion
I'm answering your question sir
um we we took the position that it was
just improper for the court to hear it
on the Saturday
we agreed to come back on the Monday
I had informed my clients that there is
no way the court was not going to Grant
the injunction
and that the best we could do
was to ensure that the terms of the
injunction order were not excessive
were not prone to abuse
and arbitrariness
and had an acknowledgment of their right
to protest
so we
um
uh the real argument before the court
was
what is the terms of the order going to
be and get overcoming the challenge of
in-rem versus in-personum orders
thank you
um
now around that same time I understand
from uh your uh your witness your
witness statement that um
you had some discussions with Mr
marazzo about his concerns that there
seemed to be a change in tone in the
response of the uh Ontario Police
Service to the protesters yeah the
Ottawa Police Service that's correct
and um
and I and that that change in tone was
related to
um what uh Mr marazzo saw as a shift
from a uh
a
negotiation type response to a
surgeon-contained enforcement response
is that right precise and um was that
consistent with your view yeah and and
we had uh to the extent we had the
opportunity because as as you can
appreciate it was a very very
fast-moving chaotic environment with so
many
either interpersonal issues arising
between the players or logistical issues
or whatever
um but we did have occasion when we were
mischief and I were leaving our hotel we
worked I must have been the second it
must have been the Monday when we were
in court because we ran those from our
hotel outside of downtown
and um we heard Miss Dean's in an
interview on cbc's as it happens and her
language was deeply troubling
and that combined with Mr marazzo
expressing uh concerns about the change
in tone from Chiefs slowly
um it heightened the urgency of trying
to find a way to open up dialogue and I
had if you if you look at my phone
records you'll see that my first attempt
to um bring in Mr French occurred
actually that weekend
okay and um
what was um
your
your strategy as a result of this well
I've
um
in my past I've been involved in two
International scope crises the first was
the 2003 mad cow
disease outbreak in Alberta where I was
representing a government agency
and the second was in 2009 H1N1 where I
represented the the people who were
patient zero for the zutonic
transmutation
and
so I've been in an Emergency Operations
centers of government on two major
incidences and I've seen the chaos that
occurs in there
and you know I know the importance of
dialogue and communication and I know
the Dane I sense the danger of the
parties not talking even if it's back
channel so I I had a strong desire to
open up back Channel Communications so
we could bring the temperature down
start to see if there's ways to resolve
this de-escalate this wind this thing
down so that was a heavy focus of mine
at all times
okay and I take it that you
contacted Mr peckford and uh asked him
if he had any contacts that might help
yes and then you received a call from
Dean French that's correct and
um
in your statement you indicate that Mr
French
suggested that it would was what was
needed was to move trucks out of the
residential areas is that right yeah he
laid down some ground rules sort of Base
conditions for his willingness to get
involved and try and be intermediary
and so uh we had we had I still remember
and have a chippy it's reminded me of it
that we had a very very intense phone
call
uh where he was testing me and I was
testing him
but what he made absolutely clear
was that
the truckers had to be willing to move
out of the residential areas
and I had to be honest with him about
whether I thought that was achievable
and once he learned to trust me and I
learned to trust him we both thought it
was achievable so then he proceeded to
go to work
to it to go to work on it go go behind
the scenes and I wasn't asking for the
details that's not how it works if
you've ever done this before you just
let them go do their thing behind the
scenes and they will come back to you at
the appropriate time
and
um
on
February 8th
I understand that Mr marazzo asked if
you and Miss chippyuk would come to a
meeting at City Hall yeah what had
happened was
um I first met Mr marazzo on the
Thursday that we had the press
conference
it was later in the day that I was
introduced to him this first time I had
met him
um
I immediately was impressed with his
calmness and his level-headedness he
didn't
there was a lot of emotion up and down
with various individuals in these rooms
but Tom was always just completely calm
and he had been observing for longer
than us and oh and he had been working
with the police Liaisons
and felt that he was in a circle where
they would nothing material was arising
and he advised
uh in the meeting room I remember he
came in he'd left a meeting with the
plts and had told them that he didn't
want to speak with them anymore and he
needed somebody that was more of an
inspector level somebody who had some
actual decision-making capability and
greater Authority
um things went quiet the next morning
this should be now
the Tuesday
um February correct
um Tom
told Miss chippick and I that he wanted
us to come to a meeting at City Hall at
noon
and I said okay what's this all about
and does the city know we're coming
because one thing that is a certainty of
lawyer will will of any experience will
share with you is that it's always a bad
idea for your client to unexpectedly
bring lawyers to meetings it never goes
well
um so I've I've never before consented
to that in my 27 years but this being
such an unusual circumstance I agreed
that we would go
and we arrived at City Hall and had
quite an interesting interaction in
order to get upstairs to meet with Steve
k
okay and I take it that you met with the
PLT officers and
they weren't very happy about your being
there is that right uh
animatedly Angry
yeah and so as you indicate in your your
statement you uh uh
told them that uh to try and cool things
down that you would see constructions
not to impose the
continuation of the injunction which was
coming up in court that's correct we uh
the only thing I you know you kind of
you go through your pockets and see what
do I have
and I had nothing and Eva Miss chippyick
as a student she has pointed out that
there was one thing that we did control
and that was what recommendation we
could make to the board about what
position they would take on the
continuation of the injunction because
Justice McLean had issued it for a set
number of days I can't remember the
number of days but it was only set and
we had a returnable date that was coming
up
in the following either that later that
week I believe it's you can figure it
out from the pleadings
um
so we said that we would see
constructions from our client not to
oppose it becoming a long-term
injunction
so the quiet that had resulted from the
injunction would remain
and that was what we offered had it been
your instructions to oppose the
continuation of that injunction
I had not yet received instructions at
that point
and um
I take it that you ultimately had the
meeting with Mr kanalakis yes and were
you here for his testimony yes and is
there anything about what he testified
to regarding the meeting that you
disagree with
uh there was a couple of sort of nuanced
details but
um that I think he might have just been
misremembering at least or or
alternatively I am but nothing of
substance
okay and um
subsequent to that uh meeting
um
sorry let me take a step back sure I
understand that uh
he had two concerns one was to keep the
meeting secret because he didn't want to
it to get out if
there wasn't a successful negotiation
and he wanted
to move trucks from the residential area
and the Rideau Sussex intersection yeah
he'd given us a list of three so I I led
by saying once uh Evan and I went into
the room and I know there was some
conflicting testimony
there was three plts in that room
there were seven people in that room I
know someone testified I think it was
one of the uh it might have been uh
Drummond that uh it was there was no
police in the room that is absolutely
false
um and he likely just wasn't accurately
briefed I suspect
and I led by uh saying okay give us your
top three if we can get movement at
three locations in the downtown if we
can move trucks and protesters
where can we provide the most immediate
and effective relief and they gave us
the three locations and one of them was
Kent and I can't recall the other two
but what I also picked up on
as did Tom brazo and Ava chipiak is that
they spent almost the entirety of the
time talking about riddle and Sussex
and so even though we had this list it
was clear to me and to us as a team that
Rito and Sussex was in a category by
itself
so we promised them at the end of the
meeting that we would keep the meeting
secret and the reason that that was
important it's in these situations it's
always about building Trust
and it's the littlest things you can
control that build the trust
and so we agreed to keep the meeting
Secret
um and in fact no word got out about the
meeting
and I said and I'm not from Ottawa so
you know I was stuck in buildings and
then when I was on the move it was often
at night so I was very spatially
disoriented all the time
and
um so I said to Eva chippyuk who had
done uh her her I don't think it was her
master of laws I think it was her
undergrad or her LLB here at in Ottawa
so she was very familiar with the area
and Tom obviously was so I said can you
please take me to Rodeo and Sussex
okay so um
take it after the meeting the three of
you went to the intersection that's
correct and um Mr Claire could you bring
up hrf four zeros one five five zero
take it um this is a picture that you
took of the intersection at that time
yeah I took several pictures including a
picture
um
with uh Mr marazzo and Miss chippyick in
it I started doing that just to help
keep track of things you know you get
metadata on your phone so it shows
exactly what time and place so I started
taking these pictures
now you indicate in your statement that
um
at some point you left the intersection
and Ms shipyak and Mr uh marazzo
remained to talk to the protesters yeah
we decided
um and this is the way things worked
particularly with the people that were
there involved in the protest is
if something needed to be done you did
it right there and then you never
weighed it so the decision we had a
discussion and it was ever and and Tom
were like well why don't we try and move
this intersection right now
um so I said all right I'll go back to
the Sheridan and
the the reason that I we agreed that I
would go is because we had so little to
negotiate with in terms of tools and
tactics with the protesters
because I had been on the stage at the
press conference uh the week previous
I was recognized as the truckers homeboy
lawyer so the idea was that if they made
significant progress but were needed
just something more to get the truckers
to agree to clear this intersection
that I would that they would say well
we're going to have to have Keith come
and then I would come and try and use
whatever influence I may have
so that was the plan and
to be clear because there's been
conflicting evidence about this our
focus at this intersection was to clear
it
which is very different from the deal
with the mayor what the objective was
this was to clear this intersection and
as soon as we got there we could see why
it was such a concern I think there's
six streets that come together there's
the very high-end condo Tower there's
the U.S embassy down the road the Senate
and on and on and we're like okay we
understand why they want this cleared so
our goal was at least to clear up uh the
westbound Lanes
and um
if we can bring up back up your uh your
Witness
summary wts-6058
at page seven
and uh can you scroll up a bit uh you
said out there in the interest of time
I'm not going to take you through it all
of what happened at uh at Rideau and
Sussex that led up
um
to
um
you're finding out that um there was a
willing or at least Miss shipyak and Mr
marazzo the bottom paragraph
um finding out that uh the truckers had
agreed to move uh their vehicles to
Wellington
but there was a problem in removing the
Jersey barriers and that filter correct
well and it it was
not
um
what had happened was that my briefing
is that
we had an advantage because the first
three big trucks that would have to move
were the ones that had the Polish
immigrants
and Miss chippyuk is Polish
background and can speak Polish fluently
and she very quickly developed a rapport
with these Truckers
um and
we knew if we could get the first three
to go it would incentivize the other
ones to join in
there was a sense of of each of these
areas that people didn't want to be left
alone that that there was a real group
thing going we picked up
so
um
um but this this was an intense group
there's no doubt about it I mean you've
heard about that either is this forefata
stuff that the first time I heard it was
in this inquiry so it was never on our
radar but um
so Mr marazzo gathered you know about 80
of them together and in the middle of
the intersection surrounded by their
vehicles and got them to pick amongst
themselves to Representatives
then he moved forward and effectively a
parlay and the old military sense
with the police
to the West up to it closer to
Wellington and then
um
the particular police liaison Sergeant
Fung Lee
had a little bit of a
an aggressive personality he could
really turn aggressive very quickly and
Mr marazzo was concerned about him
interacting directly with the trucker
leaders from that intersection so Tom
went up spoke to Fung and said okay
bring in the equipment we're ready to
move at least half the intersection the
westbound up into that space on
Wellington
um Fung Mr Lee's phone rang he stepped
back
and then turned around and said to Tom
the deal's off they're not going to move
the barricades and we now know from the
record and the testimony of others that
others higher up the command
uh vetoed that movement so Tom but this
is important
um Tom did not go back and disclose what
actually happened he said they just
can't get the barriers moved because he
didn't want to destroy what little
progress we had made
we agreed to have a cooling off because
a lot of the truckers were upset
they had had arrangements to make kinds
of moves before our involvement and they
felt that the police had double crossed
them
and so we decided to give everything a
cooling off and a try again on the
Thursday
and
so that was on
February 8th
and I take it that February 9th uh there
were
some discussions with the
Ops PLT
officers and that uh led to February
10th where um
you returned to Rideau and Sussex to try
again is that yeah on the on the ninth
uh plt's uh
about 4 45 4 40 p.m uh contacted me
through Eva chippyuk that was the
protocol we had is that if they needed
to get me urgently they would call her
because she was always at my side
and they came over to a meeting in the
main floor of the Sheridan
it was an intense meeting
um
but we briefed the board that evening
and Tamara Leach
requested that all of the road captains
all legal
the board members all assemble at Sussex
arito and Sussex the next morning
prior to 10 a.m in an effort an all-out
effort to
use their persuasive skills we had an
initial success where there was a load
safe truck that you'll see in lots of
pictures load safe is what was on the
the logo on the side of the the cargo
trailer of the semi truck and it was
parked right by the valet area of
the shadow Laurier and it was pulled up
on an angle almost jackknife blocking
almost four lanes and the police did not
like it at all they'd been trying to
move it and I was standing with a large
group of plts misleach and others Mr
Barber came up we said hey I said Chris
or one of us said to Chris is there any
way you could go talk to that guy and as
you heard we all watched an amazement
Chris jumped up on the step and was
hanging onto the mirror the window came
down he started visiting with the guy
for a few minutes and all sudden Chris
hollered out for truckers to come and
set up a perimeter to safely back him up
and the backup alarm went on and they
repositioned him so he was right up
against the curb and
I remember we all thought okay this is a
good sign maybe we're going to do this
and then as you say in your statement
um the um
there was a crowd that suddenly appeared
who
didn't understand what was going on
and
they in effect
kind of surrounded
uh the area what just a little bit more
detail because I think it's important
for context if I can just stop you for
one second I do have a a video without
helping to contextualize it first if I
could sure
um so what happened was
we had a bunch of failed attempts
to get
the enough truckers to agree we always
had the Polish guys at the front that
were ready to go
so
um
a lot of the team or those of us who are
there to try and clear that intersection
we're done it was a very very cold day I
was back and forth trying to keep warm
in the lobby
of the Shadow Lorry that's when I got
served with one of the seizure orders
and was dealing with the TD Bank on
interpleter there were so many things
going on all the time
in any event
we'd largely given up it was just about
to get dark and then one of the plts
came out of the
the area and he came up and Tamara was
with me and a couple of others and said
they're ready to go
and Tamara's like well then let's do it
so they called in the big heavy lift
equipment to lift the barricade and they
end up bringing a tow truck
as well a flatbed tow truck because you
may have saw one of those pictures they
have these orange mechanical devices
that are actually bolted to the ground
and the vehicle drives over it it comes
up behind it
so we were waiting it was now getting
dark and it was typical as you get into
four or five o'clock six o'clock the
number of Ottawa residents and others
that would start to converge in the
downtown would significantly increase
each night this was typical of that
when the trucks and the heavy equipment
arrive they've got yellow flashing
lights they have backup alarms that
caused even more people to come
because we were anticipating moving the
trucks up past the war memorial to
Wellington
um
um
we needed the police were obviously
handling this part of it more police to
create a safety corridor so that no one
got run over
and
um
as
the one vehicle backed up and its alarm
was very loud
people started to rush in Tamara had
been removing from the barricades the
signs no one out the police were smart
not to go and start taking signs down it
was Tamara she was recognized so she
would place the signs over on another
railing by the Senate to get the
barricades ready to be removed safely
without
controversy hopefully
just as the equipment was going
people rushed behind the tow truck
because they seemed to think that the
police were about to do something bad to
the truckers I was talking to them
Tamara was individually talking to
groups of people it's okay this is a
Cooperative move we're trying to clear
this intersection the truckers want to
move up to Wellington
and then
um
um people would sit on a barricade
Tamara would go talk to them they'd
apologize get off the barricade she
turned around and they're on another
different people run another barricade
and then the police were further in
Tamara and I were trying to talk to as
many people as we could to explain that
it was okay this is a Cooperative move
we're just trying to clear an
intersection
and then
um
the people just swarmed in and that's
where the video plays okay can you pull
up please hrf401587
and I'm in the orange
high visibility coat which they jokingly
called my trucker camo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'd like to move
um
back to your statement
please that's um
wts-6058 and we only have about 15
minutes so I think we're gonna try and
speed it up a bit
the um excuse me that video was what
date that's that would have been on the
Thursday sir that would have been
February 10th
the evening that would have been about
five o'clock
sorry go ahead now you set out uh
starting at page nine of your statement
um
the
uh your your dealings with Mr French
um and leading up to a meeting with him
on February 11th
where he presented to you a draft letter
from the mayor
and you went and got
instructions and uh you were you're
discussed it with the board
and the board agreed
um
essentially to go ahead with the
proposed deal to move trucks out of the
residential areas is that that's correct
and and the proposal was not was never
just to move up to Wellington it was
always recognized that probably only 25
percent of the vehicles could go to
Wellington
the the more dominant theme of the plan
was for the vehicles to move to the
remote locations at embrom Exit 88 and
arm prior and
um to have expand the shuttle buses that
were already running and there was also
this is a very important point and I
don't know that it's come out yet is a
lot of people who were there the
truckers never planned to stay that long
but the Canadians they met along the way
and the stories and the heartache that
they heard and the trust and
um plea that they heard from those
people
many of the truckers I talked to felt
this obligation to stay as long as they
could but they also needed a way to
leave gracefully and respectfully and
one of the things we recognized was that
um if 75 percent of the vehicles were
going to be given an opportunity to
leave and go either to embrom
or arm prior that some would actually
use it as an opportunity to go home and
do so respectfully so that was an
important part of the plan and that's
what you refer to in your statement as
an exit strategy correct
and um
in that uh regard
um if you can bring up please hrf
four zeros one two seven eight
and this is uh
an email
um excuse me
it starts at the top February 12th
from you
it's a reverse Chronicle chronological
order so that would be the latest
response I had prepared following the
board meeting on the Friday evening
where the board decided to approve the
deal
they were all there in person except for
Mr Victor who was
incapacitated due to his broken leg and
had to stay at the Sheridan but we had
him joined by conference call
um and because of the significance of
this even though on the Friday they had
all agreed to proceed with the deal with
the mayor I wanted to get something
documented so I sent an email to all of
the board you can see where it says
right just by where the mouse is a
little bit up and to the left a gidg
that's a part of Bridget belton's email
address you'll also see
you can see Mr Victor's emails on this
as well
um it's the first one on the CC line
actually
and
um I received responses from everyone
approving it it makes reference to the
arrangement with the mayor the plan was
how are we going to get the truckers on
side so the decision was made to do this
Freedom manifest document where Tamara
at with all the board members signing at
the bottom would say it's time
we've had an impact it's time to to to
do something differently it's time for
us to focus our presence on Wellington
where our beef is with the federal
government
for them and for them to have the other
trucks move out to the other locations
and if you can just scroll up please
there stop right there um
you say in in that email from February
12 347
um you indicate that the drafting
committee
um
had looked into a way to draft a
document that would describe the freedom
convoys overall demands of all
governments and a Way Forward strategy
and so they were working on the broader
document for review by the board
tomorrow but you're circulating a draft
now
um
as a uh communicate and it was intended
to be a communication for the captains
and truckers regarding the uh deal with
the the mayor
and then you say on the
towards the end of that line after
Wellington and and
elegant while at the same time taking
away the excuse that Trudeau wants to
unleash the police goons and seize
trucks remember we are trying to block
Trudeau from having the justification to
cause the police to use the new
emergency Powers against the truckers
and allow the truckers to stay here in
Ottawa
for as long as it takes
Etc
now this is February 12th at that point
in time did you anticipate use of the
emergencies Act
um yes and um
further there's if rather than looking
at what's the the draft can we pull up
uh Mr
grf40 sorry excuse me I apologize Miss
Young commissioner I I just like to just
make a note of the record or perhaps a
small objection Ms Belton testified
yesterday that on the mayor's deal it
was her understanding that it was all
completely fake news I think it was the
terminology she she used and as I
understand it Mr Wilson is now
testifying that this deal was sent to Ms
Belton as one of the Convoy organizers
and that they all agreed to it I just
note In fairness the witness I don't
think that was put to her by the
commission nor uh the Convoy organizers
or Freedom Corp so I mean we're all
working very hard Herculean and we're
missing lots of things at times just
because of the pace but I think this is
a rather important point that it's
unfortunate we didn't hear from his
Belton
um on that issue
I think I think at this stage let's hear
the evidence and maybe that's a point
that can be made later but I'm sorry you
want to also involve yourself in this
yes
yes the issue is whether or not
Miss Belton is being impeached frankly I
don't think it matters so this this
commission doesn't need to make a
finding of credibility of Miss Belton so
I understand my friend's concern and
he's turning to the rule of brown and
done but I don't really even think it's
a concern sir it's not Material okay
hrf40 is one two eight five
and this is uh the the freedom manifest
that was uh I think there were you said
there were about
um 800 coffees made up and distributed
to
the the truckers that's correct about
850 copies were printed
um we decided to go old school Gutenberg
you know printed press
um in fact I took a little video and had
forwarded it to Dean French so that he
could see that progress was being made
on the efforts and the plan to get the
information out to the truckers the
Chris Barber Tamara and others went out
onto the streets and met with truckers
and the road captains handed these out
and Tamara even went out to
arm Pryor and embrom to inspect them to
make sure that they had sufficient
capacity to take all the 75 percent of
the vehicles and to meet with the owners
of those lands to make sure they were
comfortable with that many vehicles
showing up in the coming days
okay and uh
um I'm not going to ask the be pulled up
now but just for the record
um we then had the exchange of letters
between the mayor and Ms Leach which
we've seen the mayor's letter is hrf
four zeros one two six four and the uh
and Ms Leach's letter is hrf 401275
um
okay
and um
can I now ask to bring up hrf401323
and this is a document dated February 17
2022 open letter to our premiers and uh
to our elected and appointed officials
um it's a long letter but I take it that
the idea of this was still part of the
exit strategy to do something to make
contact with government officials so
that people could be satisfied that
you'd done all you could do at that to
that point is that fair yeah it is and
we I think what we were hoping would
happen is
the the
success that we felt we could achieve
with the arrangement and the agreement
with the mayor
and because if it was successful we were
going to have had the downtown cleared
out by the Wednesday but for Wellington
up to the Sir John A
and you know a defined area which they
actually in logistics meet and shorted
up because of the issues about the
hospital and so on access and the
truckers agreed to make it even a
smaller area
okay was that it would focus the focus
the protest now on the federal
government and then the federal
government would be encouraged by the
fact that the truckers proved to be
honest Brokers and that would lead to a
meeting with some federal ministers
there was not a strong desire to have a
meeting with the Prime Minister it was
more with the ministers
um and that we could agree on a process
of of
formally presenting briefs and
information and scientific information
to support
and comparative information because
Canada was anomaly at this time in terms
of our mandates the other G7 countries
weren't doing these things uh to try and
persuade the government to review its
policies
thank you and then um
we don't have to bring it up but at in
in your statement uh page 10 and 11 you
outline
um your understanding of what happened
in terms of the movement of the trucks
outside of from the residential area
either to leave or up to Wellington
correct yeah well I was I was directly
involved and uh on the Monday and my
text messages and my phone logs confirm
it my text messages with the sergeant uh
uh lee with um uh the mayor's chief of
staff and with the city manager uh we
the the reports I was getting from the
ground were that the police were not in
a position they were getting blocked at
different phases by the police they
finally got some trucks moved
we were ready to move trucks again on
the Tuesday Chris had worked and others
Joe Jantz and uh Ryan and Dale and
others had gone out and worked hard
to get a whole bunch of trucks ready to
move on the on the Tuesday
police completely blocked it we now see
all the back Communications and
infighting that was going on we didn't
know that at the time obviously and then
again on the Wednesday
um and and the other thing is we
realized
when we discussed it and I listened to
the road captains into the Chris barbers
is they felt that once the big trucks
moved there would be stragglers but they
wouldn't want to be alone and that they
would either leave or they may go in and
fill a little bit but so we recognize
that
and there was also discussion that if
and this is uh controversial but there
is also discussion
that if we get down to a few areas where
everybody else has either gone up to
Wellington or gone out to the base camps
or gone home and we have a few holdouts
that Freedom Corp would no longer
provide any supplies
fuel or materials to those areas to
incentivize them to follow the lead of
everyone else who was leaving downtown
thank you I I see I've gone up for my
hour and a half commissioner I have two
more points to deal with if I could sure
thank you
um
hrf401298
this is a letter that
you sent to Chief Bell
stating your view
on the
uh enact the the powers that were the
police were given under the emergency
act and you took issue with uh whether
there was the power to
um
prevent peaceful protesters from coming
into Ottawa to protest
correct and just to clarify uh the
letter is signed by Miss chipyak but I
did review the letter and we also had
at least four or five other lawyers from
the Justice Center reviewing the same
statutory regulatory instruments and we
had all reached the same conclusion that
the description that the government
officials and the police were using to
describe the measures
was not even close to what the emergency
Proclamation actually said and that as
long as you were not seeking to
interfere with International Trade
disrupt or interfere with critical
infrastructure or engage in serious acts
of violence against persons you continue
to have the right of a political
advocacy protest and dissent
and so the labeling by the police chief
and others that any Canadian citizen
was no longer allowed
to walk in downtown
Ottawa
or hold a sign in front of their
Parliament is was not legally accurate
and was against the charter and I think
we've seen the video that's uh and you
don't have to bring it up hrf
five zeros two seven four that you did
with Mr Barber
to essentially given giving that opinion
and telling whoever saw the the video
that they could and should come to
Ottawa and continue lawful protest I had
we were in the seventh floor boardroom
at the Sheridan I just finished briefing
um the board on the legal review that
had been completed of the proclamations
and Mr Barber turned to me and said
uh come over here sit on the arm of the
chair let's do a tick tock and it
literally happened that quick and
um
in
making that Tick Tock video
um
was it your understanding that there was
about uh to be an enforcement initiative
by the the police to remove people from
the the Red Zone I didn't know for sure
what I did know is that there was a
numerous times where
information would come into the
operations center from various police
sources that a raid was imminent and it
happened many times and then the raids
either did occur in part such as
Coventry or other evenings where they
would go and take uh firewood and and
fuel their food from one of the blocks
um but it did appear from the build up
we were seeing on the ground uh it was
obvious and the information we had about
the number of
I don't know there's some lands down
park or some place had been set up as a
processing center so it seemed that
there was a shift occurring
and did you have a concern if that about
the fact that if that was going to
happen you were in suggesting to people
to come back into the Red Zone and
potentially be in danger when the
enforcement action started no because
I'm a Canadian and I never imagined that
our government our federal government
would use that level of force against
non-violent peaceful Canadians
and um just a couple of final points
um
we heard
um Ms belton's evidence that her uh
Hotel Bill had been paid by Mr burro got
borobot or go or go
um have you ever met Mr burgo yes I met
Joseph a number of times he's an
immediate amazing human being and very
concerned Canadian
um but I have no knowledge of any bills
he was paying
um who paid your hotel bill uh who would
have paid my hotel bill
um
I pretty sure the first hotel bill went
on my firm Visa card and then I I was
reimbursed by the Justice Center
the Jermaine was on my Visa card
and was reimbursed
and then
the Swiss was paid for I believe I don't
know this with certainty by Chris Guerra
through adopt a trucker thank you and um
do you have any other information about
Mr Virgo about uh contributions he may
have made to the uh the the freedom
Convoy in terms of how much or what for
no I do know that he helped pay for some
meeting rooms
um I don't think when Mr marazzo and Mr
bullford were holding their press
conferences at the Lord Elgin I don't
think he paid for that but he might have
um and it was mostly the only only
firsthand knowledge I have was was hotel
rooms
okay and then um there's two other
documents that I want to ask you about
the first one is hrf
uh
six zeros
just let me get it here
eight three
and this was a press release February 17
2022
um
from the freedom Convoy indicating that
they did not support any of the
comments being made by Mr King uh
I may have asked you this but had you
met Mr King uh I knew of Mr King
prior to over a year prior to going to
Ottawa he had a court matter in Red Deer
where he was all over social media
saying that he's found this magic recipe
for defeating all government laws and I
researched it read the Court's decision
and it was clear he was misunderstanding
how the law works so I knew of him from
then and I knew that he was a very loud
voice
um uh when I found out that he was here
I told him I was I told the clients that
I wasn't prepared to be in the same room
with him there was one instance where he
was brought into a room and I
immediately requested that he leave the
reason was that I had heard of his
language
um at times and and maybe it was unfair
to him maybe I was duped by the the
media I don't know but there was there
was innuendo of violence
and it was completely unacceptable to me
but more importantly Miss Leach
um because the Legacy Media was
repeating it so many times and it was
needing to be explained so many times
the board made the decision to issue
this press release this is the only
press release of this nature that was
issued where they identified a person
and made it clear that they did not
agree with
um as it says he does not speak for us
we expressly condemn any talk of
violence from him or others
thank you and then the final document
hrf60513 page three I just wanted to ask
you about this uh
this is one of your I believe text
messages
um
yeah right there stop if you can roll it
up
a little more
uh that right there
um
I believe this is uh these data to the
top February 9th
um did you appear on on Fox News that's
correct and how did that come about
um I received
on a daily basis 10 20 or more media
requests
everyone from the New York Times
Washington Post BBC France 24 Belgium
Korea Japan
and every Canadian news Outlet
um I I uh I did agree to do one
interview
um and I agreed to go on on Fox
with premier peckford
that's a premier packford on the on the
right that's correct
thank you uh thank you sir those are my
questions and thank you commissioner for
the extra time
okay so we're uh pretty close to the
time for the morning break so I'm going
to take the 15-minute break and we'll
come back and start with our
list of cross-examinations
commission is in recess for 15 minutes
minute
order a lot
the commission is reconvened in the
commission on a pro
okay the first
up is for the government of Canada
please
good morning I'm Robert McKinnon for the
government of Canada Council
hi Mr Wilson I just want to take you to
a point that you made at the end of your
testimony with commission Council I
don't know that we have to turn up the
document but it was in reference to an
email of February 12th
uh that you had sent
and the line in there that I I just want
to clarify is where you say we are
trying to block Trudeau from having the
jurisdiction to cause the police to use
the new emergency Powers against the
truckers and to allow the truckers to
stay here in Ottawa as long as it takes
do you remember that line I think you
misspoke I think you meant to say
justification does it say jurisdiction
oh having that okay sorry justification
good memory so
is that not a reference to the
Declaration of emergency that was made
the day before by the Ontario Premier no
it does not speak into the future it
says to use the new emergency Powers
which just came into effect the day
before
it was uh the um
we have so I had lawyers with me on the
ground I also had teams of lawyers that
wrote back at their normal place of
business
when an issue would arise I would
delegate it out I would say okay this
team in Toronto I want you to review
this we even prepared a draft judicial
review application for the both the
cities emergency Proclamation and
and the
Ottawa or sorry the provincial
government one
uh media assessment is what does this
change what impact does it have on the
rights of the people on the ground and
we concluded that it was largely benign
okay what I'm saying is that those words
refer to the new emergencies power in
the present tense the Declaration from
the federal government came on the 14th
it was two days before
well I can
I can help you by telling you what was
in my mind
and our concern was
I believe that it was
early in the previous week by early I
mean the Tuesday and if not Tuesday the
Wednesday for certain
that we started hearing rumors that the
federal government
was contemplating invoking the federal
emergencies act so all of the references
in any of the communications that you
have at that time would be
and and unless there's one that's more
specific about that there was we weren't
concerned about the either the Civic one
uh nor the provincial one can you point
me to one document
Which documents what you're just telling
us now
um
well first of all this was not a normal
file
right but you've managed to pay for it
to finish my sorry okay officially
answering please sir uh this was not a
normal file you did not I did not have
opportunity to document things
um and
um I'm telling you under oath
that at no time was the either the
Ottawa state of emergency declaration
nor the Ontario state of uh declaration
a matter of concern
uh for me and the other lawyers with me
we were very concerned about the
potential and the rumors we were hearing
for the federal government to invoke the
federal emergencies act who told you the
federal government was considering using
the emergencies act who told you that
um I can't remember
the specific individual but I do
remember the source that they relayed
and they advised that they had heard
from some MPS that there was active
discussion over at the parliament about
the Prime Minister considering using the
emergencies act and it was so MPS
some MPS had shared with the people
involved in the Convoy and they reported
that to me do you have any document you
can refer this commission to today I
might but I can't recall any offhand and
you can't you can't recall any offhand
you can't recall a description of the
document or anything like that right now
uh no okay that's correct all right I'd
like to continue with uh just confirming
some statements from your witness
summary
um
you'd agree that there was a broad array
of groups that were part of this Convoy
correct
and you subdivided them into three
groups
those who came to support the movement
those who came to take it over
and those who came to seek a piece of
the 10 million dollars that was my
assessment uh
uh
probably I reached that conclusion in my
mind within I would say three to five
days of being here I had sufficient
interactions and repeated interactions
with different individuals from
different groups that that was the
pattern that I felt was present and you
also have said that the Convoy attracted
a lot of strange people yeah
and in that in those people you
mentioned the coven of witches
that's what they called themselves and
they were doing weird Seance things and
burning things in the lobby and and uh
conspiracy groups like digitalo if you
went on yes yeah you bet yeah so
it not only consisted of a broader array
of groups but it attracted other strange
groups that
at least as you've described them
correct like moths to a flame
so you'd agree that some of these
individuals we've heard a little bit
already may have tried to hijack the
message or
even try and control perhaps parts of
the Convoy group is that correct yes and
it was a constant effort by
Miss Leach Mr Barber and others
to fend them off so to speak and I do
recall reading documents in the record
where cesus and the RCMP had also
intercepted Communications and reached
the same conclusion that there was a
concerted effort by the mainstream group
to resist these hangers ons and and Mr
Barber testified yesterday that he could
not control
uh truckers generally they're very
independently minded and certainly not
the groups that were coming would you
agree with that that's correct yes I
would agree
and
there's in a Mr eros's interview summary
um that you've been taken to a little
bit uh a reference to at least a quote
that you supposedly mentioned concerning
um taking back our freedoms group yes
did you did you refer to them as Bad
actors
um I don't think I would have referred
to no I don't know that I would have
referred to them as Bad actors okay he
says you did and uh and Bad actors and
manipulators he says I would have
characterized without a doubt some of
the individuals involved with that group
as being manipulative 100 so I I even
within your group The Convoy group and
the the leadership that you've mentioned
uh there were would you say sort of
divisions or factions I would say
absolutely it was an incredibly diverse
uh Dynamic remember that if you walked
into the operations center at any given
moment and said how many people in this
room knew one another before January
15th and the only two people would put
up their hands would be Chris garan
chatty roast these people all came
together for the first time
all right and you mentioned the
negotiations with the city of Ottawa and
the days leading up to February 14th yes
to move the trucks out of residential
neighborhoods to take at least a bit of
a valve to some of the uh the
temperature that had been raised with
all the complaints and
issues that arose from that
that's correct yeah and the tensions
with the police and the political
tensions it was it was time to to
de-escalate and uh reduce the footprint
and relieve the pressure but that was
never intended to rid uh the city
core of the gridlock of 30-ton trucks or
resolve the Grievances of all the
various protesting groups there was no
gridlock I've described how I was able
to travel freely well let's just say
you're not saying that it was empty of
uh 30 ton trucks sitting in front of
Wellington
no the the idea was to concentrate and
this was discussed in the negotiations
with the mayor the mayor's
message that I received through Mr
French was that he recognized that the
grievance I think it's even in his
letter if I'm not mistaken that was with
the federal government primarily was the
triggering event the federal mandates
that you've heard about but your your
deal I just sorry sir have it finished
and I'm just that was slowing down
because I've Commissioners reminded me
that I'm speaking too fast
um so
it was recognized
that
trucks would remain on Wellington and to
be clear there was no
understanding that it would be a grant
of immunity it was recognized that at
any time after those trucks repositioned
the police could come and move them out
it was recognized that there would be an
interference in the flow of traffic on
Wellington but I note because I was up
there the other day it's blocked today
this very moment by government
barricades okay I I'm just getting to
the point that the deal was never
intended
to resolve all these Grievances and
protests and to get rid of this the the
trucks from the city core correct no it
was absolutely to remove the pressure on
the downtown residents and businesses
Focus the attention on the grievance
with the federal government
build from the success of de-escalation
and negotiation to incentivize and
encourage the federal government to come
to the table open up a dialogue and set
a pretext for the truckers to go home
how how does well would you be surprised
that the mayor would say that that the
deal was to just release some of the
tension from the neighborhoods it did
nothing to deal with the core issue of
getting rid of the trucks in front of a
Wellington
I don't know do you want me to repeat my
answer a third time no I don't need I
don't need that but I've got your answer
so you don't agree that this was this
deal was intended to uh resolve
all these uh
issues and gridlock on Wellington
complex problems require complex
Solutions complex Solutions require
phasing
so you had faith
I had faith I had confidence in the Good
Will of of the of of look do we have an
agreement a written agreement that said
they would move
I
have been able to resolve at least more
than 90 percent of all the litigation
files I've been involved in by opening
up dialogue between the parties
and I remained optimistic that through
applying those skills and those tactics
that we could have had a peaceful
resolution
and a respectful Canadian dialogue about
important policy issues who are you
representing at the negotiations were
you representing the leadership that you
mentioned that the the directors of that
company the non-profit company the
freedom 22 2022 the president Tamara
Leach and uh the vice president Chris
Barber and the treasurer
Chad Eros
uh Beyond those people
who were who are your clients uh you've
described them that's accurate so you
were not acting on behalf of all of the
truckers that's correct
so you had faith
uh I had faith and uh my faith uh
uh in the same way I would have quit
practicing lost sir a long time ago if I
didn't have faith in the ability of of
of people having civil and respectful
discussions to resolve disputes but the
objective of that agreement was to move
25 percent more trucks into the
Wellington Street area so it doesn't do
anything to relieve that congestion
it was a fair but we've already
established sir that the roads blocked
today so if I'm not sure if your concern
is about the presence of trucks and
Canadians or whether you're concerned is
about the road being blocked it can't be
the road being blocked because it's
still blocked to this day by the
government
you you have heard are you aware of the
evidence given at this inquiry of of the
racial slurs
the intimidation the threats against
Ottawa residents and public officials
and the blaring High decibel horns at
all times of day and night during these
demonstrations in Ottawa you're aware of
that evidence correct I'm aware of the
allegations and I'm also aware of what I
experienced which was Canadians
particularly immigrants of all ethnic
backgrounds
um coming together in a very peaceful
respectful way with a deep concern about
what the federal government and
governments were doing to their rights
and freedoms I'm just talking about
those particular allegations right now
okay yes as a lawyer you would agree
that those are not protected
as a form of free speech
or action under the charter
um I know I don't know that I'd agree
with that I need it you have to be very
contextual specific
um our Free Speech rights are very Broad
and
um uh just to say that someone made some
Vic
some vague
so allegation of racism is not enough
for me or anyone else to make a reasoned
conclusion you agree hate speech has
been codified in the criminal code right
yes and I find the prime minister's hate
speech towards unvaccinated people and
saying how do we deal with these people
of deeply troubling right so you you
don't agree then that threats against
the life of somebody is is is not a
protected form of speech under the
charter uh I do not believe that anyone
either morally or legally should be
threatening anyone else's life and I
have received many death threats myself
since representing the freedom Convoy so
we agree that that's not protected right
um death threats are not protected
correct nor nor is speech that is
looking to uh demean to an extent a
particular group of people in a serious
way
I'm going to have to object at this time
my friend is entirely
mischaracterizing the law of section 2B
of the charter and the decisions and
respect to that in fact the Supreme
Court of Canada of course has held that
hate speech other than inciting violence
is actually protected by section two via
the charter and so I would ask that my
friend
um essentially cease putting errors of
law to the witness on public television
I am just asking for his view as a
lawyer
but I I don't have to continue I have
other questions for Mr commissioner I
hate to interrupt the proceedings but
I've received an email communication
from our certified transcriptionist
asking if parties when they're making
objections from the Florida please State
their name first
thank you Mr commissioner
okay uh
I think this is proper cross-examination
so I'm not go ahead okay
so uh
you'd agree trucks do not have uh
Charter rights
yes obviously good
and you don't have the right to park
somewhere for three weeks
wherever you want whenever you want
I was asked many times
every day By Truckers when they
recognized me
and they would say Mr Wilson
am I allowed
to have my truck here and
if they were parked in the parking Lane
I would say it depends what does the
sign say about how long you can park you
might get a ticket if they were parked
in a driving lane I had the same
response to all of them which was you
tell me this if you were to stop your
truck in the number two lane on the 401
and get out and leave it what would
happen and they would say the opp would
come they would ticket it and they would
tow it away I said I would say to them
you're in the exact same situation here
no you cannot lawfully Park your truck
there there is an interesting argument
because they were told to park there by
the police as to whether they might have
an officially induced error defense but
that was the answer that I would give
them okay you'd agree it's not a
protected rate under the charter
of course okay
and and neither is blaring High decibel
horns
a protected form of speech or action
under the charter well there was and I'm
not trying to be cute about this but
you're asking me a very nuanced question
because Charter writes especially when
you get into freedom of expression are
nuanced is there were times where these
dance parties on the weekend and I said
this and it's in the transcript but when
I was before Justice McLean because we
did have a discussion about whether
there was an artistic element and the
trucks would start with the different
frequency of their horns would start
doing dance beats so there was that but
it's clear
Miss Leach and Mr Barber
were clear that they did not want the
horns before the injunction the week
before the injunction the truckers
agreed amongst themselves
to
have a quiet time from 8 pm to 8 A.M
because they wanted to get sleep too
the injunction allowed that to be
expanded
well people weren't dancing to these
horns that were going all hours of the
day and night you've heard the evidence
from the from the residents I witnessed
people dancing a lot to the horns with
the music I'm sorry so that's what I saw
I'm under oath yes at one in the morning
three in the morning yes and okay I
wasn't on the street at three in the
morning so I can't say but I was at
least once or twice leaving meetings at
one in the morning
I I've got your perspective
uh
do you recall a
a second press conference that you gave
on uh with others on February 6th so
this one you're more organized I I could
call up
document com I think it's five zeros
eight five six it's a transcript of that
uh there you attended Ms litch Mr
Beaufort Mr Victor and Tom quigan is
that how you pronounce his name yes okay
do you recall that I believe that was
a press conference that Mr dichter had
asked that was primarily focused on
bitcoin it was in the Sheridan Hotel and
I and Miss Lynch were asked to come to
attend the first part of it to provide a
legal update and an operational update
um on where things were at so these were
people who are all part of your group is
that right so uh Tom quiggin Mr Victor
Mr Beauford Ms Lich
that they're all part of your convoy
group leadership would you say or part
of your working group they're part of
the freedom Convoy I thought as far as
I'd be prepared to go okay
and you worked together
I worked with lots of people every day
on a wide variety of issues and Tom
quiggin is an ex-military intelligence
officer that's my understanding and um
he worked in the operations center all
right uh he was mostly
I almost never saw him in the Operation
Center at the Swiss he was almost always
at the ark and he was doing these on his
own initiative these daily situation
briefs they were not reviewed by anybody
in fact I haven't still haven't even
read most of them we had no time to even
read them and he was circulating them to
the truckers now so so he he did write
daily intelligence reports and special
intelligence reports on certain events
correct yeah that's my understanding yes
and I've read read some of them since uh
since preparing for this and uh do you
place Credence in his uh his assessments
um sometimes I did and sometimes I
didn't
uh are you okay well I we could take you
to
um who he is first uh page 12. of this
uh document
uh where it has his Tom mcquigans if you
go down to line 12
uh so okay
are we on the right page 12 okay I've
got page 12 here
uh
yeah so yeah that that's it yeah
so it says uh he describes himself I'm
ex-military intelligence I also work for
the RCMP for six years in National
Security the integrated National
Security enforcement team I'm one of the
few Court experts in the country on
terrorism and I'm a declared Court
expert in both in criminal court and
which is to say Ontario Superior Court
as well as the federal court do you see
that yeah I've since reviewed his CV and
confirmed these things to be true okay
and and he did put out uh
reports every day right I don't know if
it was every day I was a few days in
that I learned that these things were
occurring I think they were distributed
to the block captains if I'm not
mistaken in the morning yeah uh
so I I'm gonna have to get to the point
quite quickly you're already over time
okay uh my my well I'll take you to one
of the threat assessments right now okay
at one of the daily assessments it's uh
document hrf one two three four five six
zeros 18.
so you'll agree that there were
people attracted to the Convoy not only
strange but who
had violent tendencies if you could look
here so this is on February 3rd this is
the day I think you arrive
here the assessment is freedom Convoy
2020 to assess the potentially violent
protesters may arrive in Ottawa to
vandalize property
following that they will then attempt to
blame Convoy members for the violent
actions the protesters are likely to
arrive in Ottawa either late Wednesday
or Thursday the violent actions are
likely intended for Thursday and Friday
the actions from the protesters are
likely to consider harass consistent
harassment of citizens and damage to
vehicles and properties and then they
describe how they're going to be dressed
do you see that yeah I recall that in
fact we were
received a separate briefing and this
actually was raised by GoFundMe
Executives and their legal team on our
call on the Thursday
um and it was antifa they had previously
come in on occasion and knifed trucks
cut uh cut the airlines stop knife tires
and they had announced on social media I
was told the antifa group that they were
going to be coming in a larger numbered
force and trying to do more damage to
the trucks so if I might ask one more
question uh Mr commissioner just on it
it's on a document that uh the the
transcript if you could pull up the
transcript again it's page 14. it has to
do with tow trucks an issue that
everybody seems to have an opinion on so
this is Tom mcguigan again in the
interview
that's right so he says concerning tow
trucks the short answer is tow truck
companies right across the country in
Alberta Ontario whatever have either
politely refused requests from the
government to assist or not so plate
politely refused requests for assistance
and if you turn over the page
well sorry go down to the bottom of that
page first
uh what but what it shows is the federal
government in Ottawa is reaching all the
way down to Buffalo New York trying to
find a tow truck and they can't get one
because the turn turn over to the page
Trucking industry is somewhat of a
Brotherhood much like the military much
like the police and we do kind of all
know each other and no tow truck company
that wants to be in business for more
than a week after this is going to help
out
and it goes down a couple more
paragraphs so what's actually happening
now we have a network of tow truck
operators who are talking to each other
to see who's being called and who's not
short answer is they're having a hard
time getting tow trucks so was the
Convoy actively
trying to prevent
the use of tow trucks no there was never
any of the rooms I was in and I was
usually with the leadership at all times
any effort attempt or even discussion
about reaching out to any tow companies
to discourage them and we know from the
evidence from the police and the
previous days of this inquiry that in
fact the governments were able to get
tow trucks so that contradicts what the
Mr McQueen just said in his press
conference on February 6th and
corroborates my evidence that sometimes
they agreed with him and sometimes I
didn't
thank you
okay
um the Ottawa residence Coalition please
foreign
champ for the Ottawa Coalition of
residents and businesses uh
commissioner I'm going to uh I don't
think I'll have any difficulty finishing
within time but just like buys a city of
Ottawa has offered their time to me in
the event I get close so
uh Mr Wilson
um just have a few questions for you on
your testimony from this morning first
is with respect to your flight to Ottawa
how you got here there was a news report
that that was on uh
Charter flight operated by Northern Air
Charter is that correct I believe so I
think that's the name of the company
and apparently that company is now under
investigation by Transport Canada for
carrying unvaccinated people on that
flight are you aware of that uh that was
the allegation by CTV and my
understanding is
an investigation was commenced but no
action was taken okay
and who originally offered to pay for
the flight was that Mr Borgo
um I'm not as I testified earlier
entirely clear on who was offering I
don't remember it to be Borgo might have
been take back our freedoms I believe
there was a couple of people and as I
explained we had this pattern where
people would come forward and say oh
we'll look after this we'll look after
that
and it didn't happen there was some
uncertainty as to whether or not we were
even going to be allowed to get on the
plane but the Justice Center said this
is too important get on the plane we'll
sort this out later
now before you got on the plane um I
understand from the interview summary of
Mr Eros that there was a virtual meeting
or a zoom meeting on or about January
31st whether it was yourself Andre
mamari Brian packford Tamara Leach and
himself and Joseph Bordeaux do you
recall that uh it was on the evening of
the first
um it was the reception they had in the
hotel was terrible terrible they've only
heard probably a third of what we talked
about Mr BOGO was not on that
um there was a doctor with a British
accent
a very nice man I can't remember his
name
um and Mr peckford was most definitely
not on that call was not was not
uh was there another virtual call with
Mr burgo and yourself and Mr Eros I have
never had a virtual call at any time in
my life involving Mr Eros and Mr Bogle
ever okay
um when you arrived in Ottawa you
testified that it was apparent to you
that Ms Leach really was the leader
um
was the leader of this movement
um you said that it seemed that people
listened to her uh she seemed to command
a lot of respect and so forth
uh that that's right yeah and even if
you walk the streets when we were moving
from one location to another
it was remarkable the people that would
come up and stop her and politely ask if
they could have a hug
and the tears would just start to flow
and often I was standing behind her and
I would hear what these these incredibly
tragic stories that these people would
share and the grown men and about how
they'd lost children to Suicide they'd
lost their businesses they'd lost their
marriage and it was Tamara and seeing
what Tamara was doing that had given
them hope hope
um I guess it was it also in part
because people knew that she had control
over the 10 million dollars from
GoFundMe that's why she was a leader
Tamara figured out something way before
I did
and I remember we got
it was my fault I thought someone was
coming up to hug her we were leaving the
Westin Hotel
um after coming out of the meeting with
Dean French on the Friday night when
when he had presented the mayor's
proposal I thought it was someone
wanting a hug and it turned out it was a
TV crew from Berlin TV from Germany
and I felt bad because we tried to
protect Tamara from that but
um when they asked her about the the 10
million she responded by saying the
money symbolism
the money is symbolism it was and if you
look at how much money actually got to
the truckers and how much was actually
returned to the donors at the vast
majority ended up back at the donors and
as you know very well otherwise it's in
the escrow fund under Court supervision
partly over which you must receive
notice before anything can happen to it
so the money was symbolism in Tamara's
View and I think she's right it was a
way for Canadians to demonstrate and add
their voice to what they thought the
Convoy stood for which was holding the
government to account and advocating for
respect for our Charter return to the
rule of law
um I wasn't going to ask a question on
this but I couldn't help when I heard
your testimony uh about the horn
injunction
um you testified that you advised your
clients that the horns were a problem
and that you expected that the
injunction uh would be granted and you
were asked a couple of times by
commission commence Council about
whether your clients oppose the
injunction just to be clear your clients
oppose that injunction correct thank you
I I honestly can tell you Mr Champion as
you know one of the things that happens
to me when I come to Ottawa I meet you
and and I I mean that in a respectful
way you've been very professional in
your dealings and I thank you
um I actually as I was asked that
question couldn't remember whether I
actively opposed so
um uh if that's your memory I agree that
I I probably did do as lawyers do oppose
but I do what I remember more clearly is
advising my clients that there was no
way that the court was not going to
grant that injunction you
um you had argued that the horns were
not irreparable harm and Ms Lee should
wear earplugs do you remember to sleep
do you remember those arguments I don't
but I'm I I have confidence in you if if
that's your memory then I'll accept that
okay I won't go further down the road of
the different arguments that were made
um but then on the continuation of the
injunction a week later as you remember
that um that became a bargaining point
with the city you were offering to the
city that perhaps that your clients
wouldn't oppose the continuation of Ms
Lee's horn injunction if they did
certain things is that right that's
correct and and and and my memory I'm
hoping is correct that you recall we did
not oppose that yeah that's correct
that's right you did not oppose the
second one
um I want to ask you some questions
about dealings with the police now
you've testified that uh you were
hearing at times that there were police
raids imminent at different times during
the protest and we we did hear some
evidence from the police that there were
raids planned at times that them were
aborted
um so it sounds like you might have had
some solid Intelligence on that is that
fair well actually we thought we did but
after having uh observed uh the the
proceedings uh since uh the last few
weeks
we had no idea of the level of
dysfunction of
of infighting that was going on
we assumed that when information
filtered in to the Operation Center that
a raid was going to occur at nine
o'clock that night at this location that
it was real and then when it didn't
happen the Assumption was it was a test
not that there was something happening
where
different inspectors and forces were in
Conflict about a plan we had we did not
that was all new Revelations through
this inquiry
uh yeah those New Revelations I think
that's one issue your clients and my
clients can agree on for sure
um now but uh that you you were getting
information from sympathetic police is
that right that's correct
throughout yes there was the remarkable
thing was
that all these different individuals who
had experienced
you know I I was never
prior to this a big believer a huge I
didn't think they were a bad idea but
mission statements
it was remarkable how efficient
everybody worked because they all had
the same mission statement that they had
formulated deep to the core of their
being was that they felt the country was
badly off track that their families and
their communities were being harmed and
this was their opportunity to try and
make a difference so we had former
police officers military Navy thesis
airline pilots doctors nurses teachers
Carpenters
chiropractors the whole breadth of
society was there and the cream just
Rose
and they organically came together
during the time in in those who were
getting things done there was very
little infighting there was a lot of
people coming in that we were trying to
manage but it was really remarkable the
organic way in which the Enterprise ran
so that if people could cook they were
cooking if they were I.T people they
were helping you with that if they were
Communications
they could share you with that one
really illustrative example was
in the operations center mid-morning
super cold outside you know some people
are the big huge Square table people
working people standing in groups people
looking at things on the board and then
someone came in and said some situations
occurring at Albert and Kent or wherever
it was
and everybody stopped for a minute
no one said what needed to be done two
people got up threw their coats on
grabbed their tooths and they were gone
and then everybody carried on
it was so efficient that there was no
point even discussing what needed to be
done and who was going to be doing it
once the information came in that the
people who knew they were best suited
for dealing with it did it was
spectacular to watch that's why I now
believe mission statements are very
important
um now on some of the things that people
were doing cooperatively uh with the
Convoy we we heard from uh both Ms
Belton and Mr Barber about the
distribution of cash
truckers
um you were you knew that that was going
on right I observed that yes you
observed it uh that and they were trying
to keep track of how much cash is being
put into each envelope before it was
being distributed yeah that was really
chatty Ross's department and he
um he has given
um interviews that are online where he
describes
Chris Carson's interview where he
describes the processes that he put in
place but I did observe cash being
counted my understanding was it was
coming from the stage and from other
places
and being put into envelopes and then
teams would go out and distribute it to
the truckers but but Mr Eros he was one
of the directors of Freedom Corp correct
he was not only a director he was a
Treasurer and he was in a paid
accountant right so he was gathering or
trying to keep track of that money on
on behalf of Freedom Corp right
I would hope so right and uh so
um as an advisor to Freedom Corp at that
time you were aware that they were
managing this distribution of funds and
cash out to the truckers
uh he was yes okay
and um he had estimated that it seemed
that around twenty thousand dollars per
day was being raised through cash and he
transfers do you have any reason to
dispute that
um
I think the first time
I saw cash
would have been probably around just
trying to visualize a calendar here
probably around the 11th or the 11th
maybe yeah and that weekend the 12th
um and be that was after
the provincial government in Ontario the
Attorney General issued the seizure
order that you're familiar with with
respect to the gifts and go funds and
much like what you saw happen with when
the police said no more fuel
to if you bring fuel to downtown you're
going to be charged with counseling
Mischief or something
the next day
Ottawa residents and other one everyone
showed up with gas cans it was the I am
Spartacus moment
and what I observed was people were so
determined to support the truckers that
because the GoFundMe got shut down and
now the give send go was being frozen
they weren't going to let that
discourage them I heard anecdotal
stories from many truckers where they
would get the tap on the door and
someone would be there with their family
and give them twenty dollars or a
hundred dollars or a thousand dollars or
five thousand dollars
so in your statement you say that some
people were at the protest for money is
getting all of this cash do you think
that was an incentive for the truckers
to stay not the vast majority because
um I just that wasn't why they were
there there was always there's always
opportunistic people that are more
focused on money than others of us
that's all I meant
and those trucks uh the 300 to 400
semi-tractor trailers operating 24-hour
idling 24 hours a day required a lot of
diesel fuel correct not as much as if
they're pulling a load for sure uh but
who was paying for all of that fuel the
big trucks uh fuel at Coventry I know
there's we put into in it well in your
uh in your action with the meriva
injunction uh there's details on that in
the affidavits but I also know that I
was told
by a businessman who wanted to donate
fuel that he had contacted or had his
office
contact three different fuel suppliers
in the bulk suppliers
and he wanted them he wanted to pay for
a shipment of fuel from each of them
they declined because they said the best
they could do was put him on a waiting
list they had so many people phoning
from across the country to pay for fuel
to be delivered downtown that they
actually didn't want his money and they
said all they could do is put him on a
waiting list
so just a couple last points uh Mr
Wilson
um just about some of the people who
you're involved with Pat King he
testified that you knew him from about a
year before uh the Convoy protest is
that right yeah like I would I I wasn't
at his house or anything yeah yeah uh he
had gone on this highly misinformed rant
on social media and he was attacking a
reporter and so I it's always dangerous
on Twitter I jumped in and explained the
law and showed the pleading so to show
where he was misunderstanding how the
law worked and he hadn't set this big
precedent so I had but he's a loud voice
like Chris guy right so I was aware of
him but but Mr Skies from Ontario
generally speaking Mr King is from
Alberta like yourself correct yeah Mr
Skye made his way across the country a
few more of that but Mr King he is in
Alberta so you you did have some
interactions with him you know there's
four million people in Alberta right
yeah but I presume you don't have
interactions with all of them I'm asking
about Mr King not all four million the
first time I was in physical presence of
Mr King was when he showed up in a
boardroom
in Ottawa during the protest and it was
about two or three days in and I
immediately instructed him to be to
leave the room not him I told the people
around he's got to go
the only other direct interaction I had
with him was on Twitter in the previous
about 18 months prior to that where he
was misunderstanding uh ruling by a
court judge but Mr King my understanding
he he was a supporter of uh Western
separatism and so forth wegs it and
those kinds of movements were you aware
I I wasn't aware of that it wouldn't
surprise me but I wasn't aware of that
were you involved in those movements
Western I was never I've never formally
been involved in those movements uh I I
have been very concerned about
the merits and the fairness of our
confederation but seeing as you've heard
and I saw myself
a quebecer with a Quebec flag running
towards an albertan with a cowboy hat
and an Alberta flag and embracing
seeing
a quebecer trucker who could not speak
any English
with a
trucker from elsewhere in Canada I don't
know where he was from who couldn't
speak any french and they were using
Google Translate in a Tim Hortons to
communicate and they were laughing and
getting along it restored my faith in
the future of our country so just the
last person to ask about while you're
talking about French Mr Dean French uh
Mr French called you a patriot is that
right
I believe that's in the text message yes
yeah he he
um supported the movement wholeheartedly
did he not
um it's clear I you'd have to ask him
but it was clear to me that
he uh uh support that he also had
concerns about uh government overreach
and that the
the truckers were protesting that and I
thought I understood from your text with
Mr French he's the one that arranged
that interview with you in Fox news is
that right he did but I also received
phone calls from Fox News I received
emails from Fox News they were all about
the same time I mean that's how these
guys work when they really want to get
somebody they reach out to everybody
they can I don't know that it was
because of Dean that I got it it might
have been but I I had emails and phone
calls from Fox News independent of of
those just like I had con been contacted
by the New York Times in the Washington
Post and everyone else but he was
assisting you
um
he was he I wouldn't say he was
assisting me it was something he did on
his initiative I think he thought I
would be a good interview
I was surprised to see you on Legacy
Media like Fox News well you know I
guess we all get surprised his last
piece did Mr French ever uh indicate to
you uh whether uh he had had any
Communications with Premier Ford about
his views about the protest
um he never did but my clear sense was
I'm not very familiar with with the
goings-on in
um
um in Ontario politics but I had a
general sense I think I might have
Googled him and I think I got a sense
there was some estrangement or some
falling out between him and the premier
but I I just wonder if he ever
communicated anything like that too
never brought up
um the only time he would have made a
reference to the premier was oh like the
whole Twitter account thing that because
we had the problem with BJ Victor
logging into Tamara's Twitter account
and sending out that one tweet and he
said multiple people have access to this
right and I said yeah and he explained
to me that when he was Chief of Staff to
the premier they had a rule three people
had access to the premier's Twitter
account but two of them had to agree to
a tweet no one person and I said yeah it
would have been nice to have known that
just on that though that Ms Leach also
put out a live stream on Facebook uh
saying she wasn't supporting the deal
that night that's not true that's not
true okay thank you
thank you commissioner okay thank you
the next is the city of Ottawa I might
take it you're uh you have no questions
that is correct Mr commissioner thank
you
next is the
Ottawa Police Service
good afternoon Mr Wilson my name is
Jessica Barrow and I'm counsel for the
Ottawa Police Service
I just have a couple of points I want to
walk through with you so first of all I
want to make sure that the record is
very clear about who you do represent
and who you do not represent so as the
representative for Freedom Corp you
represent only those organizers that I
believe you listed earlier in relation
to Freedom Corp and not other
participants in the Convoy correct
that's correct and so specifically you
do not represent Pat king or James
botter that's correct
and you would agree with me that both
Pat King and James Potter were esposing
views that your clients disagreed with
is that fair
um at times yes not universally but some
of their messages they did not agree
with
we saw specific evidence of of them kind
of rejecting the views of Pat King and
James Potter is that fair yeah James
Potter there was a number of times where
they were preparing a press release to
distance from the mou or they were going
to add it to a paragraph of a letter
but if you've ever drafted by committee
you know that everybody wants their
piece and certain things get left out
but I think they made it pretty clear
that they did not support the mou and
nor did they support and they were very
concerned about any innuendo of violence
from Mr King right so so speaking of
violence you indicated that at the time
you sort of advertised on Tick Tock that
people should come to the city it was
your view that that was because it was a
lawful and peaceful protest and Ottawa
is that fair yeah and it was more than
that because one of the things that I
I mean I'm a lawyer but I'm also a dad
and I my wife and I have four kids and
it was remarkable to me
meeting many of the families with with
younger children I mean
five six up to 12 14 and the amazement
on their face they're interacting with
all these different truckers of every
ethnic background and other Canadians
and the excitement
and the pride
was really historic and I I commended
those parents for
having their children learn from this
and participate in an experience at
first time it was very safe
I never imagined that the police would
use the level of violence that they did
so you were aware however that and there
were multiple warnings to that effect
that that arrests were going to be
taking place very shortly correct
um the warnings really accelerated
on the Thursday and when I did the when
Mr Barber asked me to do his Tick Tock
that was on the Wednesday and so when
you're speaking of peacefulness and
lawfulness I take it you're not
referring to those individuals that were
charged with criminal offenses prior to
that date in relation to violence or
threats or weapons
I'm not following your question what do
you
mean
so
I believe you've seen the institutional
report from the Ottawa Police Service
it's been part of made part of the
evidence yeah I've only had a chance to
skim through parts of it
um and would you uh disagree with me
that multiple charges were laid prior to
that Tick Tock video uh in relation to
criminal offenses that related to
violence or threatening behavior or
weapons
I do know that the statistics were clear
that the crime rate had gone down I do
know that the uh because of some of the
former police paramedics
Emergency Services people that were
in the operations center explained to me
what happens in Ottawa here after I
think it's called Blues Fest and the
amount of assaults and violence that and
even on Canada days the amount of
assaults and violence they said they
told me having attended and participated
and been on duty on those events they
had never seen this number of people
come into the downtown core
and with this level of safety and
absence of violence so that's what I
knew okay but my specific question was
when you're referring to a peaceful
protest I take it you're not referring
to the people who were engaged in
criminal behavior that was obviously
deemed not to be peaceful
well I mean it's a peaceful protest
where there's some people within a large
crowd of five or eight or ten thousand
people as there were on the weekends
that engaged in criminality that's
called normal
I'm going to move on to the deal with uh
the city officials we've heard quite a
bit of testimony about that
um and I think it's clear that your
understanding of the deal always was
that some trucks would move on to
Wellington and I think your evidence was
around 25 percent and then the rest
would leave the city core is that
correct absolutely right
um and so I want to bring you to uh
hrf000513
at page 52 and just for your reference
these are the text messages between you
and Mr French okay
and actually could we go to page 59 I
apologize Mr Clark
and so we just heard very briefly
um
from you in relation to the tweet that
went out
I think if you scroll down a little bit
and that's the tweet that that's being
referenced right this is a an article
about the Tweet where
um it comes from Tamara's account that
that it's a denial of the deal is that
correct
yes and so regardless of who ultimately
authored the tweet it was coming from
Miss Leach's Twitter account correct Mr
Victor has confirmed that he was the one
who did it right but it in terms of how
the public received it it came from a
Miss leeches account right yep and
within minutes of being informed of it
and once we found out Miss chippick and
I got to the bottom of it
um and that Mr Victor acknowledged that
he had done his own tweet and then he
logged out and logged back in as her and
then retweeted his tweet with a quote
that it was him uh we said you gotta fix
this and you got to fix it fast because
I have an email from him where he
agreed to confirmed his consent good to
go
um so he was the one we were trying to
think of wording that could go out to
confirm the deal was still going ahead
and he decided that he would play the
Tweet as though the reporter had made a
mistake and I think he says something
like nice try so and so we were talking
about the federal mandates the deal to
move trucks tomorrow was going ahead can
we just scroll down a little bit please
sure
and if you keep going down
I think you just passed it no I want to
I think if we keep going down sorry
um right there yeah so this is Dean
French saying it was posted two hours
ago and no correction yet
uh so it does take some time right for
the for the Tweet to get corrected I
recognize there may have been some inner
workings going on but it takes at least
a few hours for that to get corrected is
that fair yes okay I I can't dispute
that I can't remember I know that we
were able to uh correct it around it was
either 10 58 PM or 1102 PM uh Dean had
strongly recommended that we correct it
um get to the bottom of it figure out
what happened correct it in advance of
the 11 o'clock news hour shows
and I moved as quickly as I could to get
to the bottom of it because I was
completely blindsided by it and there is
I won't take you through the whole
exchange just to save time but there is
a an acknowledgment from Mr French where
he's saying it would have been nice had
it occurred prior to the 11 o'clock news
so would you agree that it didn't get
corrected prior to the 11 o'clock news
is that there was many times where Mr
French and Mr peckford said oh it would
be nice if you could do this and you and
I was like I don't think you are
appreciating the Dynamics of this
environment it was extremely chaotic
would it be fair to say that through
this text exchange and I can walk you
through it if need be but to save time
um that Mr French was expressing
concerns um about the impact this tweet
would have on the legit as legitimacy of
the deal probably so as was I I was sure
those concerns yeah I was uh I received
feedback from a lot of the people I was
around that they were
they were struck how calm I was most of
the time there was one notable exception
where I was arms flailing yelling likely
swearing
and a very loud voice when I was like
who did this and what just happened here
I was very because I and others had
worked very very hard to get us to this
point
we had the logistics meeting at City
Hall with uh
ayotte and the city manager and Drummond
we had
report heard back that the trucks were
ready to roll some of the guys were
packing up some of their gear
and I was like oh my goodness we've come
this far and we're going to get
sabotaged and you would agree that
because of that miscommunication it
would have created a lack of clarity to
those following that account about
whether there was or there was not a
deal is that fair there was that lack of
clarity even prior to that because this
is the Sunday night
so when the the pamphlets were being
circulated and people would get them
they'd go this is fake some people
thought that it was actually
counterintelligence propaganda either by
the government or by the police that's
why the plan that we developed had teams
of recognized Road captains and other
truckers who were very much recognized
from the journeys to Edmonton to go out
in teams to the various blocks to
personally talk to as many truckers as
possible so they knew it was real but
notwithstanding that that plan that that
may have been engaged
um we did hear from Miss Belton
yesterday that she was of the view at
that time that it was fake news and in
fact she put a video out on Tick Tock
that said it was fake news is that
correct
uh I don't I can't recall I think that
was played yesterday sorry yes right
correct and so even at that time there
was still a lack of clarity even amongst
organizers as to whether there was or
was not a deal
um I would say I would say it
differently
I would say that subsequent to leaving
Ottawa when they've reflected their
remembering events differently because
there are emails
sure there may be emails but but the
tick tock video was put out to whomever
Miss belton's following consisted of
correct fair enough right
um and so I just want to bring up you
mentioned that the flyer that got
circulated can we bring that up please
that's hrf1259
thank you
if we could scroll down to the bottom of
the the notice here we this is obviously
the notice we saw earlier that got
circulated correct sorry if we could go
yes right there it's perfect
is this the the correct version I
believe so and so we he actually if you
scroll down a little bit I can tell you
if it is
um
yes this is the final version and so we
see here that it says if we Sorry if
that's perfect uh the truckers on the
freedom Convoy board plan to start
repositioning our trucks forward on
Monday to consolidate our protest to the
streets in front of parliament there's
also room for trucks to relocate to 88
that's the site off out of the city
correct there's one of the three sites
that existed at the 88 is the exit 88
which I understand is near enbrom would
you agree with me that no one nowhere in
this letter does it say that 75 percent
of the trucks are going to have to leave
the city as part of this deal obviously
right so there may have been a lack of
clarity about that issue as well
um
there was a lack of clarity about many
things
but
um most of the truckers would have
uh some of them wanted to go
some of them wanted to go well just like
look at Mr Barber first he had his truck
downtown on Wellington and on his own
initiative he moved it out to arm prior
or emberham one of the two on his own
initiative he didn't want his truck
downtown
others wanted to do the same thing
these trucks were covered in salt it's
not a good thing to do for a long time
there was they'd set up truck washes at
these places
Mr Barber wanted big red clean
so
um
this was not to be a precise document to
enumerate every Nuance of what we felt
was going on at the time
fair enough but you would agree and we
saw evidence of that in the video at
Rito in Sussex you would agree that
where there was a lack of clarity about
what the police were up to it created
challenges for the police in in managing
the situation is that a fair assessment
it is and that's the the learning from
the video
um because I you saw me walking with the
plts we kept walking and I had a meeting
with them and Tamara was there as well
if you pause the video you'll actually
see us walk past Tamera and then she
comes up and we talk and we're like okay
what are our lessons learned here
how do we do this differently and number
one was don't do it at night
don't do it at night that's why we shut
down the moves on partly on the Monday
because it was getting dark that was a
huge error and Tom marazzo had actually
said earlier on we don't make any moves
at night it's just too dangerous but it
also changed the dynamic of the crowd
but and that's why we needed this
coordination with the police we were
very optimistic with the truckers and a
lot of them went out it wasn't just
Chris there were several of them that
were on their feet moving if you look at
some of the videos You'll see them
running along the sidewalk you'll see
the police cars and then you see the
trucks and you see Chris running
and and we were doing it and the PLT
were alongside doing that as well
correct in terms of trying to get uh
truckers to move in in response to the
deal
uh they weren't trying to get truckers
moved they were trying to get the other
people in the police to agree that the
truckers could move on the Tuesday
Morning a delegation of plts arrived
unexpectedly for the first time ever at
the Swiss Hotel I was in a room working
on the letter with Tamara
for the Prime Minister and the premiers
with the one that's been put in evidence
I got a knock on the door the plts were
there I went in and that's on the
Tuesday
they said
like they sense something was wrong like
the trucks are all wanting to move but
they said to me it was only a 24-hour
deal
he said look at the letter
would a large logistical exercise the
mayor's letter will take 24 to 72 hours
he looked embarrassed he went over into
the corner by the bathroom he got on the
phone turned around his face was a
little red and he said to everybody
sorry major miscommunication we're gonna
go out and try and get the trucks moving
so it was the plts were not trying to
convince trucks to move they were
dealing with the police hierarchy and
trying to get them whoever kept blocking
to stop the blocking
but I think after that miscommunication
was clarified PLT did work with
protesters and ultimately some trucks
did move not on the Tuesday no I'm
talking about in general in response to
the city deal some trucks moved oh yeah
over 100 Vehicles two over two city
blocks were cleared on Albert 100
Vehicles left the the downtown including
around 40 trucks 23 of which I know it
was 23 because I reported the 23 count
from Chris he phoned me and me I said
how many you have on Wellington he said
we moved 23 to Wellington if you look at
my text message you'll see 23 onto
Wellington but it was 40 semis moved in
total the others left and we know for
sure one of them went straight home okay
here well over your time could I just
ask one more question thank you
um you were here when superintendent
Drummond testified and he testified that
there were challenges with getting some
of the truckers to move in response to
that deal do you have any reason to
disbelieve that evidence from
superintendent drama no we anticipate
stated that there would be some holdouts
but we also knew that they wanted to be
part of the group and we anticipated
that once the big most of them moved the
holdouts we didn't want to just be
sitting there by themselves and they
would move and you testified that you
you were taking that on faith is that
correct uh we that was our expectation
and it bore out to be true on the Monday
thank you those are my questions and
thank you for the Indulgence
okay uh
Council for former Chief slowly
foreign
good afternoon to the record Tom Curry
for for chief slowly
um you were present uninterrupted here
in Ottawa February if I have it February
2 to the 21st uh 19 days yes and
you've described for the commission or
your observations of the scene on the
ground
um Did You observe the enforcement
action that was taken yes
um the the vantage point we had uh Miss
chipik and I we set up a little
um
you know operation center of our own
because we also had to monitor the bail
applications and coordinate with the
criminal legal teams and we could see we
had the view of the back side of the
Westin and that tunnel so we saw all the
police the all the the the highway buses
coming in with the police filing off
and then we also of course had the
television on
um so we were watching the live streams
from CTV and CBC as we were looking out
our window and actually watching we were
quite high up like the 17th floor and
then getting various reports it was a
very very active environment had you
given advice about the implications of
the emergencies act the invocation of
the emergencies act and what it meant
for the protesters who were in the areas
that had been
um
who were affected by that uh I had given
advice to the board as I've testified on
the Wednesday
I had
um done the tick tock that the board and
Mr Barber requested on the Wednesday
I wasn't because Miss Leach instructed
myself in Mississippi to go to an
undisclosed location because she was
concerned
she had no idea what was going to happen
to us
uh we followed her instruction and after
that point I lost any ability to do any
large-scale communication that I can
recall right understood did you see the
Flyers the pamphlets the information
distributed by police to protesters yes
through the police liaison team to be
preciser
um when I say yes
there was they had a big blue outline
and some of them had a red outline they
were placed on the windshields
um and I saw that
was the Calm before the storms that was
the Thursday the Thursday there was a
ceremony at the war memorial that I
attended along with my wife and I
remember stopping and reading the
warning that if you didn't leave
um I'm going by memory uh that you're
you would be ticketed your vehicle would
be impounded and I can't recall what
else what else it said okay now you had
you told us you had involvement with the
PLT uh police liaison team members were
they uh Ottawa Police Service and OPP
that's correct okay any other
police officials that you dealt with
face to face or was it exclusively PLT
um I had interactions with with uh
chance meetings with other some OPP and
other police they were extremely
friendly uh very cordial very
non-threatening but in terms of any you
know official formal interactions it was
the plts okay thank you and of course
your your role evolved as you've tried
to provide the Convoy organizers with
the illegal strategy or input into their
strategy from a legal perspective and
advice to achieve their objectives is
that fair yes
your your contact with protesters
um I think you told the commissioner
just to clarify these are these are
independent operators
yes it reminded me of the ranchers in
Alberta yes indeed and you you told us
that they came here
and I'm not going to say every single
one but would it be right for the
commissioner to understand that those
protesters who you encountered came here
to Ottawa as part of the Convoy
intending to protest for the weekend but
were inspired to stay as a consequence
of their of the response that they
observed from Canadians as they came
here and once they arrived I think they
were inspired and they felt
charged with a new responsibility
to ensure the protest was successful
a responsibility they didn't realize
they would be invested in them
when they set out however I do know
having reviewed the evidence
that
in every instance that I have seen
Miss Leach was clear
that at no time did she say we're
leaving after the weekend I believe she
said we're going to stay until the
mandates are lifted right into the
independent operator protesters though
do you agree with me that because they
are that they if they're not on the road
they're going backwards financially
right correct and so would it be right I
understood your evidence to mean that
the protesters the independent operators
leaving aside the organizers and their
message that the protesters were
invested in a in a shorter protest than
they were inspired to commit to once
they got here is that fair
do you mean the opposite of what you
just said
independent operators who came here
weren't intending when they when they uh
let me start over again
the inspiration that you've spoken about
ins that that acted on them to stay here
and protest longer than they would have
originally so yeah I I thank you
um and I wasn't trying to be unfair to
you
um
I had a number of truckers say to me
that they originally planned as you've
already heard from Mr Barber you know to
be in the Convoy for a day
take join it for a certain distance and
then turn around and reverse course home
and then they found themselves in Ottawa
and found themselves in Ottawa for a
long for a long period yeah that's part
of that Synergy of growth that occurred
and
you you told us that there were some
challenging members even in among the
the top group of the leadership group
you've called Mr King I think in your
statement a rabble Rouser who who was at
least if not encouraging violence
tolerant of violence
yeah and I mean I think he he was very
angry and frustrated and really wanted
to fight hard to get the government to
change course and
not all of us
um use the same approaches Mr dickter
was undermining the leadership
I I or at least in part yeah I've just
never been able to understand Mr Victor
I mean and the other thing is that he
wasn't there that much because firstly
he had left early before I arrived
uh in late
um January and they had a car accident I
believe near Kingston and then he
returned on the Friday the 4th of
February and then early that evening at
approximately six or seven p.m as he was
leaving the front door of the Swiss of
the Ark Hotel he fell and badly broke
his ankle so then he was away at
hospital for a period of time then he
was restricted to his room because he
just had a wheelchair and crutches then
he had to go back for some surgery so he
was
he was out of the loop a lot right and
then Mr botter you've described the mou
was was not helpful to to the main
strategy you were the organizers were
pursuing Fair a distraction and false
hope now that meant all of it in the
aggregate in addition to the independent
minds of the independent operators that
controlling this entire group was very
challenging it was impossible and uh one
of the things could I show you please
just to see if this quote is accurate uh
in in HR
F please to register one three seven
nine just while that's coming up uh Mr
Wilson that you I think you gave an
interview to Mr Lawton who has published
or was publishing a book about the
events of the Convoy do you recall that
that's correct can I just ask you please
to to look at this and just maybe to the
top just to orient the witness
um
just a little higher there's an email I
think
here we go
do you recall seeing this yes could you
please
um
go then to
um I think it's page five
there is a quote attributed to you I
just want to make sure that it's right
there it is
um
and for context that Mr marazzo had also
spoken about some of the the events and
the last line of that part see it at the
top no one could force the truckers to
do anything they didn't want to do and
you seem to have agreed in that to say
we don't control them
we don't even know who they are no one
signed up it's not a curling bonds feel
it's not a golf tournament
and you made the comment that you can't
simply tell them what to do Fair comment
yeah and that's why we had to use other
approaches of moral suasion of
leadership
of
recognizing their fatigue
um recognizing the desire of many to
find a graceful and respectful way
a proud way to get back home
and the the Ottawa Police Service and
your interaction with them
um expected and reasonably expected that
a peaceful protest a lawful protest
would be held in their Community fair I
have to assume that to be true and the
unlawful you raise the issue with my
friend Mr Leon about the when did it
become an unlawful protest and uh you've
answered this question to others I won't
dwell on it but certainly you would
um accept that the blocking of Municipal
roads the violation of noise bylaws and
other forms of what might Loosely be
described as harassment as part of that
demonstration would be a challenge for
police
in confining the protest to a lawful
protest is that fair well
if you and I
and I mean you and I happen to be of
walking down
um Wellington
on February 10th
and we were having a chat lawyer to
lawyer I don't think we would conclude
that you and I were breaking the law by
walking down in front of parliament you
know on on the sidewalk of Wellington
Street so this was the challenge is that
you had individuals who were who I had
told consistently when they asked you
know of course you can't park your truck
there and I always used
the analogy to the 401 which they got
yeah that I wouldn't be allowed to do
that this is no different
uh but for this potential I really
wouldn't get into it most of them would
officially induce Terror because they
were told to park there and then they
were barricaded in place
um
so it was this weird mix where you had
people lawfully in my view
walking mingling shopping
interacting
some showing signs some not some just
wanting to take it in
with others who were breaching various
parking bylaws and you know Municipal
ordinances and provincial statutes and
just a couple of quick things then Mr
commissioner the the in it on top of
that you also face the challenge of some
I think in your statement you may
describe them as strange people who had
descended into the pro into the protest
often in the evening often on the
weekends some Sovereign citizens others
who were uh I think you may have labeled
them troublemakers that was a challenge
for the Convoy organizers to deal with
of course constantly and challenging
obviously for police and residents yes
and there was a good cooperation there
you know when that was the rule so
everybody had a block captain and if and
antifa was going to show up the rule was
you phone the police you call 911 and
the frustration for us was the next day
you know three people from antifa came
in and vandalized trucks the next day
the police chief or whichever one would
hold a press conference and say last
night we had three charges for property
damage in the downtown core and we're
like
you closely watched the signals coming
from all levels of government including
the Police Services Board here in Ottawa
and the chief chief slowly correct yeah
our most acute concern was the level of
pressure we saw building on the police
slowly from the Police Services Board
that's what motivated Mr marazzo uh to
take a series of steps to cause the city
meeting to facilitate
um some action to reduce pressure
including through your efforts with Mr
French to avoid what I think in one of
your text messages to him was a
bloodbath yes and the first one though
was to it was two distinct strategies
one was immediate acute which was the
pressures we saw in slowly before he he
was no longer Chief and the other one
was a broader Exit Plan
thank you Mr Wilson thank you
okay thank you
next is the Ontario Provincial Police
good afternoon commissioner the opdopp
have no questions today okay thank you
the ccla please
uh good afternoon commissioner Eva
creepska for the Canadian civil
liberties Association uh Mr Wilson just
briefly
um were you still on the ground in
Ottawa when the financial institution
freezing order started to come into
effect
um yes just to be clear
um there was three instances related to
freezing that I was dealing with before
and no random order just off the top of
my head the earliest one was the threat
of an interpleter application by TD Bank
through their external Council the next
one was the ex-part a order obtained by
the Attorney General of Ontario under
the criminal code declaring the
donations proceeds of crime then the
next was a
freeze order
of sorts
um and then we had the emergency
measures the financial measures and then
after that we had the meriven junction
about the financial measures under the
emergencies act yes
can you just uh did people come to you
from the freedom Convoy and ask you for
advice with respect to the orders and
relate to you how they were affecting
them and can you just provide a if they
did could you just provide a summary of
how the orders were affecting affecting
them if they came to you to speak to you
about that every one of them did in real
time and they were finding out at
different times I still remember one of
them coming to me and saying I just got
a phone call from my wife she's at the
supermarket she was with the kids
grocery cart was full she went to pay
with the debit card it didn't work
there's a lineup of people what's going
on because now the conveyor is full with
the next person's groceries
um and then she tried her visa card and
her second credit card and none of it
worked and she had to leave the store in
great embarrassment and phoned her
spouse and said what is going on
um we had other people that were trying
to put gas in their vehicles and
couldn't uh there was more than one
instance where people needed to get
prescriptions filled could not
um and then subsequent to that
as we work to get the freezes lifted
and reach out to the bank we developed
this template email to write to the bank
to ask the bank to respond to us as
lawyers Miss chipik and I
um then we have received reports since
and to very recently that a number of
these people even though their bank
accounts were unfrozen
sorry Mr commissioner I just realized
how fast I was speaking
um after their accounts were frozen have
been denied credit applications
and I have explained to my clients and
others who contacted me that the
Canadian Bankers Association
representative who testified before the
house committee said that each of these
persons will have their accounts uh
their names marked flagged for life
thank you Mr Wilson those are all my
questions thank you commissioner
thank you
uh okay Convoy organizers any questions
we have no questions sir
thank you any re-examination
uh yes just two points um
Mr Wilson in response to my friend Mr
McKinnon's questions about uh whether
you were referring in that email
to the federal emergencies act I believe
you said that someone had heard from
some MPS that it was under
active discussion yes we'd heard it a
number of times over the course of the
week prior do you recall who was telling
you that
no it would have been someone coming
into the operations center that had
heard from an MP I remember hearing
because I would say well what's the
source and it was some MP and I can't
remember I don't believe it was
indicated as to which party whether it
was a liberal or democrat or
conservative MP but it was I guess there
was strong rumors over in the Parliament
that it was Act of under active
consideration
and in response to my friend Mr Champs
questioning you about the injunction I
think you acknowledged that um you you
did oppose the initial application yes
can you help me with this
um
I understood from your evidence that
your clients had been concerned for some
time about the the horn film yes and I I
believe you said that they took their
own action even before the injunction
uh the the the
truckers had agreed amongst themselves
and this is in the transcript and
represented I believe in an affidavit
actually before the Superior Court in
the adjunction application that they'd
put in this informal protocol of being
silent between uh eight and eight pm and
8 A.M Justice McLean on the Saturday
application had suggested the parties
consider agreeing to maybe allowing one
hour for horns during the noon hour
um but when we returned on the following
Monday uh that was something he wasn't
interested in entertaining
and so
um can you
tell us
if there was this concern
why was it that you were opposing the
injunction wouldn't it have been
consistent with your clients views to
have an injunction and stop people
blowing their horns the board was split
um other other
members and some of the truckers felt
that it was something that shouldn't be
that they shouldn't be restricted other
than the agreement they had for night
quiet
uh from being able to blow their horn
they thought it was part of their right
of protest so there wasn't unanimity in
the client group on on uh on that point
and the instructions that I in
Mississippi received were to oppose it
now I'm not now that Mr champ has
refreshed my memory thank you
foreign
so that completes the cross-examinations
I just have one one question and it's uh
it's with respect to something I believe
was heard early on was there an area
that was
allowed for protests or encouraged by
either the police or your group
to carry out uh protest other than on
Wellington Street I'd heard something
about near the war museum do you are you
aware of anything like that yeah no
there wasn't and that was one of our
frustrations Mr commissioner was that
we were always faced with this zero-sum
Choice with the police Liaisons we were
trying to I really believe that if we
could have a stepped type process you
know a
a ramping down
um and building off success and building
building trust but no it was always the
number of calls in the day and you if
you look at my phone logs you'll see the
number of calls in a day I was receiving
from the plts after I became more
involved in that
and it was always the same question
Keith what's the exit strategy you know
it was always when are everybody leaving
sort of thing okay so you're not aware
of an area near the war museum that was
uh that protests were allowed and were
carried out there was an area I believe
along if my geography is corrected it
may not be
um along the surge on a
uh where they had set up and you'll see
this there's photographs of it uh and I
don't know but I there was never any
discussion or offer from the plts
for anything other than ending the
protest and it's in totality
did you ever specifically ask the plts
for
a an area or a manner to continue the
protest no I did not other than taking
the steps of this de-escalation and
reducing the footprint to um uh to
Wellington so you didn't ask and they
didn't offer correct
okay well thank you very much uh for
your evidence we're going to take the
lunch break and come back in an hour
with a new witness thank you
machine is in recess for one hour
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
good afternoon Mr commissioner the next
witness is Tom marazzo
foreign
azzo will you swear on a religious
document or do you wish to affirm
I'd like to affirm please
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Thomas James
morazzo m-a-r-a-z-z-o
do you solemnly affirm that the evidence
to be given by you to this commission
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth I do thank you
good afternoon Mr marazzo good afternoon
my name is John Mather I'm one of the
commission Council
um through your Council you have
provided a statement about your
involvement in the protest in Ottawa is
that correct yes sir if we could pull up
hrf1595
um is this the statement that you've
provided yes it is have you reviewed it
before testifying yes I did is are there
any changes you wish to make no sir do
you adopt the contents of this statement
as accurate yes
I'm gonna ask you just a few questions
about your background
um I understand from the statement which
we can actually take down Mr clerk um is
that you were born and raised in Ontario
where did you grow up Niagara Falls and
St Catharines Ontario and where do you
live now
just outside of Napanee
and I understand that you're a father of
two children is that right yes sir
and you served in the armed forces for
25 years achieving the rank of Captain
is that correct yes
and then after leaving the Armed Forces
you earned an MBA no I had the NBA when
I was currently serving and then when I
retired from the military in 2015 I went
back to school and did a bachelor of
technology and software development
and where did you uh earn that Bachelor
Seneca yeah and then after that you
began working at Georgian College as a
part partial load teacher is that right
yes sorry
and as I understand it you lost that job
in 2021 is that correct yes can you
please explain to the commission what
happened
I was notified that the college had
adopted the province-wide
covid-19 vaccine mandates
and I had um
had some interactions with my union and
realized that the union was not going to
be supportive
and so
subsequent emails came out from the
president of the college herself
and my response to that was to
send an email to the president of the
college as well as Dean's the VP of HR
and as many other faculty as I could put
on this email I sent it internally to
the college not publicly
looking to express my my concern and
question you know I'm not a lawyer
obviously but questioning the legality
and sort of the morality of what they
were doing and um a few days later I was
terminated with cause and when was that
approximately September 13th of last
year so year September okay and uh what
were you doing between September 2021
and your arrival in Ottawa uh which
we'll get to in a minute which I
understand was in January 2022. yeah
um my former spouse and I sold our house
and we purchased land outside of Napanee
and then we moved to that area
and um
the plan really this year was to build a
house uh I cashed an RSP to live off of
while I was you know trying to build the
house and um really just
focus on that focus on my family uh the
level of tension in this country was
extreme to say the least and uh I really
wanted to focus on putting my my family
in a better situation
which meant actually going off grid if
if that was even possible
because as an unvaccinated person there
was a lot of rhetoric about actually
being able to participate in society
and so we we chose to sell the house we
purchased land we were going to build a
house and
um
I ended up we ended up in an apartment
together uh the three of us was my
daughter in uh just outside of Kingston
and we were there working on plans for
the house
and prior to participating in the
protests in Ottawa had you been
politically active no I was not
um and I understand it but please
correct me if I'm wrong that you've
never been a trucker no sir
um and you say in your statement that
you arrived in Ottawa on January 30th
which I believe was the first Sunday is
that sound right
okay
and
what brought you to Ottawa
through a mutual friend of mine in James
Bater and his wife Sandy I was contacted
on the phone that Sunday morning and I
was asked if I would uh
take a phone call with James and Sandy
just to discuss some logistical
organizational ideas around the Convoy I
had been tracking the Convoy as it was
coming across Canada and I was
absolutely a supporter of it I really
loved what this whole entire Freedom
Convoy was about
so in the in that discussion which
lasted approximately 15 minutes
James had asked me if I would come to
Ottawa and uh
support the Convoy in any way that I
could in terms of getting organized
doing logistical stuff
and within three hours of that phone
call I was actually at the arc Hotel
who was the mutual friend
her name is Jane Moffett I believe I had
only ever met her once in person
and that was that I actually have I
think I spoken to her one time since the
Convoy
when you first spoke with Mr bowder what
did you know about him nothing
what did you learn about him when you
spoke about him spoke with him sorry
I learned that there was
um
a great need to get organized and from
him personally I I the details I never
got any details about him personally or
his wife Sandy I knew there were two
people that
um were trying to affect the change in
this country and I wanted to to help
them out so
there was an opportunity for me to
employ the skills that I have gained
over my career and so I recognized it as
a great opportunity to get involved
do you have any sense how James bouter
identified you as someone who might be
able to assist
I think Jane had mentioned to him that I
was a retired military and I think
that's pretty much it
after that initial phone conversation
with Mr better how often were you two in
communication
I had seen James when I first arrived at
the ark and then it was somewhat
sporadic I think he moved to a different
location I don't know where I know he
had a room in the ark
and I would occasionally run into him my
contact with him was very sporadic
when you arrived at the arc hotel in
Ottawa what did you learn about the
organization of the protests
really when I walked into the to the ark
I was brought into a boardroom and there
were several truckers and two Ops uh
police officer Sergeant Fong Lee
Sergeant Lou carvello
and the meeting had already begun and I
was I was asked to turn my cell phone
off or remove it from the room and give
the police my name which I did
um and then I just quietly sat there
James actually brought me into the room
and introduced me uh and I believe he
oversold my my career uh I know there
was people in the room that actually
thought I was a retired general which is
clearly not the case
and um
so I sat there quietly and I just
listened and
it was a very telling meeting I got the
feeling that after two days of the
Convoy Convoy being there this was the
very first Collective meeting that they
had actually had in a room I could be
wrong about that but I didn't get the
sense that this group of people had ever
come together with the Ottawa Police
sorry or any representative of the
government of any kind and uh we've
heard the name Fong Lee was it your
understanding that those uh him and the
other officer were members of the PLT
they were
and who are the other truckers in the
room
I my the details of that are a little
sketchy they weren't all truckers uh
Dana Metcalf was somebody I sat beside
Joe Borgo was in the room Brian Olson
his
um son-in-law
there was uh Bridget Belton I believe
was in the room
um some of the other names I just I I
didn't know who they were when I first
walked into the room so I can't really
account for who everybody was in the
room and return return to uh who you
were dealing with in a minute
um could you just perhaps provide some
more context or an explanation about how
it was the case that you received a
phone like what what drove you to go to
Ottawa after receiving a phone call from
a man that you'd never met before but
you didn't know anything about that
would have you leave you know your wife
and your kids to go to Ottawa what what
drove you to do that
to be perfectly honest I think it was a
case of fear
I had um
over the time of covid
noticed
things that I never before believed that
I would see in in Canada related to the
way the police and bylaw and the
government were going after Canadians
and for the first time in my life I was
you know actually afraid of police and I
have several friends that are police
officers
and I had a phone call with Randy
Hillier one day and Randy didn't know
who I was this was uh I sent an email to
him in Roman baber and other people and
months later his office had returned the
call and Randy doesn't even recall the
the conversation and they said you know
I spent 25 years of my life in the
military and for the first time I'm
actually afraid in my own country
and
he said you know never be afraid like
you can't be afraid of the police or the
government they're they're here to serve
us
and I think for me that kind of flipped
a switch uh where I was like I I went
from thinking I'm afraid to get uh
arrested or beaten by the police or
getting an 880 fine to you know what now
I want the fine
I'm done I'm not going to hide from
these people anymore
um
and so that started to mentally
transition the way I thought and then we
came to a point where I thought well at
some point the the lawyers are going to
step in and intervene and and start
protecting the public and and they
didn't except for a few
then when the coveted man the vaccine
came out I thought well the medical
community is going to stand up and and
put a stop to this because of informed
consent and they and they didn't uh
except for a few
and it was the truckers that gave me an
opportunity to actually get into you
know fighting for for my kids rights
okay
the phone call you mentioned with Mr
Hillier was that in the context of the
Ottawa protest or did that happen before
no it was months before when I still was
employed uh and still lived in uh I I
don't know if I was employed I think it
was
um I still lived in my old house prior
to selling it and moving to the Napanee
area
when you arrived in Ottawa did you have
a sense of how long you were planning on
being there
No I um
I had a bag
five changes of clothes
um
I believed that at the time I would go
there
get organized uh start to just kind of
develop a daily sustainment plan and a
routine and then I would I would look
for somebody who was able to basically
take over from me and then I would move
on uh if I wasn't required anymore
so when you arrive and you know you've
spoken to Mr bowder on the phone he
brings you into this room where there's
protesters and some police
what happens next how do you integrate
yourself into the organization that
particular meeting actually got quite
animated very loud I remember Bridget
being quite upset with Sergeant Lee
where she had made a comment of
basically to the effect of what are you
going to shoot us in the streets like
that's where the level had gone and uh
it started to calm down
eventually the two police officers
departed from the meeting and uh we all
just kind of sat around and regrouped I
think people went for breaks
and then um
we people left the room I remember
Bridget and I being in the room and
right around that time I think uh
somebody brought in the map
and so
I had learned there was a list of places
that the the Ops had requested that we
not go near uh like roads that we stay
off of and I said okay great we've got
the map
let's start marking the map and and for
me what was really important because I
had spent um my son has a a very severe
heart condition
and I spent uh Christmas this year in
the hospital uh with my son
and
so you know I'm very aware of keeping
the emergency lanes open it is an
important issue for me
so the first thing we did was start
identifying uh hospitals we identified
the police station fire departments
vulnerable infrastructure
and then started to plan out the routes
to those uh in a in an effort really to
make sure that those lanes were always
accessible
so that's really where we started and
then we I needed to get a handle on
where all the vehicles were were located
and that was a Monumental task because
at the time
trucks were coming to the city trucks
were leaving the city there was a huge
uh just change in our overall
um
size of the Convoy overall so really
that that first day was about just
getting a handle on where everybody was
and and the size uh and scope of the
Convoy
I take it that this involved you meeting
a lot of people you had never met before
yes everybody did anyone ask you who you
were and what you were doing there James
had introduced me initially into that
meeting so everyone just realized there
was an army guy in the room and uh
so
I my sense was right away that
nobody was
in charge particularly uh there were
strong personalities people with strong
opinions but for some reason and I don't
know why uh I think it was just the fact
that I was an army guy that people
assumed that I was going to be able to
to get organized uh and to be perfectly
honest it was quite
it's nothing unusual for an army officer
to be able to do what I did
um but it was just
trying to get organized when you say in
charging it organized do you mean get
organized are you talking about
logistics Logistics my focus was really
just on Logistics in a in a sustainment
plan
um not any other
um I I wasn't thinking in a tactical
sense I was thinking just purely in
sustainment to make sure that people
could get food fuel
um money if they needed it for for
whatever purpose
um that was really what my my thinking
was at the time so emergency lanes fuel
food money anything else that you would
consider as part of being responsible
for Logistics there was um
the the a big task which was really
really difficult was just to find the
numbers and the composition of all the
different types of trucks
um and where everybody was scattered and
then I learned that we had trucks out on
the parkway we had Vehicles out on 88
armed prior locations I never actually
made it to but it was just trying to get
a good situation situational awareness
or essay of uh what was happening on the
ground
when you arrived on the 30th and I guess
probably moving into the uh the 31st did
you come to understand that there had
already been people in Ottawa who were
working on food Logistics and money
I did not know that until I believe late
that first evening
and that is that is when I met uh Tamara
and uh found out that there was an
alternate or alternate um
coordination Center at the Swiss Hotel
okay can you explain what did you learn
about the alternate coordination Center
the Swiss Hotel just that it that it had
existed in that in those conversations
uh it was agreed that
my scope of what I was interested or
involved in was now going to be really
cut in half and I was quite happy about
that because I didn't want to get into
the situation where I had to think about
um security public speaking and the
stage and all that stuff that I had
learned about I didn't have to worry
about doing first aid that was going to
be handled by the other group we were
just really going to focus on the
logistics in terms of feeding Fuel and
then truck movements that was another
piece of my responsibility would be
moving vehicles in and out and around
the city was it the case that no one was
organizing feeding and fuel before your
arrival no and that's the surprising
thing because that was happening I mean
that just that just does happen I mean
the the number of supplies in in fuel
that was coming into the city
um that actually did make what I was
trying to do a lot more easy uh because
that was just organically happening
anyway I mean when people are hungry
they go on go searching for food
I'm gonna do this in a bit of a two-part
question sure and bear with me if it
presents a problem but can you explain
to me what was happening in terms of
where food and fuel was coming from
before your arrival and then what
changed after your arrival or what what
you did to change anything
to be honest I don't know where where
they were getting their supplies on
Route to Ontario or uh or to Ottawa but
I had seen a lot of social media videos
um and seen people on the overpasses
um at truck stops so I know that all
along the way they were collecting food
and donations
um everything that I had seen on social
media and so when I believe when they
arrived in Ottawa the um
it was the the intention of the public
to continue to come to the city of
Ottawa in in
give more supplies as much as they could
possibly uh give did you learn anything
about the adopt a trucker campaign that
was being spearheaded by Chris Guerra I
learned about it a few days later I
didn't really know much about it I my
interactions with Chris uh were very
little
um it wasn't inside it wasn't something
inside of my area of influence that I
was concerned about
um it was something that was kind of
going on in the background so I didn't
interact with it
how is fuel supplied to the truckers
that were in the downtown core
uh
there were I think different sources
coming in
um
sorry I can't remember the name of the
the type of vehicle it's a fuel truck
um
it's probably written I'm not a trucker
so some of the lingo I wasn't fully
conversant on I just I know that they
were getting a lot of fuel but it wasn't
until after uh it was forbidden to bring
in more fuel with with bigger trucks and
stuff to refuel them people started to
bring in the Jerry cans by hand and was
that something you assisted in
organizing no no that was um by that
point my role had kind of
been modified it had sort of
transitioned a little bit later on about
a week after so
um I just knew they were getting in fuel
the truckers were taking care of their
own Fuel and there was no shortage of
the fuel
um up until the Ottawa Police forbid
them from bringing in trucks uh trucks
of fuel
and then it was Jerry kantz and that was
not my idea that was just people being
very very industrious did you do
anything to coordinate fuel into the
downtown Ottawa at any point I did not
have to no
foreign s you said you did was get a
sense of the number and composition of
the types of truck
two first question how did you go about
doing that
I literally had to go and send people
out and count trucks in the streets
and do you recall what was the result of
that calculation
well the there was different areas so I
remember speaking to one person who
after it took four days just to get that
magic number of 322.
um
that was a head count that was literally
somebody going out with sticky notes on
streets and then actually breaking down
by vehicle it was incredibly difficult
to get an accurate count because
trucks kept coming and trucks kept going
in and out of the city or out to
different locations so at some point I I
just kind of gave up on that as a
something that I really needed to focus
on I was just kind of more interested in
you know general terms where do we have
Vehicle Center of mass kind of thing not
uh I didn't need the details of of where
they where they were but at some point
in time it was determined there was
roughly 322 trucks that was our account
and I knew honestly I knew that that
count I I guess I shouldn't say honestly
when I've sworn else but um I I really I
didn't have a lot of confidence in the
number just because the influx and out
Flux Of Vehicles so even when I got that
number it wasn't overly valuable to me
at any point did you feel that you had a
handle on the number of trucks that were
in in the city and then were coming and
going or is that something that always
changed it always changed and again it
just it lost value in knowing that
specific number the the
point of interest for me was that we had
more trucks uh concentrated on
Wellington
with respect to clearing emergency lanes
the commission has heard evidence
including from Mr Barber and Mr Wilson
that the uh that the emergency lanes
that would let me back up there the
protesters weren't able to keep the
lanes clear on Rideau Sussex and at Kent
is that sound correct
sometimes yes that's true was there any
other locations or intersections where
the emergency lanes were not left open
to your knowledge my understanding was
the uh when that did happen and it
happened occasionally for example I uh
Sergeant Lee had been
let's say uh
vigorously contacting me to clear out
one of the intersections and he kept
asking me you know if I've gone down
there and checked it so I finally I
didn't send a runner I went down for
myself to see it for myself and what I
discovered was there was
um heavy equipment owned by the city
concrete barriers and five Ottawa police
officers standing in the intersection it
wasn't being blocked by any of our
people at all so I I you know there was
a there was a give and take where
we were sent or I was sent or other
people that I was with were sent to go
look at an intersection only to find out
it wasn't even us and um I had two
members that I was working with that
routinely when when we were asked by Ops
to go and check on a safety lane or an
intersection or something that was
blocking safety our two people would go
down and physically speak to the drivers
and and get them to open up those Lanes
and so it's my understanding that those
efforts were generally successful except
on Kent Street is that correct
um I can't say the the street are you is
that Kent is
um right near the Rito or sorry I'm I'm
fuzzy on some of the streets okay so the
evidence has been there's been two
locations one's Rito Sussex we'll talk
about in a moment to your knowledge was
there another location that was where
the emergency lanes were not open no the
only the only sticking point was
um Rito
and even on Rito I spoke to one of the
drivers personally and I said you need
to make sure you keep a safety Lane and
he said they have twice moved out of the
way they sit in their trucks and they
listen for ambulances or they listen for
sirens and if they hear it they move the
truck out of the way because three times
they had uh listened to the Ottawa
Police who said you know can you please
move the vehicle
and they would move the vehicle and the
Ottawa Police would move their cars in
that spot and they would trick the
drivers so the the drivers at Rideau
said we're not falling for it again
we'll sit in our truck we will listen
for sirens and when we hear it we will
move and then and he assured me that in
two occasions they did exactly that
do you know who you were speaking with
who gave you that information
I don't know his name I know where he
was parked uh he was parked um
I I know where he was parked
um I don't know his name
I know he had a a paper bag full of
letters from children
I understand from your statement and
from some of the evidence that you had
several interactions with the people who
are at either Rito and Sussex is that
correct yes sir what did you come to
learn about who was in that intersection
there was a Polish contingent polish
Canadian contingent there was uh French
Canadians
um and I know there was anglophones on
that corner there was many different
groups of people on that corner
um
yeah
um the commission has heard many
adjectives to describe the group but
I'll put to you uh the suggestion that
they've been described as difficult or
standoffish would you agree with that
I know there was a reputation prior to
me going there and speaking to some of
them and um
I didn't I didn't get the sense that
they were difficult I I got the sense
that they were
they were there for their own reasons
which were separate from the overall uh
Convoy itself the the most of the people
that I was interacting with
but I got the the feeling they were
there for their families uh for their
communities I know one driver I spoke to
said that he didn't have anything to go
back to until these mandates were were
lifted
and uh they were quite determined I
didn't find them to be difficult I just
there was a little bit of a language
barrier with one of the the French
speaking uh men that I spoke to
but I didn't find it difficult I just
found it a different style of motivation
um we've heard a bit again about with
respect to French French Canadian
protesters there were you familiar with
the term farfa does at the time not
until I've been sitting in the audience
here
um
would you say there was anything
different in the makeup of the group at
Rito Sussex than at any other locations
just that they were more independent
than the rest of the Convoy
as you began to work on clearing
emergency lanes interacting with the
police working with the protesters what
did you come to understand the
organization of the protest movement to
be
very very decentralized
um
I learned that the the truckers were not
from Big organizations that they were
actually independent owner operators of
their vehicles
and that you really
you really had to be respectful of the
position that they were in they were
individual business owners they weren't
going to take orders from anybody you
know they weren't going to take orders
from me just because I said you know I
had no legitimate or legal authority to
tell anyone to do anything and I wasn't
signing anyone's paycheck this was a
case where you you know you had to use
your soft skills to to communicate and
get people to buy in with what you're
trying to do collectively
to your mind were there any leader or
leaders of the movement
I think there were people that were in
leadership positions uh you know for
example Chris Barber is a very
charismatic person uh he's an honest
person he'll he'll just tell you the way
it is and and he was very very effective
at communicating with with truckers and
it didn't matter if what their uh you
know backgrounds where he they were all
truckers and so Chris was very
influential speaking with truckers
Tamara was very influential Bridget was
influential in her own way
um and many of the other people that
were there working out of the Ark uh had
developed networks and they were always
trying to broaden the network to
communicate uh the things that we were
all trying to do and that was a lot of
stuff was like we've got speeches on
Saturday trying to communicate that to
the public and and really work the
social media angles because we were
getting vilified
um badly in in such a grotesque way by
the the Legacy Media that we made a
conscious effort at one point to go into
the trucks with cameras and get truckers
to tell their stories on social media so
they were the the leaders were out there
developing that kind of messaging to get
out to all the supporters across Canada
that had given us 20 million dollars to
be there
did you ever interact with Pat King
while you're in Ottawa I did okay and
can you tell us what what your
interactions were and what your
impression of him was
really my my interactions were very very
little with with uh Pat King
and it wasn't overly impactful to be
honest I just um
I had spent maybe two to three occasions
in his presence and it was very little
um
I know that at one point there were some
slow rolls and I had requested that one
of the other members go with Pat because
I know Pat was leading that Convoy uh
and I I made sure that uh the person I
sent
kept him well behaved are you talking
about the slow rolls at the airport yes
sir okay yeah um and why did you think
you needed to send someone to keep Pat
King well behaved because I only knew
Pat through reputation uh in one or two
interactions with him and uh I didn't
want there to be any
um any confusion as to what they were
there to do it was to really just do a
slow roll and to guarantee that in no
way did we we stop at the airport
because we were well aware that there
was an orange uh helicopter route for
the hospital and we wanted to make sure
that we had no impact on any air
ambulance ability to get in and out of
that airport we had no intention of
slowing down or disrupting the airport
and I wanted to make sure that we had
somebody that was going to guarantee
that we weren't there to close down or
lock down the airport or disrupt the air
ambulance we just wanted to
basically send a message that uh you
know we we can still move around the
city
so I taken so one of your concerns was
potentially that Mr King might try to
shut down the airport or blockade the
airport
it was it was just on my part to be
honest in in some of the others that we
discussed it uh it was just a precaution
just to make sure we
we also believe that if we told him not
to do something like that he would
listen I don't
so you take a precaution when you're
concerned that something might happen so
is that yes is that what you were
concerned would happen yes okay and was
your concern based on Mr King's
reputation as you as you indicated yes
just as just solely on his reputation
that was it and what was Mr King's
reputation
um a little bit of a um
foreign
card I remember in a meeting once that I
had uh jokingly referred to him as a
hand grenade going off in a room and
scaring everybody else that he was it
was going to explode and and it was a
bit of a joke
um he laughed everybody else seemed to
think it was funny but it was kind of
like funny because yeah that's true
um but just reputation-wise he was a
little bit of a wild card and I just
wanted to make sure that we were able to
to contain anything like that are you
concerned it was possible that Mr King
may not engage in peaceful protest that
was never a concern that I shared or had
and you mentioned that you had dealt
with Mr bowder sporadically yes um after
the initial phone conversation and the
introduction at any point did you become
aware of uh the memorandum of
understanding which I'm sure you've
heard about over the last a few weeks or
the last few days at least yes sir I I
did hear of the the memorandum of
understanding
I learned about it once it was submitted
already to I believe the governor
general and I think the media had a copy
and I had read it
uh again I'm no lawyer but I know it
wasn't written by a lawyer it wasn't
very well written and
um I remember having a conversation once
I learned about the mou
with somebody that I believed to be
involved in drafting the mou and uh it
was a private one-on-one meeting and I
said you you must retract that you you
if you do not retract that uh or pull it
back or or put the the genie back in in
the bottle we are going to denounce it
uh it made us look
like we were here for a completely
different purpose than what we were
there for it it really muddied the
waters and um
I don't know if as a result of that
conversation they pulled it back I just
know that the next day it was
sort of retracted when you say it made
it look like you were there for a
completely different purpose what was
that purple I I had read it in as far as
I was concerned it was uh we were there
for the mandates that mou was there for
a different purpose and I don't remember
the details of it to be honest I skimmed
through it it was not very well written
um and so I didn't think it was credible
I didn't think it was appropriate and I
certainly didn't think that the
government was ever going to uh suddenly
resign uh because
somebody sent them a memo
you may not remember the details but was
your concern that what the mou appeared
to call for was something that was
undemocratic
what I believed when I read it was that
they thought that it was a legal process
that they were that they believed it was
a mechanism of government that they were
trying to uh initiate
even though
I'm no constitutional scholar by any
means but I could tell that it was not
going to go anywhere
um you said you had a conversation with
someone where you said this this must be
denounced who was that conversation with
I believe his name is Martin
Martin brodman
and it's commissions understanding that
Mr broadman was someone who was
associated with Mr bowder is that
correct yes sir
and did he seem receptive to your
message I think he was upset
uh it didn't the meeting didn't end on a
bad note it wasn't like he was he was
upset about it he'd been working on this
I believe since the the year before the
Convoy even arrived this was something
that they were working on they thought
they were doing something that was
legitimately recognized by the uh the
legal system
um and he was upset that he wasn't
getting support but I believe at the end
of that meeting he said okay we will
we'll pull it back
um
you've been referred to in media and
some of the documents we've received as
the spokesperson for the protesters did
you identify yourself to anyone as the
spokesman no sir sorry spokesperson no
did you see yourself as a spokesperson
the last two days on the 18th and 19th
of February
was the one or the the two times only
during the Convoy that I had chosen to
speak without being
uh or without discussion with other uh
members of the Convoy and that was
because I felt that given the previous
Media stuff that I had done
um alternative Media or live streams
that I would be recognized by the public
as somebody associated with
um maybe some of the other people like
Tamara and and Chris and and Bridget
because everybody else was either out of
the city or were already incarcerated so
there was nobody left that I believed
the public would recognize as a credible
person to deliver those two final days
worth on the 18th and 19th and that's
the only time other than that I was
always asked to speak
um on the live streams right and you did
on multiple occasions either speaking on
live streams or in sort of forms of
press conferences is that fair yes
and it's our understanding but again
correct me if I'm wrong the first one
was on February 7th does that sound
correct seventh or eighth yes and then
uh on the 10th and I did clean up some
of the confusion that I had caused on
the uh the initial
well let's uh talk about some of that
confusion right now then so you you uh
as our again it's our understanding it's
the seventh um yes that you you gave a
press conference Mr Barber was there
miss Belton was there miss Leach was
there and some of the other organizers
yes you know what I'm referring to I do
and
um how did that press conference come
come about
I do not remember the person who asked
me or the group of people who asked me
to uh to speak
um but I
had
I believe just previous to that we we it
was the night after the or the night of
the Coventry raid
that um we did a live stream as a larger
group and it seemed to go okay with uh I
guess my presence on a on a video
so I was asked the next day to deliver a
a message on a live stream and I don't
remember who asked me to do it I just
know that I was asked to do it and that
I would be accompanied by several
members of well I think the entire board
as well as two doctors
who were in attendance in that video
so if we could pull up com
50884 and as it's coming up Mr morozo
this is you can confirm if it is the
case but we understand that this is the
the press conference and then this is it
this is it okay different sources if you
could pause it please and go to the 725
mark
foreign
and then play from 7 25 to about 8 21.
I'm home until the job is done
okay I am not calling for violence I'm
not expecting you to get into your
vehicle drive here and and create uh
problems create crimes
okay that's not what we're saying
strengthen numbers we got sent here to
send a message the message isn't getting
through he's not getting it and I
apologize if I'm bashing the guy but
honestly from my assessment he's got a a
22 caliber mind in a 357 world
okay let's get at a table for god's
sakes enough hiding
I'm willing I'm willing to sit at a
table with the conservatives and the NDP
and the blog as a coalition I'll sit
with the governor general
you put me in somebody and put us at the
table with somebody
that actually cares about Canada
um one quick question and then I'm going
to ask you about the statement that
caused confusion when you made a
reference to a 22 caliber mine in a 357
world this has been something that's
been uh reported on it were you
referencing Mr Prime Minister Trudeau I
was
um in the video you say I'm willing to
sit at a table can I can I just continue
to answer because I've been verified in
the media for that one yeah I didn't
mean to cut you off please go ahead it's
a joke I I literally meant to comment on
the man's intelligence it was a joke
sorry understood sorry yeah you can take
the video down thank you then you said
I'm willing to sit at a table with the
conservatives in the NDP and the block
as a coalition I'll sit with the
governor general put us at the table
with somebody that actually cares about
Canada yes what did you mean when you
said that
in no way did I ever mean or intend for
us to be part of the government I wanted
them to come and sit literally at a
table and start figuring out a way
to
Be an Effective opposition to the
Liberal Party of Canada because we
weren't seeing any opposition at all
with the official opposition of Canada
you know if the conservative party had
been effective as being an opposition we
may not be in this room today but
instead they just didn't oppose anything
that was happening to Canadians as to
why we were there and when we got there
there was no attempt at any level of
government
um
Municipal provincial federal government
to even talk to us to get in a room with
us
and you've heard the testimony here
nobody ever wanted to even have a
conversation with us so
I want to say that I was I was quite
sick throughout my time during the
Convoy and uh you know I I was exhausted
I was dehydrated I you know lots of
stuff in in that particular moment of
that video I did misspeak it wasn't very
clear what I was getting at
two days later I tried to clarify that
or three days later but what we wanted
was for the government anybody we were
desperate it was a it was a basically a
cry for for help to come in and sit down
and do this democratically and that is a
mechanism of government because as we've
seen since then or even during the
Convoy the NDP and the Liberals were
forming a coalition that the public had
not yet known about
and so you know forming a coalition
seemed to be something like we were
trying to nudge them motivate them in
any way we could just to talk to us
and to this day
they've never spoken to us ever
some media Outlets reported on those
comments to suggest that you were saying
that the protesters wanted to form
governments in which they would be in a
coalition with the opposition parties
but the protesters themselves would form
part of the government you know what I'm
talking about that is and that's that is
my fault that the way I I phrase that in
the video
um that is not what my intention was but
the way I phrased it I can understand
that being confusing but it's not what I
intended we wanted no part of being the
government
we wanted the government to do the
governing but to listen to us I
understand that you spoke again on
February 10th and attempted to clarify
your servants I understand that but did
you take any steps to uh clarify what
you meant with the media Outlets who
were reporting
that the protesters wanted to form a
coalition government no I was not in
charge of direct
um
contact I had no direct contact with the
media and as far as I was concerned uh
my belief was if they actually started
to do their job and Report fairly we
would reward them with contact or I
would or whatever not necessarily me but
if they continued down the path of
constantly vilifying and lying about us
uh I didn't see the point really of
talking to them at all we were effective
highly effective at getting out
everything we wanted to get out to the
public through alternative and social
media
so you didn't make any efforts to go to
those orders who uh who had reported no
a different interpretation and say
that's wrong can you please fix it no
and so you don't know whether or not
they would have issued a correction or
uh issued as maybe not a correction a
follow-up story you just don't know I
don't know and they never reached out to
talk to me from my knowledge either
um
after the February 7th uh press
conference
um Benjamin dictor who's a witness we'll
hear from later uh send out a press
release saying that only uh himself Mr
Barber Miss Leach and a woman named
Dagny were authorized to speak on behalf
of the protesters do you know what I'm
referring to
I I do vaguely I do yes did you ever
have an interaction with Mr dikter where
you discussed who was authorized to
speak on behalf
my my interactions with him were
very like I think if I added up all the
entire time I've ever spent with him I
I'd be lucky if it was 15 20 minutes
that I've ever spent in a room with him
so I
I can't really say for certain when or
what was ever discussed with him I was
just not interacting with him at all
I'm going to move forward a bit well not
that much for it a day forward to your
meeting with Steve kanalakis
um uh which again the commission has
already heard a fair bit of evidence
about
um but I take it you you recall meeting
with Mr Cadillac yes sir why did you
want to meet with Mr kanalakis I
actually didn't
I didn't I had grown incredibly
frustrated with the police liaison
officers that I was dealing with
and uh I had requested through them to
talk to an inspector
and I had also made that same concern
known to the police liaison officer from
the Ontario Provincial Police
and I didn't want to uh
interact with the two sergeants that I
had been been dealing with anymore I
wanted somebody who was in a better
position
to make decisions and also I wasn't 100
sure that our concerns were being raised
up the chain of command in a in a way
that I was comfortable with and that's
not to suggest that you know the two uh
officers from uh
Ottawa Police were bad people or
anything like that it's just I didn't
get the sense that
they were
taking us as seriously as I would have
hoped and so I was requesting to not
talk to them anymore I wanted an
inspector and I was led to believe that
I would be talking to an inspector one
one evening and I was waiting patiently
in a room by myself to speak to the
inspector and it this mystery inspector
never arrived even though I was led to
believe I would get one
so I walked away from the meeting when I
found out I wasn't going to be talking
to somebody more senior and the next day
I believe is when the offer came to us
or to me to meet with somebody at the
city
um I and I had no interest in meeting
anybody from the city at that point I
knew where
my focus needed to be was with the
police I wasn't interested in any level
of the uh the city
can I pull up Ops 8527
chicken
if we go to page three so Mr marazzo
you're you're not involved in this email
chain so uh but this is an email train
within the Ottawa Police Service
um and if we can scroll up just a little
bit higher so we can see uh this is an
inner email from John Ferguson to Mark
Patterson and Robert Drummond do you see
that yes do you ever interact with Mr
Ferguson no okay not to my knowledge
okay
um and if we can scroll down
um
so we say here is one of our teams has
already been out Reno Sussex to speak
with the representatives of that group
and it goes on and it says in regards to
the main Convoy our PLT members are
currently walking red zones with one of
the main organizers Tom marazzo who's
responsible for three 22 trucks do you
see that there yes sir okay and then if
we could scroll up a bit further
so this is another this is a now an
email from Mr uh
I forget his rank so I'm going to call
him Mr Patterson and it says PLT members
continued their conversations with Mr
marazzo this evening he has requested a
meeting with an elected official or city
level city manager level member do you
see that yes do you recall
now that you've seen this ever at Rook
being the one who requested the meeting
uh from my recollection I had never had
any interest in meeting with any of the
elected officials in the city I was
perfectly satisfied to to deal directly
with the police I wanted an inspector I
didn't really
field that I certainly had no interest
in meeting with the mayor
Steve K was
you know when I finally met with him I I
realized that maybe that was an error
that it was good to meet with Steve but
I certainly never requested to my
knowledge to speak with any of the
municipal level uh elected officials
you can take that down so we saw in your
in the press conference you were talking
and in your answer about the press
conference you're talking about the
importance of engaging with government
and speaking with government
I appreciate you changed your mind after
you met with Steve K but why wouldn't
you want to meet with a city official
because really at the time I believe
that was
um if if I'm understanding the time
right timeline correctly
um this is the next day after the raid
at Coventry I believe the Coventry raid
was the sixth that was the seventh
um
I wanted to deal directly with the
police because I felt that the police
were the ones that were getting the most
pressure and I thought that I would be
able to uh have a conversation with the
police and try to work with them build a
rapport because I wasn't getting
anywhere that I felt with the two police
liaison sergeants I was dealing with I
felt that if we could develop a better
rapport with the police
then things would change second to that
is the police services board meeting
that we had seen uh the the rhetoric
from Diane Dean was just
um
incredible and I don't know if that that
meeting was before or after the seventh
we just knew that we needed to deal with
the police
and Mr Wilson mentioned in his testimony
on uh more than one occasion that you
had a sense that uh former Chief slowly
was you were concerned about the
pressure he was under is that is that
yeah I I had seen the uh recording of
the police services board meeting that
Diane Dean had been the chair of the
Police Services Board at the time and I
was extremely concerned about the things
that I had witnessed her say on the
video
and so I waited to see the reaction from
uh Chief slowly
and then I got a little bit more
concerned again so I rewound it and I
watched it again I watched her comments
I watched his reaction and I and I knew
uh right there and then that the
situation had fundamentally changed for
all of us them as well as us and I
realized that if we didn't do something
to take the pressure off of the chief
things were going to dramatically change
for the worst and so that's when we
started to completely reshift our Focus
uh to taking the pressure off the chief
thereby taking the pressure off of the
individual police officers and hopefully
ourselves
and again we heard Mr Wilson this
morning he described that after the
meeting with Mr kanalakis there was an
initial effort to move move the trucks
from Rito Sussex to Wellington and as I
understand it that effort was
unsuccessful because the police
ultimately didn't move the barricades
that would be necessary to do that was
did Mr Wilson have that correct
he did but I think uh I heard
um
we actually had
we were you know to use a football
analogy we were on the one yard line
with all the trucks on that corner and
and Eva and I had spent hours on that
corner
um
Eva was talking with the Polish truckers
I was talking with the uh the
English-speaking French uh truckers we
spent hours there and we finally got uh
because Sergeant Lee was there and
um despite his best efforts sometimes he
can be a little bit hostile
and we I I had asked the truckers to
basically as a group come to an
agreement themselves and then also elect
two people to go in in
deal directly with Sergeant Lee because
I was actually concerned that if he went
into the center of those 80 truckers he
would do something that would put his
own safety at risk so instead of him
going to them I said you elect two
people come out and then we'll talk and
then certainly got that phone call he
walked away and he came back and uh the
look on his face said everything I knew
that he had just had the the carpet
pulled out from under his legs and he
said there's no deal
and so I was very concerned I knew I
couldn't go back to the truckers and say
hey we spent all day convincing you to
do this
and now the police have reneged on it
um I knew that there would be no further
chance of ever getting them to to even
be open to the idea of moving had I gone
back and delivered that message to them
so
um
it was
we were there we were there that night
to move them and I just basically went
back and I said listen guys it's a
safety issue we're not going to move at
night because it's too dangerous for the
safety of people with with decreased
visibility
it's all I could come up with the time
to satisfy everybody
and then Mr Wilson talked about another
attempt that was made on February the
10th and then there there was uh that
which was was uh did not proceed and I
take you agree with with Mr uh Wilson
absolutely yes so then we come to the
agreement with the mayor and there was a
meeting on uh February 13th at City Hall
were you at that meeting
um the one with uh inspector Drummond uh
Kim ayotte and Steve K that's our
understanding of who yes I was at that
meeting okay
and I appreciate at that point in time
is is it's the case that you had
indicated that uh you wouldn't be able
to move trucks off Freedom Sussex is
that correct
no I I believe at that meeting we were
just there to go over more of the
details of on how we could properly do
that and then reposition uh or
redistribute the trucks in different
locations
um that's what my recollection of that
the intent of that meeting was in the
discussion and I believe uh kimayot or
inspector Drummond were the ones that
brought the map
um and we were looking at the map from
sort of trying to work out
uh how to redistribute that based on the
map uh that they had marked themselves
so superintendent Drummond testified
that at that meeting it was represented
that there was two locations where uh
the organizers did not believe they'd
get buy-in one was Rito Sussex and one
was with the Coventry group
um
do you recall anyone at the meeting from
the protester side indicating that
I believe that it was uh indicated that
it would be more difficult given the
events the previous two days are prior
two days that would be more work more
challenging but I also believe that
there was a will on on you know our part
to to go up and we thought we could
actually get it done
um I want to talk briefly now about the
the final days uh that you were in
Ottawa
um
after February 17 17th and after the
emergencies Act was invoked was it your
understanding that protesters were
allowed to enter into What's called the
red zone
if they were on foot
and what was the basis of your
understanding that they could enter if
they were on foot just based on some of
the briefings from Keith Wilson in
discussions with Eva and um but not with
vehicles uh clearly and I don't believe
they would have been successful trying
to get in with a vehicle anyway
um and up until at least the 14th you've
been in daily contact with police
Liaisons is that correct yes sir did you
have any contact with them after the
invocation of the emergencies act and
did they give you any indication whether
or not you were allowed whether or not
protesters on foot were allowed in the
red zone
no I I don't think that my conversations
with my regular police Liaisons were
like that I did receive one phone call
from an unknown
OPP officer who who
said that he was the guy that they call
for really difficult negotiations I
don't know who that person was I just
know he was OPP and they he had a lot of
extensive experience with negotiating
and I knew from that phone call that
um
uh the the mass arrests were imminent I
didn't get a date or a time I just got I
understood the vocabulary in the context
of his comments he didn't come out and
tell me exactly when they would they
would come in and start making Mass
arrests but I knew that it was imminent
do you know when that phone call was it
was right I believe it was right after
the emergency Act was invoked it might
have been the the 15th I I can't be
certain of that detail or and I have no
idea who that officer was were you aware
of the tick tock video that's been
discussed a couple of times in which Mr
Wilson uh explains that uh protesters
are allowed to continue to protest
peacefully I hadn't seen that until I
was here in the audience seeing that
what was your reaction to seeing it now
um
no real reaction
um uh was there any point when it became
clear to you that the police were were
not going to allow protesters on foot to
be in the red zone
not until the first day when they
started uh attacking people up in front
of the Senate and when what day was that
the 18th
and
during that time when the police began
clearing the protesters did anyone from
the police ever indicate to you that
there was an area where protesters could
go to protest no sir
did you make any did you ask whether
there's anywhere that I did not
is it something that crossed your mind
no not at that time that's not really
where my uh
my my headspace was I was uh I was quite
concerned about the things that I had
personally witnessed
um that day I was there when uh the two
people were trampled by the horse
um
I had seen some things that I never
thought that I would see in this country
and I I've run past my time so I will
ask you one last question which is is
there anything else uh that you think is
important that that I that we should ask
you about
no sir
thank you
okay and
first up is the government of Canada
please
good afternoon Mr brazzo oh
um I'll just have a few questions for
you but I'll start with where my friend
um started you with and for the record
I'm Brendan van Dean Heist one of the
lawyers for the government of Canada
um you described this call with an opp
officer that you you aren't sure of
exactly which officer it was in which it
was indicated to you that the police
were going to enforce right yes
and you saw earlier today uh the video
on Tick Tock of Mr Wilson advising
people that could remain there on foot
yes yes
and you yourself acknowledged that this
was not in fact the case right
I'm sorry I'm not understanding that
people were not permitted to remain in
the Red Zone on foot
um
I I thought that actually at the time I
thought that that was somewhat
questionable
um that you would be within your right
to be from my conversations uh you in
the briefing from from Keith
um that you would be within your right
to be in the Red Zone I just didn't
think you'd get a vehicle in there
um but that you you could remain there
as long as you weren't you know bringing
in a vehicle or anything like that
the call you described you thought it
was on the 15th shortly after the
emergency Act was invoked on the 14th I
I it's in and around there I don't know
the specific date or or the time that I
received that phone call I just know
that that phone call
uh was somewhat impactful enough for me
to remember
and it was a short call
could we go to hrf four zeros1510
I'm showing you a copy of this email
which appears to be an email from Avid
chippy up to among others yourself and
Mr Wilson do you see that yes
and she is attaching a document that I
don't think we have but it's a document
entitled the right to protest right yes
and she indicates and I guess this is
relaying some advice received
from Saya Hassan Barrister and solicitor
do you see that yes
and she's indicating her passing along a
note to you and Mr Wilson that says I've
drafted something on the right to
protest but have taken the cautious
approach because I don't know what the
emergency orders are but it's my
understanding that they can limit the
right to protest and well that that can
be challenged in court at the moment
people who do not comply may be arrested
right right and she goes on to say I
think that what if we're advising people
it's important to let them know all of
the risks that they're facing and let
them make their own decisions right yes
and that's
Sound Advice that you would agree with I
would
but I would also say that
you know combine that with the fact that
Justice McLean had ruled that we were
legally within our right to be there in
Ottawa during to to have this protest
um and then you know you're seeing an
email from a lawyer who is saying that
it is you know my understanding so if it
is not completely set in concrete for a
lawyer what chance do we have for having
a definitive
um bit of legal advice that we can make
a 100 percent absolute decision on what
is going to happen to us if we remain so
you had an interpretation of Justice
McLean's order right
um I had just from what I was briefed on
the result and that that I do remember
reading uh the decision and I'm not
again I'm not a lawyer so when I'm
reading it it's a from a very
unsophisticated perspective but I do
remember reading the the part where it
said to the effect that we had a legal
right to be there
all right well um you're not a lawyer
but Ms chippy is a lawyer and uh Saya
Hassan you understand as a lawyer as
well
I see there on the email that they are
this person is a lawyer a lawyer okay
did you take any steps to relate the
risks that people are facing so that
they could make their own decision with
respect to the uh possibility that they
would be arrested if they did not comply
I believe we handed out a
French English double-sided piece of
paper that we printed to everybody uh I
think we printed out hundreds of copies
and it was from the pro bono legal team
that we had that if people were arrested
that was a description of what their
rights would be and also the phone
number to call if that should happen to
them okay
no sir you're publishing I I understand
you're publishing a book which you
intend to release on February the 14th
of next year yes
and you've selected that date because
it's the same date I went to the report
of this commission must be tabled no
it's the one year anniversary of the
emergency act being invoked oh I see
you've been attempting to raise money
for the publication of this book through
a fundraiser on the website give send to
go correct yes because I have a team
that is helping me and they also need to
well they need
support sure
um could we go to com50415
sir this is an affidavit that you swore
in support of an application by Canadian
Frontline nurses right yes yes and if
you just go down to the very bottom of
the affidavit to find the girat date
there we go you swore this it appears on
March the 4th of this year yes
if we could go back up to paragraph four
now here you say that you arrived in
Ottawa on January the 30th with the
intention of peacefully participating in
the protest correct yes and you told us
um shortly ago that your arrival was due
to the invitation extended to you to
come to Ottawa by James bouter yes
and you understood he was asking for
your assistance in providing some form
of organization to support his
objectives
as part of the group identifying itself
as the Convoy
I wouldn't say as his because to me it
was the Convoy I he was somebody
participating in the Convoy but yes okay
well so whoever the Convoy is that's
where you're being asked to help yes by
Mr bowder yes
and you became familiar you told us with
the memorandum of understanding that he
was circulating and intended to deliver
to the governor general and the speaker
of the Senate right yes I don't know who
he delivered it to I just recall the
governor general was a name that was
thrown out there
let's go to
com50886 which is a copy of the
memorandum just for clarity
Council uh
com50886 appears to be some sort of
social media post excuse me it's 866 I
misspoke
foreign
so you were clear in saying that this
was at the very least not a well-written
document
from what I remember reading it I was I
didn't believe it was a very well
written document I I Knew by looking at
it wasn't written by a lawyer
uh and um
if you look at the
uh
second page of the document
um looking at the top here of the of the
page there's a list of the the parties
in effect to this memorandum of
understanding
um do you see what I mean there the bold
faced uh lettering there at the top yes
so one group is the concerned Canadian
citizens indigenous community and
permanent residents
represented by the bouters and Mr
broadman okay yes yeah and then the next
party is the Senate as represented by
the speaker
yes and then it's the governor general
yes and if we go to page two in article
three
you stop there
um you see the notion here is that there
would be a committee formed between the
concerned citizens and the Senate and
the governor general right yes and that
that committee then would under
paragraph each sub-paragraph e there
instruct all levels of the federal
provincial Territorial and Municipal
governments to cease and desist
etc etc
um Provisions related to covid-19 right
yes
and um
if you go over to page three
and
look at item J there you see that in
exchange for this
the concerned citizens will immediately
stop operation bear hug
Ottawa demonstration Convoy you see that
yes and so in effect and that was Mr
botter's name for the occupation and or
blockades or what have you in Ottawa was
Operation bear hug I have no idea what
he called it and I don't know what
operation bear hug Ottawa is okay at any
rate you recognize that this document
presented a
something of a nonsensical idea
I would agree with that and you insisted
that it be withdrawn and retracted
publicly and that and this was then done
right
that's my understanding
and you understood that any legislative
action would require the participation
of the elected representatives at the
federal provincial and Municipal levels
right yes
in fact if you go to article 7 of the
mou
excuse me article six you'll see that it
is in fact supposed to be construed in
accordance with the laws of Canada right
yes
no
um can I just um
looking at this this is a 15-page
document this is not from my
recollection
what I read
okay this is not what I read during my
time in Ottawa I believed it to be more
of a two-part two-page
um document I don't recall ever looking
at this particular document broken down
like this
well I'm sure maybe it was immediate
release of some kind they put out but I
I don't remember ever reading this okay
well we'll ask Mr bowder about it
tomorrow to see if there's a distinction
uh you um indicated in your press
conference on February 9th as we just
saw that you were offering yourself as
willing to sit down with the
conservative party the block quebecue
the NDP and the governor general as a
some sort of a representative right
yeah so when my I from my perspective I
was thinking not even more as a as a as
a mediator it was really just a an SOS
to be honest with you it was just a
literal call for help but desperation
stop ignoring us come and sit at a table
we've got a table you guys you know
we'll get you a conference room but just
do something instead of taking cheap
photo ops and opportunities with with
people and making this into a political
uh joke for you guys
um get off your butts and come here and
do something meaningful for the you know
six million Canadians that are affected
by this crap in this country right now
you had no interest in meeting with
Municipal elected officials right no no
because our our issues were not what the
municipal government our issues with the
federal government we're here to end
Federal mandates
on February the 13th you had a meeting
um with uh with Ottawa Police with
respect to negotiations right
in what regard you you had a meeting in
the evening with a superintendent
Drummond and yes from the Ottawa please
uh he just he was the only police
officer in the room right and you
um had commented that you'd wanted to
have an inspector uh uh uh to deal with
on behalf of Ottawa please right yes you
understand that superintendent is a rank
above inspector
yes
can we go back to your uh affidavit
com50415 and it'll be page four
now we can go to paragraph 17 I believe
it is
you indicate here
that the freezing of bank accounts in
the wake of the invocation of the
emergencies act has left me real concern
that authorities are surveilling me and
may arbitrarily charge and arrest me
although I've committed no crime right
yes I'm constantly looking over my
shoulder I am hesitant to leave my house
I have left my home only twice since I
returned from Ottawa yes right
I'm concerned about traveling with my
children as I'm concerned they'll be
taken away from me by Children's Aid in
the event the police decide to charge
and arrest me yes because I was informed
after leaving Ottawa that there was a
task force of RCMP OPP Ottawa Police as
well as the statements publicly made by
acting Chief Bell that said that you
would be identified investigated and
there would be criminal charges and
other punishments coming your way so
that statement is true because from my
perspective I was one of the ones that
was not charged during the time in
Ottawa but I was led to believe that
that I was under investigation and I
have since learned
different versions of that but it was my
understanding that I was being
investigated as a the 42 of us on the uh
one of the lists were were identified to
me
you've obviously overcome this fear to
be able to be with us today
well I asked Keith Wilson a few months
ago when would I find out that I'm no
longer uh
being investigated and when will I find
out that I'm not going to be charged
um you would overcome this fear by May
the 4th of 2022 when the election period
began in the Ontario provincial election
Fair yes sir
and that election was held on June the
2nd of 2020. and you ran in the writing
I understand of Peterborough Kawartha
for the Ontario party yes
and you there received
1973 votes amounting to approximately
3.8 percent of the vote in the writing
right yes
could we go to pb.can.401774
foreign
excerpt of the video it'll be just at
the very beginning
Council 1174 were the last four numbers
that you just one seven seven four yeah
I've done it again excuse me
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Ontario Party candidate for Peterborough
and core the a member of the Veterans
for Freedom steering committee Captain
retired Tom marazzo
thank you
this is a lot harder than it looks
before I start there are some people I'd
like to acknowledge in the room
and I'd like Jeremy McKenzie to stand up
for a moment
sir how do you know Mr McKenzie
he does
um uh he has a podcast and uh he does a
lot of
political satire and comedy
um he does some serious uh videos
sometimes
um
he is the uh the creator of a fictitious
meme on the internet known as Diagon
which I assume what you're going to ask
me about and uh the vice president of
diag Along being a time traveling
cocaine addicted goat
um
that is just a internet meme that has no
meaning at all and uh I had spoken to
Jeremy the first time when I was in
Ottawa on the phone
and um
the second time I spoke to Jeremy was
when the liberal government
was debating whether or not they should
use the emergency act and they were
citing this fictitious goat that time
travels as a domestic terrorist group in
justification for invoking the Emergency
act and I saw a video that Jeremy and
his friends were doing and they were
laughing hysterically showing clips of
the government actually talking about
Diagon as being a real thing everybody
knew it was a joke when I saw the video
I contacted Jeremy and I said tell me
everything there is to know about Diagon
he said if you draw a diagonal line from
Alaska
through Alberta to Texas it makes a
diagonal line and that's why it's called
Diagon they're the only States and
provinces that don't have mask mandates
and he used it as a joke he made the
symbol for diagonal on in a second on
his cell phone because it's a joke and
it it is meaningless he did it to
attract attention for people to come to
a barbecue and to have a lot of fun that
were you know people wanted to have a
barbecue without masks on a bunch of
strangers that didn't know each other
and yet here he was watching a you know
members of parliament and Liberal Party
actually joking or actually seriously
stating that the reason for invoking the
Emergency Act was because of
Diagon like it was the most outrageous
ridiculous thing I had ever seen and I
think this commission should be
investigating that as the biggest
intelligence joke of you know the last
decade
um so I that it's a joke Diagon is a
joke it's not even a real thing
thank you those are my questions thank
you
okay next is the
Ottawa residence coalition
foreign
good afternoon my name is Paul champ I'm
lawyer for the Ottawa Coalition of
residents and businesses just a couple
questions uh Mr morazo following your
testimony yes sir I note um we didn't
get an interview summary for you from
the commission council is that because
you refused to sit down with commission
counsel for an interview
no I
believe my lawyers felt that I would not
have my Charter rights protected if I
voluntarily gave a statement
okay
then uh turning to your activities in
Ottawa in February earlier this year
which hotel did you stay in again the
ark and uh who paid for your hotel Mr
Borgo I gather
it's possible that he paid for it but I
cannot confirm who paid for my hotel
room I just know I didn't so you stayed
in a hotel room for about three weeks
and you don't know who paid for it
I do not know for a fact who paid for it
I I spoke to uh Joseph's uh stepson Ryan
but
I don't know if he was paying for the
rooms or it just had control of a block
on behalf of somebody else I don't
really know because
they belong to some sort of an
organization and I don't know if it's
the organization or Joe or somebody
specifically who did it I just know that
I went to Ryan when I needed a room
and we know through a variety of means a
significant amount of money was raised
with respect to the Convoy demonstration
did you have some of your expenses
covered
aside from them
um there was occasions where I was
buying my own food
and um
whatever food was donated in the
um in in the conference room that we had
like I said I was sick so I ended up
losing 14 pounds and I've gained more
than that back and
um I wasn't eating very much the few
times I ate I actually just bought
myself if I wanted a more of a meal so
you didn't get any cash to cover any
attracts no expenses or anything like
that okay now uh you've told us that you
were doing logistics for the Convoy but
it's it's not it's a little bit unclear
to me exactly what you're doing you were
you were managing uh truck locations yes
uh anything else
well when I initially got there I was
focused in on the logistics and then
after the rate at Coventry I had
notified a former military officer that
I personally knew and I and I asked him
if he would come to Ottawa and help me
and he did and so I was able to actually
hand off some of those day-to-day things
that I was working on and then move
towards so my my role actually did
transition less day-to-day Logistics
more strategically working with Keith
and Eva to to get this get something
going here right I heard you talking
about the transition but it was unclear
to me what you transitioned from what
what Logistics were you doing well I
really was directing the people
um on the ground you know figuring like
basically steering people in the
direction of things that they needed to
focus on uh truck locations there was
occasions where we wanted to people
wanted to move trucks around right uh
but that became a little bit difficult
as well and then
you know oftentimes I would deal
directly with the police so that became
something that was uh impacting my day
greatly
um I would have conversations with the
the liaison sergeants and then go back
and talk to the trucker so I mean
physically was I out there filling
trucks up no I wasn't but I was
um trying to facilitate you know
organizing that better developing uh
trucker Captain organizations and stuff
like that only to find that really the
truckers were organically doing that
themselves
and you told us uh that you were trying
to manage where the trucks were figure
out where they all were map them out how
many trucks try to get an accurate count
so forth
um but it was put to you by commission
Council about Ken street now we've heard
police evidence evidence from a resident
and actually Chris Barber himself
testifying that Kent Street was almost
completely blocked uh throughout the
entire combo every once in a while the
emergency thing would get open but it
almost instantly be closed up again and
that predominantly there was no
emergency Lane on that street uh so I'm
surprised Mr Mazda you don't remember
that one street well that's I saw that
at some point
I had the two people that I were working
with that actually started to monitor
that
um my my friend that I just mentioned
that was retired military as well as one
other individual and every time that the
the other issue was this that we
recognized was that the police liaison
teams were going and talking to
everybody so they would talk to me leave
and go have the same exact conversation
with somebody else so and there was
multiple teams and the information that
was getting very confusing so for
example they would talk to me and if you
were there they would go over and talk
to you say the same thing and then
everybody's chasing their tail going in
circles so at some point we just kind of
um people took on responsibilities for
certain functions and they just would
maintain that and so the two individuals
I'm speaking out when it came to safety
the police would go to them for safety
Lanes they would immediately go out and
do the best they could to clear it but
then again sometimes they got blocked
that's helpful I just I must have
misunderstood your evidence I thought
that's what you were doing
um uh you'd agree with Mr marazzo city
buses there's no way they could get
through anywhere downtown correct
I thought that's an easy one
there were I would say uh because I
believe I was on Metcalf is what the Arc
was on there was I I believe they could
have got through there uh I don't see
any reason why not there was days I went
out there and the street was wide open a
bus could have gone up and down Metcalf
all day long back and forth I guess yes
well I don't I don't want to say all day
long but I mean there were several times
um
where you know it was wide open I moved
my vehicle on right in front of the uh
the arc Hotel on that street no problems
but presumably if people want to go
anywhere other than up and down Metcalf
they wouldn't be able to access the city
as you got closer to Wellington it
became increasingly more difficult
similarly uh and particularly
individuals require para transport buses
they weren't getting anywhere through
downtown
crap do you mean the the shorter uh
buses that are meant for wheelchairs
that's correct uh I don't I don't think
that that's entirely accurate I I think
again I would I would say that for for
that type of Transportation as you got a
little closer to Wellington it would
probably be more of a challenge but it
would be up to the individual bus driver
himself or herself to see if they could
negotiate through that uh those
intersections you didn't observe any
though no I did not and
um just moving to a different topic
police leaks uh you were getting
information about what would the police
were planning ahead of time through
sympathetic police officers is that
right that's my understanding but they
weren't coming to me directly they were
coming from uh other other sources and
then I would have conversations with
people that that information was passed
to them so you're kind of like the
Clearinghouse for the intelligence I
guess for the Convoy uh no we I tried to
decentralize that as well
um in the sense that that you could you
know I'm I wasn't a police officer I had
worked a lot with police officers in my
in my military career but I wasn't a
police officer so
um we had police officers that were
retired that you know everybody knows
Danny bulford was one
um if I had questions
you know maybe him or Vince gercy's
maybe
um but at that point at some point I
stopped actually caring about
um
certain things and I just left it into
other people's more expertise or more
capable hands
uh moving on to another topic you
testified about the Slow Roll uh Pat
King's slow roll around uh the airport
and uh that you cooperated to some
extent assisting with that correct
just so much as
um I wanted to make sure that there
would never be uh uh a complete blockage
or a stoppage of
um operations for the airport
and but you also told us there was some
value to it as well that it was sending
a message to the city that the vehicles
could move around and could move to
other areas of the city if necessary yes
and
that discussion centered around
um what happened at Coventry when the
police went in on the Sunday night and
raided and stole the fuel and stole the
food
and um my conversations with the Ottawa
Police the next day was you know if you
if you want to provoke a reaction from
this organic movement from Individual
truckers that's the best way to go about
it and if you want to keep it as civil
as it has been don't get it don't put us
in a situation where there has to be a
Tit for Tat kind of a situation and I
said by the way we will never exceed the
level of
stupidity that you guys are are doing to
us we might match it we'll never exceed
it and by the way your Coventry was your
your freebie we're not you know we're
not going to do anything because of what
you did at Coventry because we don't see
the value in it we don't want to
escalate this into something terrible
and so we just try to always keep the
temperature down keep the tone down with
them but you know they were incredibly
provoking constantly
so the the Slow Roll was a warning to
the city that if the police did some
kind of enforcement action the truckers
might retaliate in some way I don't you
know I'm not comfortable with the word
retaliate but
you know you could split hairs on that
that that word but it wasn't meant as a
retaliation it was a meant really to
send the signal that
you know we've got the ability to move
around and and do we want to do we want
to escalate to to that level no what
we're trying to say to you is that if if
we really really want to escalate to the
level you guys are ramping up
then then we can play that game with you
but we don't want to play that game so
they'll do the Slow Roll just to let you
know that it is possible and just to be
clear what we're talking about here the
game meaning the police enforcing The
Loft the police attempt to enforce the
law the truckers given their size and
their numbers will escalate towards the
city of Ottawa on the residence correct
that's what you mean I I don't really I
I didn't see it lawful to go in and
steal people's fuel or their food
I didn't actually see it as a lawful act
on the half on behalf of the police
I saw it as theft with respect to
um Mr King
um
Mr King you understood people didn't
want to deal with him because some of
his comments online about bullets and so
forth were distasteful is that right
yeah that was the sense I got but I knew
somebody had also told me those comments
for like for two years prior to the
Convoy and it was just a complete hit
piece by
somebody whoever put that that video out
there that it was just meant to
discredit him and make us look bad and
it was a video it was discrediting
himself by saying the prime minister is
going to catch a bullet
from the testimony I saw here in the
room the other day the context of that
had something to do with something
completely unrelated to this Convoy
what about his online comments about
race and the Anglo-Saxon race or those
kinds of comments discrediting the
movement I know nothing of those
comments or Mr Barber his online racist
comments was that discrediting the
movement I believe he owned up to that
himself yesterday right
and then finally uh diagonalon he said
that this was a joke and it was about uh
creating a diagonal state of people who
who don't wear masks isn't it in fact
the case it was the the concept or the
image is a diagonal state where there
would only be white people who would
live in it and they could get all
non-white people out correct all right
so
please the if just wait a moment please
let's try and keep it quiet please while
we hear the evidence this is the
equivalent of a court
in the sense that we have sworn evidence
and we'd like to keep a proper
atmosphere
go ahead I'm sorry if you were to meet
some of Jeremy McKenzie's friends and
the ones that were on the video that I
was describing earlier where they were
laughing about the Liberal Party using
Diagon as a justification you'll see
clearly that one of Jeremy's best
friends is a black man
there's
I don't I can't even comprehend as well
sorry does he have a Jewish accountant
as well
online rants you've seen them do you
find do you think that I've seen some of
his Rants and some of them you know some
of the things he says I don't agree with
and some of the things I think he's
absolutely spot on but that's up to me
to make a decision on whether or not I
find that the content is appropriate or
not and I have seen Jeremy say things I
don't like and I've seen Jeremy say
things that I thought were brilliant
thank you
okay and next I call on the Ontario
Provincial Police
guys for the delay I have no questions
okay
um
next uh is uh
Council for uh former Chief slowly
I'm sorry for interrupting Mr
commissioner but I I you may have missed
Ottawa Police on the list
yes I did well we'll get we'll get back
to you after okay for the former Chief
slowly
commissioner
I believe my friends from the Ottawa
Police Service have more time than have
I
probably makes sense for them to go
ahead if they're prepared to if it's
your pleasure
that's fine I'll uh I will concede to uh
council's agreement okay
Ottawa Police Service
good afternoon my name is Jessica Barrow
and as you've now heard I am Council for
the Ottawa Police Service yes I just
have a couple of questions and I wonder
if we can start with the document Ops
14504
have you seen this document before
I'm not entirely sure
if you read through it and obviously we
can give you a minute uh it's a document
that was Cirque we've heard was
circulated to the protesters and it's
dated February 17th it was circulated by
the Ottawa Police Service okay
I'm
my recollection I know there was a
letter that was posted all over the city
um I honestly never bothered to read it
um I know there was something that was
posted places
um and I know there was two different
colored ones but that's the extent of my
knowledge of of the documents so you
testified earlier that
perhaps there was a lack of clarity
around whether you could be in the Red
Zone on foot at this point but it was
that your it was your understanding that
you could not be there with a vehicle is
that correct do I have that correct
well what I meant as in you weren't
going to be able to bring in a large
truck
um I wasn't really thinking about it in
terms of individual vehicles
um I know my vehicle was there and I got
five parking tickets in 24 hours uh and
my car hadn't even moved so I knew there
was an issue with vehicles but
um I my mind at the time was focused on
people
that wanted to come to the city
came in on foot
okay well let's take a look at this
document then if we could scroll to the
top a little bit
it says we want to inform you that you
will face severe penalties under
provincial and federal legislation if
you not do not cease further unlawful
activity and remove your vehicle and
your property immediately from all
unlawful protest sites and then if we
scroll down a little it says you may be
arrested
your vehicle could be seized a few other
issues
um
those delivering gifts that you can see
at the bottom those delivering Fuel and
other supplies can be charged persons
traveling to the unlawful protest sites
to participate or support the unlawful
demonstration can be charged so does
that perhaps clarify the question of
whether you could be there at this point
in time on February 17th
well that's based on you know a document
that was posted around the city that was
not actually served to me personally so
I didn't look at it I I can't really
explain why I couldn't I didn't look at
it but
um you're posting that but I'm getting I
was
getting different interpretation from
the lawyers that were accompanying us
right so you're getting an
interpretation from your lawyer
information from you are circulating
information that you're choosing not to
read that is telling you that if you
continue to stay here you may get
arrested is that fair but I vaguely even
recall ever seeing it like I I might
have seen something posted in an
elevator once that's all I even remember
noticing that there was something there
and I
but
honestly
until the violence came
to the protesters from the police
um I didn't see this as something that
uh
we I I didn't see it as something that
needed to be abided by because it was a
peaceful protest and I knew that Justice
McLean had already ruled that we had a
right to be there whether or not the
emergency Act was invoked
you know we're getting conflicting
information from the police we're
getting it we have information that I
trust a lot more from our legal team uh
because we were dealing with pro bono
lawyers there was five of them that did
criminal law and we had the two lawyers
that were on the ground with us the
entire time
so we were there to do a protest and we
took the judges where I personally took
the judge's word as well as Keith and
Eva's word uh that what we were doing
was lawful and so that's how I conducted
myself according to that so I respect
the fact that that you have been
operating on legal advice but I guess my
question to you is
it wasn't a question of there being a
lack of clarity from the Ottawa Police
Service and in fact it was just that you
disagreed with the direction of the
Ottawa Police Service
at the time I wasn't really considering
that as Direction because no at no time
that the police actually come up to me
and and say that in no uncertain term it
was something that was stuck to the wall
on a piece of paper so when it stuck to
the wall not handed to me I it didn't
really seem overly credible like and I
don't want to say credible but if it was
so important to them I would have
thought that any one of those police
liaison officers would have walked up
and handed it to me and explained it to
me with either a puppet show or a box of
crayons so that I could understand it
but that was never the case it was just
posted on a wall were you aware that
there was also social media posts in
relation to These Warnings no were you
monitoring Ottawa Police Department I
was not I was not okay
um you indicated you referred to police
violence yes uh starting on the I
presume on the 18th of February Chris
yeah and you indicated that you were
watching that from your hotel room no I
was there uh I was only 15 feet away
from the horses when they trampled the
two people so then you would have heard
prior to the arrest taking place
multiple verbal warnings from police
officers indicating that if people
didn't depart they risked being arrested
is that no I did not hear them verbally
the front line of police officers were
extremely quiet the front row of
protesters were trying to engage the
police in dialogue and to convince them
to stop doing what they were doing and
there was no reaction from the police on
the front line there was no shouts there
was no I didn't hear even so much as a
bullhorn telling the the crowd to
disperse during the time that I was
there on the line from what I had
personally observed and so if there's
evidence to suggest that that there were
sort of loudspeakers or whatever we're
calling them indicating that people
needed to leave or they could be
arrested you you just didn't hear that I
did not hear that personally if that's
part if that's what was done I did not
personally hear that and notwithstanding
that the police were obviously present
and and ready to arrest those that
weren't leaving they weren't leaving
correct they were not leaving okay thank
you those are my questions
okay
now uh former Chief slowlease counts
please
thank you commissioner
Mr marazzo Tom Curry for former Chief
slowly
um
just on the point that my friend Ms
Barrel was asking you about can you just
help us I thought I saw in the statement
we don't have to go back to it and just
tell me if I've got this right that you
encouraged
the protesters towards the end as this
enforcement action uh rolled out you
encouraged protesters to leave the
protest site rather than be arrested
um
I don't believe that to be the case I
don't I never encouraged anyone to leave
until the 19th
on the 19 maybe I had that date wrong
then so on the beginning on the 19th yes
did you then change your approach and
encourage protesters to leave rather
than be arrested
for this after after what I saw
personally in the city the the level of
violence that the police had brought to
the protesters what I saw
I was so disgusted uh that day uh Danny
bulford had also been arrested later in
the afternoon
and um then the following morning on the
19th I had a meeting with the remaining
people that I knew to be leaders or
truck captains in in my hotel room with
with other people
and we my advice to everybody was to
depart uh the city of Ottawa into
peacefully withdraw but that it would be
it would have to be up to the individual
owner operators of their own Vehicles
they have to decide for themselves but
our recommendation was that they left
the city of Ottawa as peacefully as they
could and I at 1003 in the morning I
remember the phone call with the opp I
notified them and I said we will
peacefully withdraw you need to move
your concrete barriers and allow us to
get fuel into the trucks and we will
start making arrangements to leave as
soon as possible but that each truck
driver had to make their own individual
decision and you know I there is a video
of it I'm sure somebody may bring it up
um
and I you know it was a very frustrating
phone call that I had with uh the opp uh
but I said we are recommended it's not
my proudest moment if you do show the
video I my language is terrible
um but I was angry and I was frustrated
but I advised him to allow the truckers
to leave move the concrete barriers
because we couldn't get out and allow us
to get fuel because you know fuel was a
bit of an issue trying to get out right
and for the commissioner's purposes then
did did do you know how many of the
protesters took the advice that you gave
and and left voluntarily
there was a group of uh protesters that
were set up with tents there was a it
was an outdoor kitchen basically with a
big pig roast and and stuff and and that
that individual uh who was I think owned
that tent or was in control of that tent
had started to pack up and recommend to
his people that it was time to leave
um and I just know that various groups
took the advice and some didn't
um but by the the morning of the 19th
um
uh from from our perspective the
violence just actually got worse and
when they moved down to the war memorial
that's when things got really quite
disturbing uh about you know and and
even on the the 18th things were
incredibly disturbing you know I you'll
hear testimony here I'm sure from Chris
Deering the horrific things that he had
and he's a combat veteran of Afghanistan
so after hearing that
um in in
seeing the footage of all of that stuff
uh after that there was no way there was
any point in staying any longer
I mean I I understand violence
um
there was no way those truckers were
were ever going to be able to repel the
police in any way
the the truckers who the those who
remained and those who remained and
those who didn't were not allowed to get
out because I think at that point on the
18th and 19th the police decided they're
going in and
you know we we had seen the text
messages of of uh RCMP officers laughing
and joking about bringing like don't
don't do it all in one day let us get
our turn on the next day uh the police
were getting geared up that was leaked
um to the alternative or social media
um where they were joking and laughing
about using Jack Boots on people right
so just a couple of things and
um you told the commissioner that you
were watching the the interaction
between the Police Services Board chair
yes and chief slowly yes and did you
form the conclusion that that she
slowly's support at from the Police
Services Board was had been badly
affected diminished
I you know it was my understanding that
it is uh is against the law for Police
Services Board to direct police
operations and from my perspective what
I was watching was her uh her covert or
very
I don't know what the the word is but
Diane Dean's deep desire to start
directing Police Operations to Chief
slowly and when I listened to his
response I had to listen to it twice to
understand
um
what really was going on in that meeting
uh it was it was very clear to me that
he was getting pressure from every
different direction and
um especially because Diane Dean
effectively was his boss and she was
putting an enormous amount of pressure
on him and combining that with all the
other rhetoric from the mayor and the
other politicians locally uh it was my
opinion that if we didn't do something
to help him to take the pressure off of
him
specifically there would be a very
negative reaction
from the entire Police Service of of
Ottawa and you were attempting also as I
understand to take pressure off the from
the residents yeah and that was the
strategy was to take the pressure off
the residents and thereby get less
complaints to the police uh and then if
the the politicians were getting less
pressure they would put less pressure on
the chief you were right you were there
from the 30th on do I have it right that
you understood particularly having
regard to your background in in our
Armed Forces
that the Ottawa Police Service as a as a
Police Service of local jurisdiction did
not have sufficient resources to manage
and disperse the protesters
30th February 1st whatever day you
choose is that was that a fair
conclusion that you drew
at that point it was it was far too
early to tell because I knew that there
was
um parliamentary police were low were
here I knew that there was um got no
police were close by I knew OPP was in
the area
and I knew there was probably RCMP in
the area but it was it was our or my
belief because I knew that the the the
liaison teams were interacting with us
at least
that we had a an exceptionally good
chance
to work with the police this is why we
made a concerted effort to constantly
work with the police because we knew
that you know we had a measure of power
in terms of the the Convoy itself but
they they actually have the force the
physical Force to to change the
situation and so we thought if we could
just keep the temperature down
constantly and effectively with the
police there wouldn't be a need to bring
in other police departments right one
one last thing then please could I ask
to show the witness
hrf1379 this is a short little statement
that I think you gave Mr Lawton who
wrote a book published a book about
these events just want to make sure that
I
have you confirm it
this goes I think to your ability to
to manage some of the protesters other
Witnesses have told us about their the
nature of the independent thinking
independent operator you experienced
that too yes
uh page five please
uh just a little higher perhaps it
starts on four
and a little higher please
uh just I'm sorry a little lower there
it is during the meeting
do you see that during the meeting
marazzo and Wilson said they would try
to move trucks from residential areas
downtown and clear the Rideau and Sussex
intersection
police agreed to move their concrete
barriers temporarily so that trucks
could get onto Wellington Street the
caveat however which Wilson and marazzo
knew all too well
was that no one could force the truckers
to do anything they didn't want to do
that remained true throughout yes okay
thank you I don't have any other
questions for you thank you commissioner
okay thank you next uh is the city of
Ottawa
all of the areas upon which we had
intended to question have been canvas uh
thank you commissioner okay
ccla please
yes uh thank you commissioner
uh Mr marazzo my name is Eva krejevska
and I'm Council for the Canadian civil
liberties Association
I want to ask you a few questions with
respect to the emergencies orders after
the emergencies the federal emergencies
Act was invoked were any of your
personal or corporate bank accounts
Frozen
yes all of my bank accounts my joint
bank accounts was my former spouse uh
were all
um affected my uh credit card that was
on file with my son's uh Pharmacy were
suspended my former spouse her credit
rating was dropped 109 points
um
yes so everything was frozen I had
access to no money other than cash
and so
so the personal uh accounts and not just
ones that you hold individually but also
ones that you hold jointly with your
child and your former spouse yes they
were uh they were joint
um joint joint accounts were frozen as
well as my
um my ex-wife's my first wife's
um
financial institution reached out and
cautioned her that potentially her
accounts were going to also be Frozen
and I haven't been with her in over a
decade
and Mr rather for how long were your
bank accounts Frozen during the entire
time of the emergency Act
so until the emergencies Act was revoked
yes
in my um sorry go ahead sorry go ahead
no go ahead I was just going to say that
uh luckily we had cash in the house
because my son's heart medication uh we
couldn't purchase it my account had been
frozen and if we didn't have cash uh he
wouldn't have been able to get his his
heart medication
he had a month and a half previous had
myocarditis and was on
um some pretty
uh intense heart medication
and were you given any information uh
either from the bank or from the police
as to how you how your bank accounts
could be reopened I was never notified
that my bank accounts had been frozen
and I was never notified that they would
be and I was never notified
um that they were reinstated
at no time so so did you just find out
that they are frozen because you could
no longer use your could no longer yeah
cards could no longer access any uh of
our financial assets at all
and where you and how did you find out
that your bank accounts and assets were
unfrozen was it just because you were
able to use them again we just continued
it once we discovered it we would uh
check every couple hours to see if we
had access to our our own money
were you able to access your online
banking
just to get in you could log in but
there was a message on it that said
um access to your financial whatever was
denied
okay thank you very much Mr marazzo
thank you thank you thank you
commissioner
thank you next is a democracy fund jccf
commissioner Mr marazzo I'll be very
brief today
um you indicated at the beginning of
your test my name is Antoine Dai Council
to Citizens for freedom
uh you indicated near the beginning of
your testimony today that you saw things
you never thought you would see in
Canada and that those things may have
formed part of your motivation for your
participation in the Convoy yes is that
a reference to abuses of power and and
what are some of those things that you
saw that you never thought you would see
well the the biggest thing for me which
was incredible was that uh informed
consent was being absolutely ignored
um this is like prior are you talking
about prior to the Convoy or
the things the things you saw that you
never thought you would see which which
motivated you to participate you know if
you were to look at what the city of
Toronto was doing because I was living
at the time close I was just
um in the berry area so I was looking at
what the the Toronto police were doing
um what the premier was doing with all
the lockdowns
um the the lockdowns made absolutely no
sense
um the vilification of Canadians by the
prime minister of Canada
was
shocking
um so deeply disturbing to to hear him
talk about Canadians the way he did
that's just one of the examples Premier
Doug Ford in in the rhetoric that he had
and and the other big thing for me which
was really really shocking to me
was that
they did not exercise or use Emergency
Management Ontario to uh to manage this
entire pandemic for this province it was
mind-boggling to me and I knew about
them because I actually worked with the
emo representative who was a retired
Brigadier General when I was posted to
the headquarters in Toronto and so my
expectation was to handle this pandemic
you would have used the very institution
within each province that is meant to
handle a pandemic so I knew things were
fundamentally upside down with the
approach that the government was using
and uh you would see uh subsequent
effects of those decisions which were
you know
shut down a department store stop
selling uh kids clothing and stuff like
that but you can go and get a case of
beer that's no problem right so there
was there was a lot of stuff that were
just so absurd and cumulatively after a
while that starts to build up this
amount of anxiety in in fear and I know
a lot of people that I was talking to
especially when I was campaigning were
recounting their time during all the
lockdowns and they felt the same fear
that I did of the police which was a
really unusual I didn't want to go in
public because
honestly I I thought that I was going to
be uh it would take nothing for the
police to come for any infraction and
start arresting people for the most
bizarre things I mean we we saw a year
and a half ago two Calgary police
officers pointed a taser and threatened
to arrest a young kid who was playing
hockey out in Calgary you know in in the
next day police on guard went public
because there were law enforcement in
this country that were
just appalled by what was going on in
this country and they decided to
um
you know start becoming public and
defending what they thought was massive
breaches of the charter which they they
spend their whole careers defending the
charter and so when the police started
to push back through organizations like
police on guard or later on mounties for
Freedom when the police started to push
back
that was a sign that things had really
really gone off the rails for me so
accumulatively there were just too many
things to ignore in this Society right
now but I I think the worst thing had
for me was uh
when the Convoy was rolling through and
I wasn't part of it the statements
coming from the prime minister of this
country were
terrifying disgusting
um
just Unbecoming of a prime minister of a
country you know of people that actually
voted him in to represent and he was
acting like he was a king and it was
appalling and it's certainly not what I
joined the Canadian military to uh to
defend uh nothing of the sort
so I I just didn't know how we could
possibly call ourselves a free country
anymore if our prime minister was
allowed to get away with the rhetoric he
was getting away with
and nobody stood up until the truckers
all right well thank you and thank you
for your service thank you
okay next is uh the Convoy organizers
good afternoon Mr commissioner Bathsheba
Vandenberg for Freedom Corp and the
protesters we have no questions for Mr
marazzo thank you thank you any
re-examination
uh yes commissioner just one area um Mr
marazzo you were asked a few questions
with respect to Mr Jeremy McKenzie yes
sir um did you know of Mr McKenzie prior
to coming to Ottawa just from what I saw
on his
um social media short video so that's
all had you ever met him prior to coming
to Ottawa no
um were you aware that he was also a
former Canadian Forces member yes I was
which was one of the reasons why I
followed him
did you know that Mr Mckenzie was in
Ottawa at certain times during the
protests I did did you ever interact
with Mr McKenzie in Ottawa not
physically I phoned him on two occasions
and I had a couple of text messages with
him back and forth do you still have
those text messages I don't believe I do
I'm I'm on a different phone and they
were just basically as a uh hi it's Tom
I want to have a phone call with you
there was I've had two phone calls with
him
um during the time that I was in Ottawa
and you described I think one of the
phone calls
um what was discussed on the other one
the first one was
um
I actually uh
now that I think about it somebody that
I knew had Jeremy's contact info and
they reached out and uh said I just
wanted to meet him because to be honest
at the time I was just a fan of of what
he was doing on his podcasts I knew
there was a veteran in town
um and I kind of wanted to get his
thoughts we had a conversation
reminisced about both being posted to
cfp Petawawa but then later on the next
phone call was was when I saw the video
of him laughing about the uh what was
going on in in uh Parliament regarding
Diagon I just called him and I said tell
me everything there is to know about
Diagon because we may get asked about it
and I'm just curious
uh who gave you Mr McKenzie's phone
number
I honestly don't know that is somebody
that I I probably met when I first got
to Ottawa and I did not know any single
person I never met even James Bater
until I stepped into the conference or
into the lobby of the Ark and and he
brought me into the conference room so I
don't even know who gave me his phone
number how did you know the person might
have Mr McKenzie's phone number
um
it's a good question I I can't I the
only thing I can remember it was a
female that gave me the phone number and
I can't remember how uh they came to
have his number did you ever have any
Communications or contact with anyone
who is protesting or was in Coots
Alberta well you were in Ottawa in Coots
no I had no communication with anyone in
Kutz did you have any communication with
anyone at any other any of the other
protest locations in Canada there was
one message that somehow came through
either text or email from somebody that
was in Windsor and I don't I cannot
honestly I don't know who this person
was I know they were in Windsor
and my only reaction was whatever you do
make sure you keep at least one lane
open across that bridge so that there
can be traffic going back and forth do
you still have a copy of that message I
don't believe I do and I and because I
don't even know who the person was
um
I don't and and I to be honest I really
did not want to have contact with any
other protest around the country I had
my hands full with what I was doing in
all of these convoys and protests were
all organic they started all naturally
on their own from citizens that were
absolutely fed up with what was
happening to this Society in this
country so I was perfectly happy to have
no contact with any other protest other
than the one I was involved in during
your two conversations with Mr McKenzie
did he ever indicate to you that he was
in contact with anyone into any of the
other protest locations in Canada no sir
thank you those are my questions
okay
thank you I just have a few short
questions and just following up on on uh
one of those uh the penultimate question
you answered
all of the uh protests across the
country started organically yes
how do you know that
I didn't start to learn about the
protest until I was already in Ottawa
the only one that I knew about was in
um
I would I was at in Ottawa and then
people would just say hey there's
another protest in Windsor or like
people in the room they would just be
discussing where they had heard about
another protest somewhere else
um I had just assumed that it was very
much like this protest in Ottawa where
citizens just said we're seeing Ottawa
as an example that you can actually do
something and I and I think the Ottawa
protest was an inspiration for a lot of
people and what I've later Learned was
that there was 20 convoys around the
world and they were all saying that they
were inspired by the Convoy in Ottawa so
it seemed to be a logical conclusion to
me that there was further convoys being
inspired by Ottawa around Canada as well
so it's a it's an assumption it's an
assumption because I just wondered since
you made it as a statement that if you
had some information no sir now the what
I wanted to ask a bit more is uh the
322 trucks yes
um it wasn't clear to me what those 322
trucks were and by that I mean were
those part of the Convoy group you were
involved with or is that total trucks
um now you understand the confusion we I
was asking for a head count of all of
the trucks in the downtown so Wellington
being the the sort of center of gravity
in all of the perpendicular and parallel
streets based off of Wellington and I
had asked for for people that I was
working with daily if you could go out
and get and find out how many vehicles
we have on every every street yeah it's
the Wii I'm trying to figure out
yeah these were these were um convoys
from my understanding what happened so
for example a convoy came in from New
Brunswick and as they got into the city
they had a plan to stick together
and as soon as they got here and they
interacted with the Ottawa Police the
Ottawa Police started directing that
particular Convoy as an example in New
Brunswick and that entire Convoy got
spread out all over the place
same thing came from the West uh same
thing came from from Quebec so when they
came in here they expected they drove in
together they'd stay together but they
were spread out like Buckshot all over
all of the streets so you couldn't say
that hey the Convoy from New Brunswick
that started with 50 trucks as an
example were still confined to 50 trucks
over on a certain area they just
literally got spread out all over the
place and nobody can control that so we
were trying to organize ourselves in a
way that we could get effective
communication going between the arc and
the in every single individual truck
driver we just wanted to reduce our
Hispanic control to the Convoy leader
from New Brunswick just to talk to that
person you go share it we couldn't do
that because we were spread out
everywhere and so Communications were
near impossible for us okay maybe I
wasn't clear is it what I'm trying to
understand is
322 is that a total truck count for the
city of Ottawa all the streets or is it
those are the trucks that you had a
relationship with either because they
were the Western Convoy or one of your
organizers
at the time I believe that was just to
the downtown that did not include the uh
Parkway that didn't include 88 didn't
include arm prior that was just in the
city on that given day it was 322 trucks
that was given to me on a sticky note as
the total number of trucks in the
downtown core on that day so it wouldn't
be the trucks that your group controlled
it was a it would include the Rideau
Street uh yes trucks all of the trucks
all of the trucks and
second that I wanted to talk just
briefly about logistics and I understand
a bit better were you told when new
convoys were coming in
we would get we would get reports that
there would be a substantial Convoy
coming in from a new area and then only
to find out that that Convoy either
didn't show up or was much smaller than
what was reported and then sometimes
convoys would show up and we didn't even
know they were on their way
so the our ability to track
convoys was very very difficult
so
there's really no clear answer as to uh
to that question unfortunately but was
that your responsibility to deal with
new convoys coming in leaving aside how
much you knew about what was coming in
it would have been because then we would
have been able to as a group in the arc
discuss and figure out what the best way
to get them into a good spot would be so
where I was at the arc yes we would have
handled that movement into the City and
put them somewhere appropriate
and that continued or how long did that
continue where trucks were coming in and
you would direct them to where to go I
would say that was probably about the
first week and a half uh that I would be
involved in that kind of
um those discussions uh but my my role
started to evolve and so after I brought
in a couple of uh people one individual
who was another military officer once I
brought him in I kind of handed that off
and then I worked more
strategically with Keith and Eva to do
different things so really about a week
and a half Max
and
finally with respect to those convoys
coming in how
which convoys would you end up being
involved with and which would you not be
involved with or was that a sort of a
hazard for me only the ones that were
coming directly into the city I wasn't
involved in the ones going to arm prior
or 88 or to the parkway I was only
involved in the ones in the downtown
core
but I guess I'm trying to understand
were you somehow
have an official how would convoys know
that you will direct the Convoy rather
than the police for example we would we
would go through truck captains and we
also had people that were in the ark
that would go out and try to meet uh
with them and sort of direct create that
that contact between them and then guide
them in where we wanted them or where we
could find space for them so it wasn't
necessarily you who would go I would not
no I basically was uh I I rarely got out
of the The Arc
um not many occasions could I detach
myself from the ark and with the when
you did or your delegates do that would
it be with the police or as opposed to
uh despite or contrary to police
instructions if there was an opportunity
to involve the police we would have
always sought to do that yes
okay thank you very much thank you
so we're going to take the morning break
or the afternoon break and make the same
mistake as yesterday
um so we'll take the afternoon break 15
minutes and then we'll come back with
our Final witness for today
the commission is a missus for 15
minutes
foreign
the commission has been convenient
Jeffrey Leon co-lead
commission Council the next witness is
Patrick King and he is here with his
counsel Natasha kelbino
good afternoon Miss Calvino
thank you sure the commission is aware
my client is still facing a number of
criminal charges that are there's a
publication ban on and there's trial
dates have been set and they're
currently still before the courts Mr
King is here today as he was compelled
to by virtue of his subpoena and he is
answered to that subpoena
he invokes his protections under the
Canada Evidence Act and the Canadian
Charter of Rights and Freedoms vis-a-vis
evidence we consider we consider his
response to questions put to him to be
compelled statements or compelled
answers for any future proceeding
we are here and we understand the
parameters of the commission and there
are type quite time constraints on the
information needing to come out and
Witnesses needing to be called without
having been said late uh yesterday we
received less than 24 hours before the
hearing 127 individual items and 246
2460 individual pages of material Mr
King is anxious to respond to his
subpoena and offer his evidence he and I
have done our level best to get through
the materials there may become a point
in time where he may need some guidance
for me or we might need a bit of time to
review something because we've done the
best that we can but we were able to get
through all of it and I've would ask for
the courts or the commission's
Indulgence if we get to that point but I
hope we don't and Mr King is available
to testify thank you sir okay well thank
you uh and uh yes uh understand about
the
subpoena and the protections that's uh
obviously provided and we do appreciate
uh that it is sometimes challenging to
deal with the documentation
I think you would have a lot of sympathy
from the parties
and the commission Council so I
understand that and we've been very
accommodating as required and certainly
if there's something please
uh provide some sort of an indication
and we can sort it out thank you very
much Mr
okay go ahead thank you uh Mr King
um oh yes
Mr King will you swear on a religious
document or do you wish to affirm I'd
like I'd like to swear on a Bible please
look up
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out full name is
Patrick James King
p-a-t-r-i-c-k-h-a-m-e-s-k-i-n-g
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God absolutely
so help me God thank you
Mr King just to follow on what your your
Council has just said if at any time
during my questioning uh you need uh
time to review a document uh don't
hesitate to ask thank you and I'm going
to be asking you questions to give you
an opportunity to explain to the
commissioner your involvement in the
freedom con Convoy and also to give you
a chance to respond to some of the
evidence that's been LED before the
commission
like to start with your uh background I
understand you were born in Sault Ste
Marie so that's correct yes and how long
did you live there until I was 18. and
then where did you go
I moved out to Alberta where there was
work and I've been living in Red Deer
Alberta ever since
and uh
what sort of work do you do
oh boy uh I started out 22 years oil and
gas uh worked my way up from a roughneck
all the way up to a driller to a
Frontline supervisor to flow completions
specialist
and then I went back to University and I
got my degree in occupational health
safety environment three-year degree
from the University of University of
Alberta
from there I took a position as a health
and safety manager or sorry administer
um admin and I would look uh after
Upstream oil and gas manufactured
and from Iowa's H2S instructor uh
I drove truck out of class one driver's
license uh oversized loads
uh I also have a course
I guess uh certificate as a logistics
coordinator
and a dispatcher
thank you
now
um your Council has indicated that uh
you uh have been charged with criminal
offenses and I understand that a
condition of your your bill is that you
are not allowed to use social media is
that correct not allowed to do anything
I've had absolutely every right of a
Canadian citizen stripped of me my
freedom of speech
my freedom of protest my freedom
everything
am I correct you can't use social media
no
you are absolutely correct thank you so
I'd like to ask you about your use of
social media prior to your being charged
um uh in the latter part of February
2022 so if we can talk about the period
let's say uh 2019 to uh to March 2022
um
what kinds of social media did you use
Facebook Instagram was it
I would never go on Twitter that's a
troll site that's a joke
but Facebook and Instagram
tick tock
just to like watch it
uh YouTube
oh I had YouTube but uh around the time
that Donald Trump was being elected
um I hold and actually hold this a title
only him and myself are the only ones
who have ever been banned from using any
Google product
so I would never never promote YouTube
and um I had understand you had a large
following on social media is that
correct
uh can you define large
well how big was your following
it was big
can you define big
it was
International
it was big
okay our hundred thousand two hundred
three hundred four hundred thousand
that all depends on Facebook's
algorithms what they really say but on
my website on all my Facebook page about
half a million people thank you
yeah
um and I understand uh on Facebook if
you would uh host Live Events is that
correct
I would do podcasts and I would do media
um and I'd catch interactions
in real time
for
basically just to show it in real in
reality
and not some distorted
mainstream media view I'd show you what
it was like in the real time
and I understand in 2019 you were
involved in a convoy called United We
Roll yes sir right yes sir and uh that
was a protest over
some oil and gas issues I was a protest
over Bill c-69 and c-48 which is the
anti-pipeline and the anti-harbor
moratorium
of which when we came to Ottawa we were
successful
they reopened all the contracts after
and actually since I've been
incarcerated as of June 2022 both those
bills have been scrapped because they
have been deemed unconstitutional
and Alberta finally got our pipelines
and we're finally back to work again
and
that uh that Convoy traveled from was it
Red Deer to Ottawa all right dear
Alberta yeah we left on February 14th
and we like to deem it as the love of
our country on Valentine's Day we left
to stand up for our rights and exercise
our Democratic right to a freedom of
peaceful assembly
to exercise our Democratic right to a
freedom to protest
and to have our voices heard by the
government and who led that Convoy uh I
was in the Pilot Truck myself and
another person by the name of Angie Reed
love you Angie
uh Glenn carrot was involved along with
um he drove op 22 or op
um the fire truck
we brought a fire truck
um he was an oil and gas
um
fire suppression unit
how many vehicles were in the car
um when it got to Wellington we had
about 170 178 I believe
okay was Mr bowder involved in that
Convoy
involved in what way was he part of it
sure what was his involvement
fellow Canadian exercising his
Democratic right to protest
was he part of organizing it
nope
okay so I'd like to uh and so when you
got to Ottawa how long were you there uh
we arrived I believe it was the 19th of
February
uh we protested the 20th and 21st
and then we left that following Monday
and you went back to Red Deer yep
but I'd like to say that we left
because the politicians acknowledged why
we were there
they came out and said we hear you
we're here to support you
and we will back you and we will do
everything we can
to try and get your issues hurt
okay now I'd like to uh come to your
involvement in the uh the freedom Convoy
if I could
um
sorry
trying to keep track of the time but I
won't doesn't seem to be working the
um how did you first get in
how did you first get involved in the
the freedom Convoy
um well I'd already been social media
I'd already been doing my my stuff that
I always do and um
I had happened to see some people that
were talking about the trucking industry
and how they were about to be affected
and I know that our truckers here in
Canada are the backbone
of the economy in Canada they moved the
freight their importance is a very under
um basically they're they're forgotten
they're kind of yeah they're a trucker
truck or whatever a trucker
but I knew the importance that if you
stopped the trucking industry within
four within 72 hours
you'll be brother and brother for a loaf
of bread
and when they started to hit the truck
drivers and these guys have already been
working diligently throughout this
nonsense
um we've seen it as a a direct attack
against the Canadian economy
and not only a direct attack against the
Canadian economy but a direct attack to
truckers are the guys that want to be
left alone
they want to work in their trucks they
want to go do their job independently
leave us alone
we will create a stir we won't cause a
problem we'll pay our taxes
and
felt like they needed a voice did
somebody contact you and ask you to get
involved nope
what did you do to get involved
well um
I reached out to a few people and I
asked if they'd like to you know let's
talk about it who did you reach out to I
reached out to Chris Barber Bridget
Belton
um I reached out to
well basically them
those two and I said I'd love to have
you on my show
and I really think what you guys are
about to what you guys are wanting to do
I can be an asset because I've done this
before back in 2019 and I can help you
out in any way possible
and am I correct that you then had a
Facebook live event on January was it 13
2022. if that's the date that you have
um yes and uh as you Mr Barber Ms Belton
and I understand James bowder were all
on part of that that's correct yeah
I I gotta I gotta say there's people
involved but I've had my social media
stripped I thought all my videos gone I
can't recollect who was all there but
that sounds very close to who was there
I think there were some other people
that were involved too
Dave steenberg was one
um
well there was a cup I think
Joe Johnson was one
there's a there was a few people yet
and um
during that event you talked about the
the plan for a free Freedom Convoy with
those people who were with you
well we had thrown the idea around we
had said you guys really want to do this
and they're like yeah we should do this
I said okay
well I'll do everything I can to help
you
I'll give you the platform I'll give you
the voice I'll allow not allow but I'd
like to help you because I see what
you're doing is absolutely prophetic
finally the hard-working blue collared
people of Canada we're gonna stand up
and
was this the the first time you'd met Mr
Barber and Miss Milton yeah
and my information was you had about 3
000 viewers to that event does that
sound right if that's what you have a
number sure I never could I was never
concerned about the numbers I could have
two people in the room and it didn't
matter
and have you have you told us
why you decided to get involved with the
freedom Convoy based on uh the statement
you just made
um the reason I did it was basically I
have gone through my own issues with
these mandates and I have my own stance
and my own beliefs on these mandates and
what they're doing and now I want
everybody to remember mandate is not a
law
and they were pushing this and I finally
found people that
didn't want it pushed on them anymore
and what did you understand was the goal
of the freedom Convoy
to go and protest and exercise your
Democratic rate to a freedom of peaceful
protest to a freedom of assembly
to exercise your voice
and be heard by politicians
of your concerns and your
basically your uh
your agitation with the way things are
being
controlled and later in January the 21st
did you have another uh video stream
that involved uh Tamara litch Chris
Barber James bowder and others you call
that
you bet and I understand there was a
general discussion of what was going to
happen with the freedom Convoy
uh yes there was a discussion
um it was basically like so organic like
how are we gonna do this
who's gonna do what who's going to be
doing this who's going to be doing that
I basically was a platform
for these people to be able to
like
show who they are and by this time do
you know if anyone in that group had
contacted
um any members of a police force to uh
tell them that this was going yeah yeah
um James bouter bragged about how he had
Ottawa around his little finger
um that he had all the police and he had
all the uh connections and I was like is
that the same connections of when we did
the United We Roll and he's like yes I'm
like oh okay
um
so I reached out because I have a
rapport with PPS I am I've traveled
around Canada protesting and speaking on
public
platforms
and I've given my like I've basically
set
a good communication between
these officers so I reached out to these
officers and said we're looking at
bringing another Convoy to Ottawa
remember me and they're like oh yeah
yeah we remember you Pat
like it's good right like oh my God
you're always great when you're here
and you had some of those at least one
of those officers on your uh your stream
that night but we had a few officers
yeah yeah they were on our streams Yes
And discussing uh safety issues and
absolutely safety's number one like your
rules of the road
and all that and they knew who I was
they knew how we had organized the 2019
Convoy and they knew how absolutely
law-abiding and professional that we
were
and you traveled to
Ottawa with the Western leg of the
Convoy yes sir and what type of vehicle
were you driving uh I wasn't driving
um I had somebody who was driving a
motorhome
um and I sat passenger in the motorhome
and did you where did you join up with
the gun
well I I joined up with the main Convoy
in Calgary
now
um I uh clerk can you please bring up
hrf
four zeros one two two one
okay
this is a chronology of events that was
put together by the group of of Convoy
organizers and is now an exhibit in
these proceedings and it's a timeline of
events from their perspective and I want
to ask you about a few entries that
refer to you we can go to uh
the bottom of page two please
you can see there January 24 Chris
Barber and Tamara Leach meet
and then concerns re Pat King expressed
and uh Tamara and Chris discuss concern
about Pat king after doing a tweet with
a video making reference to bullets
Pierce agreed perhaps Pat should be sent
home but there was concern about the
trucks that brought with him
talked to Pat about the tweet and he
stated the video was an old one about an
issue on a reserve and had been heavily
edited to make it appear as though it
was regarding the Convoy
following Captain's meeting everyone
expressed concern about Pat King's
involvement and the decision was made to
talk to Pat about uh
in in the coming days and request he not
attend in Ottawa do you remember that
conversation no I do not
do you deny it happened yes
I'm not the one they're they're
discussing their concerns
that wasn't what I asked you I'm saying
do you did the conversation happen sir
no
the conversation came up of hey there's
a tweet out there I said don't worry
about it
hey can we go to uh page three of this
document
I'd like to give a little bit of an
explanation there
the explanation is I have been
absolutely harassed I've been absolutely
defamed character assassination by a
certain group
and they edit videos and they cut and
splice and they take 10 seconds here and
they
blow it out of proportion
and I've been dealing with this for
years
I will give you an opportunity I'm going
to show you some of the the videos and
I'll give you oh absolutely I can't wait
comment down there I've been waiting for
years to tell you guys how you got how
these videos are
so on page three
um
you'll see under January 26 concerns
read Pat King raised
Pat King was on the radio annoying
others had tried to pull in front of
everyone with his motorhome that was
eventually set back to the back of the
Convoy everyone was concerned about
Pat's involvement and plans were made to
talk to him in the evening when they
arrived in Thunder Bay unfortunately Pat
did not stick around but continued to
Sue Saint Marie so no one had a chance
to speak to him
nope
were you aware that that had happened I
was one of the lead vehicles from
Calgary all the way to Kenora when we
got to Kenora I was in the front
and when I got to Thunder Bay I sat for
two hours directing everybody into their
parking spots
and I told everybody that I was leaving
for Terrace Bay where I had a fueled
stop and meals and
um basically uh a rest stop for
everybody and that's where I was going
and um if you can bring up Mr Clerk hrf
50646
foreign
this is a document that's been provided
by the uh the freedom Convoy
um and it appears to be a summary of a
conversation between you and Tamara
Leach do you recall having a
conversation with Ms Leach on January
28th yep and did she request that you
not attend in Ottawa no
what was happening is we were at a rest
stop I said oh my God this has gotten
big I said I'm getting death threats and
I might need security when I'm in Ottawa
and I said this got way bigger and
I may have said this part this little
part here where about the organizing
thing but then I checked myself right
away and I realized Tamara said whoa
it's not all about you I'm like you're
right you're absolutely right
okay but that comment at the bottom
um
check your [ __ ] ego
that never happened
thank you
now you
proceeded on to Ottawa absolutely
now were you familiar with an
organization called adopt a trucker
program or a program adopt a trucker yep
and can we put up please uh com
five zero five seven one
and you'll see at the top uh can you
just go down it says adopt a trucker
campaign created by Chris Guerra do you
know Mr Guerra I do yes
and if you scroll a little further up
no sorry down
in the first line there you'll see it
says towards the end we are endorsed by
Pat King and Canada Unity
did you endorse this uh campaign
I endorse to everybody
did you endorse this campaign by adopt a
trucker uh endorsed by what do you mean
by endorsed can you explain
did you support it and publicize well
absolutely yeah
and uh
who asked you to to get involved in this
uh they were just a group that had we
had asked for people to in the Ottawa
area
um that Community who wanted to help
adopt a trucker was
you would take a trucker uh and
basically bill it like billeting
um so if you remember hockey when you go
to tournaments you would stay with a
Billet so people were offering up their
homes for truckers to come off showers
there was food and whatever they needed
in the Necessities Chris and their group
were going to look after
um the legit or the I don't know how you
say it the uh
the care and well-being of truckers who
didn't have a place to stay like didn't
have money for hotels or we were trying
to reduce costs for for lodgings and um
I take it in this sense you were in
demand because of your large social
media following to get your put your
name to things like the freedom Convoy
like the adopt attractive it happens a
lot
um a lot of people like to you know use
my platform and I'm okay with it and I
do it on purpose I I absolutely in
invite it a lot of people use my name
and my platform to
to gain
attention for their cause and I'm
absolutely 100 percent agreeable to that
I think everybody has a right to have
their say and and get their point across
and I never hold it by us
so I make sure that everybody use it
take it take my platform do what you can
and
if I can ask you
um
did you have your own group as part of
this Convoy that came with you uh I was
a road Captain for uh I believe it was
Southern
um
the northern part of Alberta
so I took on the responsibility for
those people that were part of our
initial jump from Red Deer to Calgary
and then onwards to Ottawa and Can you
estimate how many trucks were in that
group oh boy
um when we left Red Deer there was about
50 of us
but once I found out further on we tried
to get people to sign the documents and
everything in Calgary and it turned out
to be about 148
if I'm not mistaken that
I was in I was uh
responsible for I guess responsible but
taking care of their paperwork and
you arrived in Ottawa on January 29th
yes sir
uh no no we arrived in armbrier
I see and from there
I'll never forget it it was the most
greatest most elating moment of my life
where I can pass them off to Andrew and
say they're your problem now
where did you go when did you get
daughter what date I got to Ottawa that
night once everybody got to our prayer I
left and I said I'm done I'm going into
town I'm going to get my hotel room and
I went to my hotel and
what hotel did you stay at uh one of the
ones downtown Holiday Inn on I believe
Albert
I'm not sure
um
and what did you do with your vehicle I
never had a vehicle
so how did you get to the Holiday Inn
well I we dropped the motorhome off uh
at a secure location and we had people
give us a ride into the hotel
and um
uh did at one point were you involved
with the group at Confederation Park
nope
now I want to move forward uh uh
to
February 12th
and on that date did you learn that an
agreement had been reached with the
mayor of Ottawa to move trucks out of
residential areas and on to Wellington
Street I heard that that was the plan
and
who did you hear that from
just from other Road captains and people
that were
um
I don't know people who thought they had
a role in this and were a voice and
I could make calls I guess if you say
like make calls like uh
they were told something and passed it
on to the block captains and then the
block captains would pass it on to their
drivers and
and so
did you agree with the
bad idea sure
whatever you want
I was here to help in any way I need
they needed me
uh Mr clerk could you uh put up a video
at com
50881
and I understand this is a video you
published on YouTube
I don't have YouTube 13. I wouldn't have
put it on YouTube I don't have YouTube
well let's see if it's you
other people can post things on YouTube
Hey guys
we got a quick one out here for you as
well right now
just been informed that while the
counter protesters were involved there
were groups of them going around giving
letters out saying that the Convoy needs
to move they made an agreement it's a
lie it's a lie break break break break
break break break
get this out everywhere get this to
every person out there just come down
from the top they've gone out and spread
letters to the truckers truckers and
your trucks do not move do not leave
there is no letter going out there's no
letter going around this was part of the
counter protesters [ __ ] what they did
it's all a lie do not leave Ottawa do
not back your trucks out do not leave
the residential areas you are good to go
stand your ground that that's it that's
all stand your ground stand your ground
hold the line you guys
counter protesters went out they passed
out letters they acted like they knew
what was going on they acted like they
knew what was happening and they acted
like participants in this they weren't
it was part of the counter protest do
not believe it ladies and gentlemen the
more people that I find in these chats
that I see these rumors that are saying
that everybody was told to leave
everybody was told to walk and uh that
they're leaving then when I catch your
little chaps and the conversations as I
go through them I will be balking I will
be blocking you you will be banned from
the page I'm done with the rumors I'm
done with the [ __ ] everybody needs
to get this message out right away
do not read that letter that letter is a
false flag letter they're trying to use
the counter protesters to push you out
Hold the Line
Hold the Line
thank you 100 do
now do you remember
uh I remember that there was a lot of
stuff going on at that moment
um we were
you said this was February 12th
I believe so I believe that this was
also at the same time that the community
had organized their own counter protest
um actually miss Catherine McKinney the
council member of Ottawa
encourage people to come out and count
to protest
and
they were leaving leaflets and and
things on trucks so we couldn't
determine whether or not these were true
documents or not
um so I put out this post
because it wasn't confirmed and there
was no letterhead there was no signature
there was no notoriety of who it came
from
so I would assume that if the city
council or Ottawa
um was going to make this leaflet and
pass it out somebody would have put
their name on it
to give it some clout to give it some
importance
um later on we found out that these were
asked to move and then we said okay
thank you Mr clerk can you put up hrf
four zeros one two eight five
now
um I understand this was the the
uh
leaflet that was passed around you see
it stated February 12th from Tamara
Leach
speaks to a freedom manifest and has the
freedom Convoy symbol on it and uh
can you uh scroll
please
and you'll see there
the last two paragraphs it talks about
repositioning the trucks and the plan to
start repositioning on Monday to
consolidate the process protest now that
the document you saw I never saw this
note
but do you remember what the document
looked like that you did see I was uh a
leaflet from the mayor or something like
that
I might be confused on this
um
I never I've never seen this
okay
now um
while you were in Ottawa
were you involved in a with a group of
trucks that went out to the airport
yep
and you did slow rolls around the
airport we went for a ride yet
well how long were you at the airport
an hour two hours and were you doing
slow rolls around the airport
well we were abiding by the law by the
rules of the road we did the speed limit
we did not impede emergency traffic
we just went for a cruiser what was the
purpose in your going
we're bored
I'm sorry we were bored and that you
found interesting
oh for a ride to see what Ottawa was
like to see well you spent two hours at
the airport seeing what Ottawa was
well let's see what the airport was and
just go for a drive
we're bored it was cold
should we recall uh speaking to Tom
marazzo before he went I've talked to
Tom many of times and did he have
somebody accompany you to
make sure what you were doing went uh
okay no
not that I know
and did you um by doing what you were
doing there how many trucks were there
I don't know all of them
all of what all of the trucks that were
there I don't know how many came with
you they're all cooked they're all
passenger vehicles they're all I see
cars and there was never a commercial
vehicle with us okay and how many
commercial uh cars came with you
I don't know if 30 40 Maybe
and uh while you were doing what you
were doing at the airport
would you agree with me that you slowed
down other vehicles from accessing the
airplane no I do not
Claire's uh when you're going to the
airport there's two lanes
when you go into arrivals and departures
there's two lanes
we used one lane we were in the one lane
and there was always a lane open
so anybody who wanted to go in they
could have used the other lane
uh thank you Mr Claire can you put up
hrf
to
six zeros eight three
and this is again sorry can you scroll
the other way you'll see it's on the
freedom Convoy letterhead February 17th
reaffirming its commitment to peaceful
demonstration and if we go to look at
the second paragraph We do not support
any form of hateful rhetoric divisive
comments or calls for violence we
explicitly condemn anything of that
nature so let us be clear we are a
peaceful and lawful demonstration we
have heard about inappropriate comments
being made by Pat King Pat King does not
speak for us we expressly condemn any
talk of violence from him or others that
King has the right like every other
Canadian citizen to protest peacefully
do you remember seeing this
never saw it but I heard about it I knew
about it and uh
do you know uh what they're referring to
when they say well the reason is is and
I'm going to say it straight up and I'm
going to have to give a little bit of a
brief background to this
I've been chasing the government and
exposing a lot of stuff
of the overreach the financial and
economic hardships that have been
happening
um
I have in my possession the document of
the non-disclosure agreement between a
young Juvenile and a certain specific
Member of Parliament
and when doing so exposing also the 42
billion dollar infrastructure project
that was stolen out of Alberto's hands
and handed over to the Chinese
government
um and the
the implementation of Chinese soldiers
on Canadian soil
I have been absolutely harassed and
degraded and defamed and
um discredited and character
assassinated
and these guys are getting attacked
because of my because of me
so
when they put this out I get it
they had to push me to out and look at
everybody and you know we don't want
anything to do with packing I actually
absolutely encouraged it
100 percent
put it out there that I don't have
anything to do with this put it out
there GoFundMe wouldn't release their
funds GoFundMe directly contacted them
and said we're not going to release your
funds
of Patrick Kings involved so do you know
this is how much Target
like how much they're out to
to make sure that I everything that I
touch has ruined so do you know what
they're referring to and they say uh
talk of violence uh inappropriate
comments
did you talk about violence not at all
did you make any inappropriate comments
not at all wow maybe I'm kind of a
hothead
I kinda
talk too much sometimes and that's I get
that honestly by my mom she's got the
gift of the gab
you recall that in Ottawa there was a
lot of honking right
oh yeah
and uh
were you involved in that uh honking
wow I didn't have a vehicle there I
didn't have a truck what horn can I honk
and
what did you think about it did you
agree with it encourage it wish it
didn't happen
do what you want to do I'm sorry people
are free to do what they wanted to do
okay
um could you uh put up uh cleric please
uh c-o-m
-50851
remember
I haven't been able to sleep for 10 days
can you try starting it again it's kind
of funny I'm not gonna lie remember
these people haven't been able to sleep
for 10 days okay
it's kind of funny I'm not gonna allow
I'm not gonna lie it's pretty hilarious
that you of course and uh that's that's
what you thought that it was hilarious
that people couldn't sleep
um
I look at it now and like no it wasn't
funny
but if you know my Persona and my
character and the way I
show myself I laugh all the time
likes a joke laugh it off it's kind of
one of my biggest mottos
um and I tend to I tend to laugh when
I'm nervous
but at that point it was kind of
it was funny you see we've been locked
down for two years
and people are complaining that they
heard horns for 10 days
do you remember what we went through for
the last two years what's a little bit
of horns for 10 days
and uh
did you uh make any statements on social
media to the effect that you wanted to
form a new government and that you and
the truckers would take power no
and did you
make any statements that uh in a video
that we will be the new government we
will just take power and share it
together
say that again we will be the new
government we will just take power and
share it together you have a video that
I can reference I have a video no I'm
asking you if you said that on a video I
hate politics I hate government
so why would I want to be the new
government
yeah I'd like to show you uh
now a
compilation of some of your your videos
oh I'm ready for this one produced by uh
Canada and edited by a 45 million dollar
contract that Trudeau and his liberal
government paid for it to do this
has been played over and over and over
well I don't think you've seen this
compilation it all was produced by the
uh Ontario or the Ottawa Police Service
it's Ops
407967 can you please uh start it and uh
stop it after the the first video
Trudeau someone's gonna make you
catchable that one day to the rest of
this government someone's gonna [ __ ]
do you then
you sons of [ __ ] the only way
I know this video like there's no
tomorrow and what do you have to say
edited and spliced and fit to make the
media their narrative
to show it in a in in a negative context
so when you hear that I had just got
kicked out of the airport I got denied
my flight because I wasn't vaccinated
after being told that I had been allowed
to fly I had a 72-hour window and
there's a video before this like this is
so ridiculous take 10 second clips and
characterize Somebody by it but I'm
waiting to defend myself on this one
and what I stated in this and I never
said you're going to get shot I'm never
going to never said that I said you're
going to catch a bullet
because as
we know mental health is a big thing in
Canada
it's kind of limelighted you have mental
health issues
one day somebody's gonna have a
breakdown
and if you push People Too Far
especially denying them their flight you
never know who you're going to get and
that person might have a mental
breakdown
and what they're doing with their
restrictions and these mandates which
are not laws
they're going to
get that wrong person
and I said that because you're lucky it
was me that day
because I would have never acted on that
but
if it had been somebody else and there's
a lot of people that are upset lost a
lot and don't give a crap
they're going to have a mental breakdown
now that was only a clip from the the
video
um can you put up a com50898
and this is a transcript that was
prepared of the the full video
I want to say I just like to uh like
give you a little bit of brief
description to this um
you ever get an argument with your
parents and you get mad and you say
things you don't wish you said like you
you like you regret saying that that's
one of my moments yeah it was
inappropriate yeah I should never have
said it but it was said
okay can you put up the document please
all right
and you see there's the part that we saw
the only way that I'm going to say it
out loud the only way that this is going
to be solved is with Bullocks no here
okay so this one someone's going to kept
make you catch a bullet one day that's
one video
what you've done is you've put another
video in there and said this part
and this part needs some major Clarity
okay because it's been edited and and
fit to make the narrative out like I'm
some kind of loony and radical but what
it was is can I just uh stop you for a
second uh I want to just go through this
whole statement and then I'll let you
speak to it
um
if we go down to the next uh paragraph
you might want to change your name to
Ishmael or drop a bunch of chains down
the stairs and call yourself chong ching
ching chang
now you want to say the Indian culture
and everything the natives culture is a
disgrace it is 100 percent every person
who was born here in Canada and North
America you are Indigent you are
indigenous people don't realize that if
you were born of the land you are
indigenous of the land it's called
depopulation of the Caucasian race or
the Anglo-Saxon and that's what the goal
is is to depopulate the Anglo-Saxon race
because they are ones with the strongest
Bloodlines they are ones with the
strongest Bloodlines they are ones with
one with the strongest bloodlines and
then going down to the bottom
I think I'm going to have a big
gathering at my house
and I'm going to film it you're right
cops will get shot
now did you make a video to that effect
nope
no I uh
can we go down so I can reference each
sentence in this because I I've been
dying to get this out did you make any
of those statements can we go down so I
could defend that first answer you have
four if not five
videos that you've transcribed
one from over four years ago that's part
of this
um and they're taking out of context
okay I just so I need to defend myself
I'll let you talk but just let me answer
my question are those statements that
you made those are statements that were
said
in a long line of online pres online
podcasts
okay that go along with the evidence or
go along with the topic that I was
discussing
now all right can we scroll down please
thank you no uh sorry I apologize
a little bit more please
uh right to the very beginning number
one all right so we say Trudeau
someone's gonna make you catch a bullet
one day that's the airport incident
that's where I was mad I was denied my
flight after being told I Can Fly And I
got stuck in Toronto Pearson
International Airport of which I re I'm
absolutely regret saying that I was mad
um
the next one
um the only way that I'm going to say it
out loud the only way that this is going
to be solved is with bullets
that is taken directly out of contact
gone context 100 what was the content
the context was if you are Canadian and
you want to exercise your political
right to stand up and be freedom of
protest and peaceful assembly
would you take it
or are you going to allow it to become
bullets
because if we keep going on the way
we're going to be going on
that's a possible end game it's a
prediction and you say at the end a
massive Revolution on a huge scale if
not yeah things are wrong in this
country massively wrong and what about
and this is me just interpreting what
I'm seeing from an outside person saying
this is what's going to happen if you do
not make these governments be held
accountable for what they're doing and
the next step we go down uh you might
want to change your name to Ishmael drop
a bunch of chains down the stairs it's
actually change not chains
and I said that because there was a
thesis document put out I believe it was
in 20
2019 about the foreign economy the
foreign influence in our Canadian
economy of a foreign government
purchasing all our resources
and the thesis guys were telling you hey
something's wrong like you guys know
that we're being bought out you know
we're being infiltrated our economy is
being destroyed
and the comment was because it was China
Chinese influence and the next paragraph
uh the next paragraph Was and I had to
say this in my court they use this in my
bail hearing the Indian culture and
everything the NATO's culture is a
disgrace never once was said it was said
what I said prior to that is what the
Canadian government has done to the
First Nations people is an absolute
disgrace
and the way they're treated and the way
they're ridiculed and not given the the
appropriate means to even have water
it's a disgrace and the next paragraph
and the next paragraph the depopulation
oh this is a good one so there was a
time uh the Prime Minister the president
of
iranjad was his name walked into a
meeting at the United Nations
with a bunch of binders and he dropped
them down on the podium
and he started bringing out everything
that who was involved in 9 11.
and and people started scattering out
and his words were we're not going to
kill you with bullets we're not going to
blow you up with bombs we're going to
breed you we're going to get rid of the
Anglo-Saxon Rays because you think
you're the proudest bloodline
and we are going to breed you out we are
going to flood your borders with
immigrants we are going to
infiltrate your education infiltrate
your uh your politics
but you got to understand like the
things that were going on around the
world I'm seeing these I bring them up I
show the video and that's what it is
okay can we go back to Ops four
zeros7967
um and can you pick it up where uh you
left off after the the first video
what the [ __ ] confusing
you sons of [ __ ] the only way that
and I'm gonna say it out loud the only
way that this is going to be solved is
with bullets
and yeah I said it that's the only way
something's gonna happen a massive
Revolution on a a huge scale you might
want to change your uh your name to
Ishmael
or drop a bunch of chains down the
stairs and call yourself chanch
[Laughter]
you want to say oh the Indian sculpture
and everything the NATO's culture is a
disgrace it is 100 every person who was
born here in Canada in North America you
are indigenous
people don't realize that if you were
born of the land you are indigenous of
the land it's called depopulation of the
Caucasian race or the Anglo
and that's what the goal is is to
depopulate the Anglo-Saxon race
because they are the ones with the
strongest bloodlines
they are the ones with the strongest
bloodlines
they are the ones with the strongest
bloodlines
and we'll leave it at that because then
we get into a whole different topic but
but now this year this year alone I
think I'm gonna have a big gathering at
my house just for that and I'm gonna
film it
yeah right cops will get shot
very well edited congrats those are my
questions thank you
okay
uh first uh
or cross-examination the Convoy uh
organizers please
good evening Mr commissioner Bathsheba
Vandenberg Council for Freedom Corps and
protesters we have no questions for Mr
King thank you thank you
next the Ottawa residents Coalition
please
foreign
my name is Paul champ I'm a lawyer for
the Ottawa Coalition of residence and
businesses of Ottawa well you guys are
the guys that called my bank account
uh uh that's still frozen after nine
months
that's all just give us a call
now you took my kids college tuition
I hope you're proud
we're talking about the funds in your
Alberta Treasury Branch oh you're very
familiar with my bank account there you
go
how many e-transfers how many
e-transfers did you get into that
account Mr King all of them
so uh people across Canada are donating
for your children's child's education
fund that's what it was for no
okay you were raising money uh for the
freedom Convoy trip is that right for
myself
okay
if people wanted to donate they could
okay and so and they donated up to a
hundred thousand dollars too is that
right no
how much I have no idea you don't know
so you don't know if it was a hundred
thousand dollars or not I have no idea
you got my bank accounts Frozen okay
well you can check the court records you
raised a hundred thousand dollars for
yourself wow
then give me it back so I can live no
I
will ask you to be removed if this
doesn't stop
you've been very good so far please
I'm sorry sir
and I I don't think you're helping just
answer the questions and we'll get
through sure properly this isn't
supposed to be a show it's supposed to
be a questions and answers and I realize
you feel
quite
I apologize strongly about things I
apologize I did take that wrong
yeah myself as well uh Mr King I'd just
like to ask you about the 2019 United We
Rule
um Convoy you you've told us that was a
successful protest
it was you you uh organized a number of
people uh you and others Mr Carrot and
others you got a number of trucks
together including semi-truck trailers
you came across Canada you got a lot of
media all the way across Canada came
through Ottawa and generated a lot of
attention to your issues correct
yeah yeah a successful protest 100 yeah
then the uh with Mr Trudeau's
involvement in the Freedom of
Information where he sent two thousand
anti-protesters to come slash our tires
right
so for the freedom Convoy protest in
February uh why
did you stay for so long
why yeah because I exercised my
Democratic right to freedom of peaceful
protest and freedom of assembly
because I'm Canadian and I have that
Democratic right
now Mr King uh where did you you said
you stayed at the Holiday Inn is that
right yeah for like four or five days
yeah and then where did you stay we
didn't get no okay that's we had heard
Ms Belton testified she thought you're
staying in a hotel out of downtown uh I
guess the horns were getting to you
downtown is that why you changed hotels
not at all why did you change hotels
well because your community decided to
pull the pin on lodgings and hotels for
people and we were told they were no
longer going to allow us to rent a room
because the community had
basically
told the hotels if you support these
guys and give them a room you're going
to be in a lot of trouble and that's
from the manager of the Holiday Inn who
told me that so I'm sorry Mr King we
can't give you another room I said
that's fine I get it no problem
it sucks to be you guys because you're
making a killing and the money that you
guys are generating from all of us being
here it's probably the
best for you guys to recoup those funds
after two years of being shut down
uh why don't you go to the arc hotel or
the Sheraton Hotel or the Swiss Hotel
there was lots of rooms there I didn't
need a motel
uh and who paid for your hotels while
you're in Ottawa Mr King me
pardon me me
with the donations that you got to make
the trip
sure okay
that's are you speculating that or no
I'm asking you're the person I'm asking
it didn't sound like a question it was a
question are you answering yes that's
how you yeah yeah me yeah I pay for it
sorry paid for it so I apologize you got
donations to come here and split those
donations that you paid for the hotel
rooms that's right and there's other
people uh who were supporters of you who
you also assisted in uh getting funds to
pay for their hotel room so I conference
you were raising money to help others as
well correct when I got money donated I
gave it away absolutely and uh you were
also working with Mr Barber and the
others about getting funds for other
people that you helped bring to Ottawa
is that right
uh and what do you mean like funds uh
like to pay for hotels for other people
who are supporters anybody who needed
help or anybody who needed money I was
open and making money come talk to me I
would help you and you would sometimes
connect with Mr Barber and Ms Leach to
see if they could assist funds as well
is that right well I barely suck Tamara
and Chris
you communicated regularly with Mr
Barber throughout maybe text messages
yeah through text I never saw them okay
they were busy man these guys were like
wow
what they had going on over there you
can have it did Mr Barber Miss Leach
ever talk to you about uh trying to get
the truckers to lay off their horns uh
they asked me to see what I can do and I
said yeah I'll do what I can
and that's when I put the post out I
believe the
they had been threatened with some
injunction or something I still wasn't
very familiar at the time but
um
they said do what you can to get the
guys to stop and I did I put out a post
I said stop honking horns and actually
um as part of my evidence package that
uh there's two videos
one of the videos actually has me on the
street on that evening on Wellington
stating listen you wouldn't know what
you have no idea where I'm at
and it was the most quietest most Eerie
eerie
place because there was no more horns
anymore
now with respect to the slow roll around
the airport or to the airport
um I take it that was that was just
you're bored we heard that but it was
also a little bit of a message to the
city of Ottawa is that right that the
vehicles could move and move to other
areas of the city if if provoked you go
uh was it why did you choose that day
was it because the police had just done
the raid at the con at uh Coventry nope
you made it down to Coventry a number of
times is that right every day every day
you were a popular figure there I gather
I wouldn't say popular is where I went
and ate breakfast
and how um you were there often uh do
you know where the fuel was coming from
into Coventry
from grateful Patriots and Canadian
citizens that were donating it
sure but like can you give us any
specific names of those grateful
Patriots
Joe Smith number one I have no idea
you have no idea you don't want to
answer
I don't remember names I meet people all
day long constantly
um
I don't remember names
if you have a specific person in
particular that you want to give me his
name and I'll let you know if I know him
or if I converse with them
are you talking to guys that got
arrested after they were told they
weren't going to be arrested that were
running fuel you knew some of those guys
yeah you knew some of those guys
personally yeah they were very upset
well look what you did you told them
we're not going to arrest not you sorry
they were told they weren't going to get
arrested right and then they left and
they got pulled over down the road and
got arrested or got tired got got a fine
for
for whatever and and I remember that
night because
the Ops came in and like tried to flex
or whatever and because these guys
didn't know what was going on they asked
me to come down and I said I'm not
coming down there not a chance but I
went down the next morning to make sure
the calm cool heads had prevailed
and on that morning that's when the RCMP
Special Response task force well they
were staying at the Marriott and they
came down one of the officers came down
to me said Pat you're not hot miked or
anything and I said no I don't got
nothing on why who are you and he it's
he
introduced himself and he said I just
want you to know about last night that
wasn't our call
um and I want you to know that the RCMP
we
met with legal and lawyers
and that we are not going to do this to
you guys because they can't give us a
justification
of why we should be
evicting your arresting people so I'm
sorry for what happened last night I
said well what do you mean by that he's
like well we fought with lawyers
to give us justification
of why we should be arresting these
people they couldn't give us a clear
answer
so we're leaving I said you're leaving
he says yeah we're going to Windsor
and they went to Windsor to break down
whatever was happening at the border so
you were in communication with people
who were involved at the Windsor
blockade no
uh so you talk to people who a police
officer was leaving all the places
going they were leaving Ottawa right
because the lawyers couldn't give them a
justification of
harassing people right and they said
we're not going to break the law right
so they the whoever is in charge of them
sent them to Windsor so uh the people
who are got tickets that night uh and
arrested were upset uh you were upset by
that and that's one of the reasons why
you organized the slow roll around the
airport of Ottawa is that not at all no
what did you do because you're upset
about that
I went and made sure everybody was calm
and cool and everybody was understanding
like these guys got a job to do
understand that yeah that was rude that
was ignorant and just be more cautious
when you're
dealing with police now Mr King you
obviously could not and did not know
everyone who was in Ottawa during that
protest right no there was millions of
people well thousands anyway for sure
hundreds of thousands
let's not undersell it there's a lot of
people here
uh I'll just this will agree to disagree
there weren't hundreds of thousands but
um
you uh it was a bit of a dangerous
situation with all those people downtown
would you agree dangerous in what way
well dangerous you don't know what
people might have in their trucks you
don't know what they might do they're
very upset they're very angry uh was
that a dangerous situation for downtown
not at all okay I met the most loving
most caring most loving people Canadian
citizens everywhere you went you were
getting hugs you were getting handshakes
and well then why nobody was violent why
did you need security then yourself it
was so dangerous that you yourself
needed security isn't that right because
the liberal left trolls were threatening
my life okay so that was dangerous right
for me just for you you're the only
person in downtown Otto who's at risk is
that right actually I was um
the the most highly protected
person in Ottawa because we had I think
they had delegated eight police officers
to follow me around everywhere so Mr
King we've heard evidence that uh many
federal uh elected officials the mayor
of Ottawa had received uh death threats
uh we've heard evidence that someone was
actually arrested with with uh Firearms
who was coming to Ottawa uh who had been
making threats about you have a record
of that do you have a good bet I'm
asking the questions Mr King sure so
um
but you would agree with me that it was
probably a dangerous situation for
elected officials in Ottawa it was a
dangerous place for us
people were dropping marbles from
high-rises
they were throwing eggs citizens of
Ottawa were threatening to run us over
you yourself said that someone who is
maybe stressed out because of lockdowns
and so forth uh might be compelled to to
shoot Mr Trudeau so you understood and
recognized that that was a risk right
that was months before the Convoy also
but everyone was all uh they were all
settled down by the time the Convoy came
and there was no threats to anyone I've
never seen anything more loving and
peaceful in my life it was woodstocks so
the only person who's at risk in Ottawa
was Pat King all the other threats to
anyone else in Ottawa were all fake is
that right I don't know I can't speak on
those you know my lawyer has been given
death threats and bomb scares
because she represents me do you know
that my friends have been their children
have been threatened
because of from Ottawa do you know that
and I hate to say this but
this town is full of a bunch of people
who really don't like
people who speak out
I I don't I disagree uh Mr King Ottawa
has uh dozens of large protests many
much larger than the one that you
organized every single year I've been
here I'm not sure that was a question
um
so
well Mr commissioner
can I just I just note
Mr commission I'll just know for the
record that the people of Ottawa got one
morning in this proceeding we've had a
week of all of these Convoy organizers
given a full platform to say whatever
they want the people in Ottawa respect
the right to protest and these folks are
getting their time to tell say
everything they want from you can I say
one sorry I'm sorry just I'm going to
stop this you'll you'll get yeah I I
please
could you could you ask uh have him I'm
going to take a break while you remove
the person
disgusting Our Lives treated the
commission is
I ever like
this
foreign
okay
it's unfortunate event but if we can now
get back and complete the today's
proceedings
next is the Ottawa Police Service
the Ottawa Police Service has no
questions thanks very much commissioner
okay the Ontario Provincial Police
the opp has no questions thank you
commissioner
a council for uh
former Chief slowly
we don't have any questions thanks
the government of Canada
thank you commissioner Mr King my name
is Kathleen Tanner and I'm Council for
the government of Canada I just have one
short area of questions based on some a
video that have been played earlier for
you and it was a video that I believe
had been recorded on February 12th after
some information had come through about
some pamphlets or some letters that have
been passed around to the drivers and
you had made a video recording telling
other drivers that it was a lie that it
was fake news to hold the ground stand
the line
and later on in that video and if you'd
like we could could bring it up or we
could just walk through it I understand
that you referenced the the information
that's at stake there is
um a letter which mentions Miss Leach's
name and later on in in that video you
mentioned that Miss Leach would never do
something like this and you knew her
well and you had good Communications and
so this wasn't going to be something
coming from her
so my question is did you have any
meetings with the city of Ottawa while
you were in by the way no I did not and
were you aware of any meetings that Miss
Leach or other representatives of the
Convoy may have had with anybody from
Ottawa no I tended to stay away from
that
and prior to releasing this video did
you make any attempts to reach out to
miss Leach to confirm whether or not
this letter may or may not be accurate
I may or may have and I believe that we
were all kind of confused we didn't know
if it was legitimate
um so there was a
the initial all like this is not a true
statement to they
um they vetted the document and then we
rechanged their statements said okay
so I guess my question is and then
earlier when you were speaking to my
friend from commission Council you had
said you were uncertain about the
truthfulness of that document and that's
why you would release the video right
because I would I would assume that if
um these people are gonna put these
Letters Out uh and that they're coming
from a delegated person that has like a
a higher position there would be a name
or a signature or a
that emblem representing who who it's
from and from my knowledge it we didn't
know where it came from so so I guess
that's my question is is it a pattern
for you to release videos like this
without first confirming the
authenticity of the information before
that I would act without knowledge
but uh there is an absolute disconnect
between myself and their
their rooms that they had
um
and I acted alone okay that's all my
questions thank you and thank you Mr
commissioner okay thank you
the next is the ccla
uh
uh good evening commissioner and Mr King
uh I'm my name is Eva kraftevsk on
behalf of the Canadian civil liberties
Association and I don't have any
questions for Mr King thank you
thank you
now the Democracy funder citizens for
freedom
Mr commissioner Antoine Dai For citizens
for Freedom no questions for this
witness thank you thank you wow uh okay
uh
and I've now I apologize I've forgotten
your name uh Council for uh
Mr King any questions anything that
concerns you about the documentation or
want to put to your client thank you no
Natasha Calvino for Mr king I don't have
any questions for the commission okay
sorry I forgot your names I apologize
for that
okay any re-examination
nope
okay well that uh completes your
evidence uh uh Mr King and uh you're
free to go can I ask for one thing
um there's some evidence that I had
given to the commission
that um
needed to be brought out that I would
appreciated that it got to the public
and they got to see it
uh I think that that should have been
done when I think at the end of the
examination now I'm not sure at this
point if there's something in particular
you want to say that of course go ahead
because uh it's uh
despite what some may say we're just
trying to get at the bottom of olive
yeah absolutely and I want to show the
the Canadian citizens in the light that
they need to be shown and and how caring
and compassionate towards the city of
Ottawa we actually were
and how we look these videos will
like I said these what I've been shown
as racist and all this stuff
um and taken out of context nobody ever
showed the positives
and that was the police officers who
were right with us saying thank you
um there was residents that were saying
thank you
the community in a whole the community
of Ottawa that came together
and respected us and understood that we
hear you
um
I have nothing against the city of
Ottawa it's not who we're here to talk
to I understand that people were
I guess
felt that we were here targeting them
that wasn't the case and to Auto
audience to people who live here to the
city council members to the police and
all that
we weren't bad people sir
we were Canadian citizens who
we've shown the Canadian pride and we're
nice and we are good people we're good
people well if it's any consolation
there's been evidence uh about uh the
the various uh uh Convoy participants on
all these issues there are more
witnesses coming we're just trying to
put out a full picture
I'll weigh it all at the end and uh
the evidence will be there and
I'm going to make some findings and
prepare a report thank you very much but
uh there are others coming so uh with
that I will adjourn for the day uh we
have a big day tomorrow there will be uh
I think it'll go a little later even
than most
I hope we'll have no
difficulties tomorrow
because that just slows up the process
um so but we'll be back tomorrow at 9
30.
the commission is adjourned Johnny